[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
questions
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
January inviton Zay the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over in fact the most
wonderful time of the year has really
just begun
I know he loves Todd of Steel and you
could just see the inspiration in fact
he's playing once again Vicon say starts
the new year as the center of the chess
Universe this year as host of the 85th
Tata steel chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps with eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is playing for win and he
has to start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge with the top half of the
CrossFit the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata type Anish is taking
down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps elderbeck
just playing a modern brilliancy what a
performance the Dutch referred to Tata
steel as The Wimbledon of chess for 85
years in running this tournament
continues to be steeped in Prestige and
Legacy and does so again in this
welcoming Little Dutch Mound by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
[Music]
happy Sunday everybody the playing haul
over in like on Zay the picturesque
Village which every year plays hosts to
the one and only Tata steel chess
tournament welcome ladies and gentlemen
to round eight a beautiful way to round
off an action-filled weekend I'm your
host Grandmaster Daniel narditsky and
alongside me today once again
International Master yvanka Huska Ivanka
I guess it's afternoon for you lucky you
good afternoon
good afternoon good morning should I say
Tanya
um no it was a it's a beautiful day
today and yesterday it was even better
so much action it was such a great
exciting round of chess
it was indeed the world champion
redeemed himself with the win Abdus the
torab continued his unbelievable
performance but speaking of the world
champion I mean it is his tough
tournament has been well publicized and
he is back on 50 and so the press found
a good opportunity to catch up to Magnus
after his win over Richard Deport and
asked him if he ever got concerned when
Richard started throwing the kitchen
sink toward magnus's King let's listen
in the world champion
now of course I was
um concerned but um I was mainly focused
on trying to
to review this attack and I didn't feel
feel as though
um
I didn't feel as though I should be
losing as as I said I mean I I
immediately understood that his idea is
if not 100 sound and very very close to
it but it also didn't feel like I should
be in major trouble just a nice
complicated game and you know for two
guys who are on a minor score that's not
a it's not a bad thing to
um
to have so I think we both welcome that
and yeah later on I was just thinking
you know double checking stuff but I
thought okay if I had made it I get made
it I don't see how
yes I'm sure Magnus would be totally
okay with getting mated and getting onto
a minus three score I wish I could just
know when my opponents sacrifice my 2740
rated opponent sacrifices are on sound
but long story short the world champion
wins Yobe we had a pretty decisive day
yesterday frog continues his incredible
run thus far I mean wherever you look
you've got young players dominating the
field
yeah absolutely and uh Prague isn't the
only Talent shining that we also have
nordebec Abdul satorov who is just
really steamrolling through his games
he's just playing such impressive
perfect chess and yesterday I have to
say it was a real slug fast there you
can see so many decisive games
you also had a seven in fifth hour 15
minute game between Parham and Fabiano a
very frustrating finale for The American
Grand Master as he manages to come back
from a worse position and was on the
cusp of winning and that affects the
tournament standings directly because
that means another book abducatorov
maintains a one-point lead over the rest
of the opposition with a win Fabiana
caruana would have sunk his teeth into
clear second place as it stands there is
a big entourage of players on four and a
half out of seven one point behind Notre
back one thing is totally clear Yogi
when you look at this which is that
notorbeck cannot fall asleep at the
wheel
no absolutely not you know one point
lead is not that significant especially
when you are playing the world's finest
players and as you mentioned there are
plenty of players on his tails and uh
take a look at who's in seventh place
Magnus Carlson don't write him off he is
the king of making comebacks and someone
else who's also on three and a half
points is Dean Lauren he also needs to
get motoring because remember he has a
very important world championship match
happening in April
and let's remember how he finished the
Madrid candidates starting in similarly
slow fashion but finishing with several
wins and that is how he qualified to
challenge Jan and apomishi so he has not
finished with this tournament just yet
let's review today's pairings of course
no Rebecca justotorov he has the white
pieces after a win with black against
Eric icy yesterday and he faces yet
another difficult task in an on formal
of honoronian who sits on plus one
Magnus Carlson has black against Fabiano
caruana I am very much looking forward
to that matchup any rematch from a
previous World Championship is going to
be one to watch but the other games
obviously nothing to sneeze at either
I know just look at the top Wesley sow
against ding Loren I mean that is going
to be huge and then we have Anish Gary
who is also in second place he will be
facing the young Vincent climber I mean
even those players who are not currently
on form they are looking to score some
points so anything can happen
especially that goes for Wesley who's
won two in a row and who faces a dingley
grand who has struggled especially in
the opening so with the white pieces
let's see if the American Grandmaster
can really put uh the pedal to the metal
and uh score a hat-trick third victory
in a row which would be insane in a
tournament of this caliber the time
control if you are not aware of the time
control Where Have You Been Just Kidding
we won't make you feel bad time control
is the most generous of any annual
tournament the players have 100 minutes
for 40 moves then after move 40 they get
50 minutes for the next 20 moves and
when move 60 is executed finally they
get 15 more minutes added to their clock
and there is a 30 second increment for
move one so each time each player makes
a move 30 seconds are added to their
clocks we've still had our fair share of
time scrambles but I'm proud to report
that nobody has lost on time just yet
maybe that'll change
today okay well it is 7 58 here that
means it is is it 158
in the Netherlands Yogi I'm not very
good with time zones I think it's 158.
it is 158 and uh do you have to remember
that time control means that these
players are playing marathons each day
you know they are pushing themselves to
the limits and as you mentioned
yesterday we saw a seven hour game I
mean we're gonna see how the players
react now because will they be tired
will we see blunders that are
uncharacteristic and there we can also
see Lavon aronen getting ready and I
think someone else who's getting ready
is Anna Maria Kazarian who is getting
ready to just hit that dong right
yes somebody else a distinguished guest
hits the gong at the start of the round
that is a Tata steel tradition and
annamaya Kazarian she is a women's uh
International Master she is a very
distinguished streamer and uh she is
should be well known to those people
watching on this bright and early hour
or if you're in Europe in on this lovely
Sunday afternoon and Amaya is about to
sound the gong and the games will be off
and I will be keeping a particularly
close eye on Parham and Fabiano let me
tell you it is no easy matter to play a
seven and a half hour game Run toward
the pizza restaurant which closed at 10
pm hopefully they still made it go to
bed really quickly and basically you get
up you have to go right back to the
playing Hall
yeah I mean it's it's a difficult
difficult ask and uh I do think that
those players perhaps will struggle and
I would not be surprised if both players
played it slightly more carefully today
and perhaps didn't go in for any long
complications and instead preferred
simpler lesser problematic positions
for sure and I'm a fan of the tournament
layout you can see the Challenger
section on the right do not be fooled by
that name there are some pretty decent
players in that section as well but of
course the stars of the show The Masters
are over on the left you can see Richard
report Fabiano caruana all of them
looking toward anamaya waiting for that
gong to sound so they can start the
clock and for Fabiano caruana yes he
played a marathon game but he's got
white against Magnus Carlson let me tell
you he will want nothing more than to
deal Magnus Carlson another blow and
send the world champion onto minus one
which would be truly shocking now that
again would uh Rock the Boat because
it's very rare that we see the world
champion first of all losing two games
in a row and if you were to lose again
well this would be unheard of and uh
there we see pragnanda arriving to the
board to meet his opponent Richard
Rapport who now plays for the Romanian
Chess Federation
um yeah
okay
I we're still waiting for Magnus to
arrive right he's always late
always he comes at
201-202 that sweet spot that fashionably
late sweet spot
um and we see all of the guests and uh
some of the distinguished authorities
Milling about okay there's Jordan event
Forest I think
yes he turns toward the right that means
he is part of the Masters that was
Jordan and there's the world champion
ladies and gentlemen shaking Fabiano's
hand taking a seat he's got a glass of
water in hand
and I don't think the clocks have
started yet you can see some Applause
there
or I believe for Anna Maya
and uh go gosh is that the moment of
anticipation before a game begins do you
ever feel nervous when you're sat here
at the board
lining up your pieces and just thinking
about what you're gonna do
yeah and a handshake the answer Yogi is
yes I mean there's always you start
thinking about your preparation your
mind starts racing but when the clocks
begin you zero in on the task at hand
and that is what Fabiano caruan will
have to do one E4 from Fabi as expected
Abby has recently been dabbling in other
openings but he is an E4 player at heart
and always the interesting question to
start the round with Yobe what is the
world champion going to play yeah what
is he going to play I mean is he going
to open with his the Sicilian as we saw
he did against Jordan van forest or is
he gonna take a different approach and
we have our answer immediately it is E4
E5 and Knight F3 Knight C6 are we gonna
see that or is he gonna surprise me and
play a petrol from no no Knight C6 and
it's the moment of truth will the bishop
code C4 B5 it is out it's a rye Lopez
and uh both players just experts in this
particular line
yeah marijuana has written a very well
received book on the Rue Lopez he's got
a course all of that came out in the
past year so you don't really want to
mess around with Fabiano caruana in the
Rue Lopez one person I would entrust to
do that is Magnus Carlson and they have
had a theoretical battle raging in this
opening now for well over a decade if
you think about the world championship
match and all of the times they've faced
each other in super tournaments right
now they are following the absolute main
line and here a big forking off point
white can play the move D3 that is
considered the sort of principal
sideline it's been all of the rage
really in the last five six years of
course the most popular move is rookie
one and Fabi he goes down the principal
path Ricky one is on the board and will
Magnus Play The Marshall uh attack or
will he push his deep Pawn out to D6
yeah I somehow yeah I think he's
castling I but somehow the Marshall
these days is not really allowed I mean
they the white players go out of the way
to avoid it primarily because it's quite
forcing and there are a lot of
variations that have led to certain
results and uh there we go
you're absolutely right
no no Marshall allowed
um
yep and they have had this I'm sure
before the thing is when two players
played this many games in one opening it
starts sort of meshing about in your
mind I just you know you don't remember
do they have this exact position or was
there the light script Bishop already on
B7 uh so you know even the players
themselves often get confused in the
sort of uh Thicket of variational
branches here let's see how Abby
proceeds here D5 is still a possibility
and if I'd be driving his Pawn to A5
early a very interesting approach as he
doesn't move his deep on just yet
yeah and I've taken inspiration from The
Young German talent I was going to ask
do you think we will ever see the move
Rook B8 happening
with the the potential rock cliff to B5
I mean it was so crazy that I don't know
I just wanna
to have a little joke at that chest joke
inside joke a chess flares only
yeah uh Magnus Carlson in the meantime
he pushes his Pawn up to D6 so Bobby's
successfully avoiding the Marshall but
that doesn't necessarily mean anything
D6 is also considered a pretty solid
move for black in the real Opus and now
the typical move C3 now often in a
comparable position you already see the
white Pawn out on H3 with that being
said Bishop G4 is rarely considered a
good move because that Bishop can be
quite easily tossed away from that
diagonal so normally you see the bishop
coming out to B7 sometimes black
develops it to E6 and still other times
black just delays the development of the
bishop as much as possible you can see
Magnus taking this third approach as
Rook V8 is on the board good call
yeah it is on it is the main move in the
database and I agree with you I don't
think that we're going to see that light
Square bishop move out to G4 first of
all it gets denied that square
especially now quite often yeah
and I was gonna say this whole kind of
variation depends on whether white can
get a very timely
d2d4 and uh often they can't do it
immediately because there's just too
much tension in the center and white
can't can't maintain it and so that's
why you'll often see white kind of go D3
Knight D2 Knight F1 you do all kinds of
maneuvering maybe even get the Knight to
C4 it doesn't matter and then once the
coast is clear maybe when black is
unprepared then the D4 break will occur
that's exactly right playing D4 is like
trying to pass through an International
Airport first there's passport
controllers B take C3 and there's
Customs there's the E takes C4 got to
make sure you have your passport with
you so you're absolutely right playing
D4 too early can result in a queen side
liquidation and that can definitely be
in Black's favor if you haven't arranged
your pieces properly and the world
champion is going to take really the
first significant think of the game
there's a lot of Canada moves even the
immediate Rook B5 is very much possible
because Bishop A4 can be met with Rook
takes A5 that rook in the corner is
undefended he can make a somewhat more
quiet move like H6 or you can choose to
finally develop the light squared Bishop
so we'll keep you posted on the world
championship Champion's choice I think
this is a good opportunity to take our
first dive into the bird's eye view and
look at how the other games are
proceeding
yep can't wait to head there and uh hang
on a second I'm already getting a big
smile on my face because I know I know
why
because dingler and my man Desperate
Times Desperate Measures hiding World
Championship prep and he's a forayed
into caracon territory
I'm already getting my support for the
world championship match just because of
that
likewise I actually have played the
caricon as my main opening in the last
year or so but exclusively with the move
C5 in this position so E5 the advanced
Caro there's Bishop C8 to F5 which is
the traditional main move but all the
rage in recent months and years has been
what I think is called the Batman and
Carl's variation and that is to play
this like an advanced French and push
the C Pawn up one square trying to
improve on the advanced French structure
that's why the karakan is objectively a
superior opening because they can still
develop the life
yeah yep I agree and somehow I don't
think ding will venture into that
territory I think he'll perhaps keep it
more flexible and put the bishop out to
F5 but it's so interesting because
Wesley say of course did a very famous
E4 Course and there he kind of Advocates
a certain line so I always very curious
will he back up his own course and play
it
yeah dun dun he recommends as far as I
remember Knight D2 and Knight B3 which
is one of probably the three or four
main responses to the advanced scare
ding is actually taking his time so he's
definitely perhaps thinking about
playing C5 maybe he didn't expect Wesley
to follow his own recommendation and you
have a smile on your face I have a smile
on mine you'll be there choosing to
satisfy the commentators ding plays C5
but the other reason I'm smiling is
because because Arjun aragaisi has
chosen to play a king's Indian uh
defense against van forest and he is
playing a line which also was totally
unheard of until Notre back abducatorov
and Java care sundarov two of the top
Uzbek players introduced it into
practice and introduced it into the
public eye in the last Olympia that's
the move H7 H6 in the main tabia that's
bottom left side invent Forest
responding with a surprise of his own
Rook A1 to B1 I smell stockfish yummy I
smell the pot tangent scent of stockfish
in that game
yeah and uh okay so where do you think
we should head into and take a deep dive
well I definitely want to look at how
the Wesley game is unfolding the danger
there is that the players could execute
the main moves very slowly I don't think
Wesley expected C5 I mean he's already
thinking and White's got a major Choice
there between Knight F3 and pawn takes
C5 so I think it would be risky uh to
focus in on that game Yobe but the other
games are all pretty standard we've got
an Italian in reports game we've got uh
an auntie Berlin a pretty standard
anti-berlin and notrex game and another
Italian in Gary kymer man I'm
experiencing some indecision here what
do you think how about we pay a visit to
tournament leader abduser toroff and
Lavon aronian and let's check out how
they are doing and uh
the thing that kind of struck me is that
it is a
is this a this is an exchange variation
right in the Royal Lopez
yeah this is an anti-berlin exchange D3
Bishop C5 and now there's a big forking
off point where it can castle where you
can play C3 but uh I'm just a tour of
choosing to take on C6 also very popular
DC it should be pointed out that Knight
takes E5 is a false friend you don't
want to take here because you lose your
knight to queen D4 that's a fork and
after Bishop E3 you might say oh well I
can win the bishop back no harm no foul
the problem is that you win the bishop
back but you lose absolutely everything
else G2 Falls and then you lose your
Rook so
uh surprisingly abusive sort of didn't
fall for it he went Knight B to D2 the
black Bishop came out castles Bishop
back to D6 in order to support the E5
pawn and now another bringing his Knight
out to B3 you often see the Knight
jumping out to A5 in these variations
and Levon nips that in the bud with B6
leading us
to the current position or abdom is
taking his time Yobe interesting yeah it
is interesting and uh the reason he is
taking his time is because
checking the opening database right in
front of me I can see that that is not a
popular move in fact it's only been
played once before
and uh everyone else tends to go Knight
to D7 push the pawn forward to A5 even
Bishop G4 no one is actually trying to
dominate The Knight Circuit by playing
B6
so the big question here is
what is White gonna do is White gonna
play the slogram or is he going to
accelerate everything yeah you you are
going to answer my question
push that pawn in the middle
do a pawn break right now
I mean
yeah dangerous
it does D4 is one of the main reasons
why black often avoids this particular
minor piece construction now I would
suppose that after D4 black wants to
grab the pawn on e4 kind of Berlin style
and then you get a very sharp position
in the center white can take on E5
anyway and then black can move the
bishop back and I would be worried I
would be afraid to go into a line of
this concrete if I'm Notre back
especially if I'm out of my preparation
because there's no question in my mind
that the first thing Lavon checked was
D3 D4 unless he's bluffing which uh is
not a very good idea against the
tournament leader so as you're pointing
out if not D4 I think Notre back might
go for the Slow Burn approach get the
bishop out Bishop to G5 uh or maybe
bishop to E3 but the the good thing
about getting the bishop out to G5 is
not only that you're pinning the Knight
which is not such a big deal but that if
black tosses the bishop around the
bishop can migrate back to G3 where it
wants to go anyway
putting significant pressure on the E5
pawn and often forcing Black's Knight
back to a relatively awkward D7 Square
so if I had to make the early prediction
I think the safest bet here is Bishop G5
but these positions yovi can get very
concrete I mean sometimes you see black
attacking on the king side with h65 so
I'm a little bit nervous in the early
going on notorbeck's behalf
yeah uh I have seen uh Lebron do that
actually and in the last years actually
I've seen that he sharpened his games
considerably you know he plays quickly
he's confident it's very Punchy he's not
afraid to get off the Beaten Track and
try his hand at playing something new
and uh yeah I agree with you I somehow
suspect that Lavon he is eager to take
the point he's eager for some Fighting
Chess and I think that he is also going
to put his King to the queen side and
we're going to be in for four blooded
fight
and uh
it sounds uh tough but I kind of like it
I love it when the players just come to
the board with this fighting mood this
ability to kind of just sit down and
just throw everything they have at their
opponent and
it's it's beautiful to see it especially
at such a high level
hey Lavon and anybody wants to be the
one who defeated the tournament leader
that is a very unique Sensation that is
just a euphoric feeling it doesn't
matter that these players are accustomed
to winning the feeling of stopping the
tournament leader especially someone
who's having as good of a run as
neuterbeck is one that everybody wants
to experience and I think lavon's choice
of playing the Berlin is a good one he
knows notabeck is not going to take the
Berlin draw I mean first of all he wants
an invite to next year's status deal and
second of all you basically have the
obligation uh to play uh with the white
pieces so the Berlin was I think a very
Savvy Choice uh and by playing it Lavon
guarantees a very rich uh middle game
struggle with a highly imbalanced
position so the perfect opening uh to
generate serious winning chances and I
agree I think there's a high probability
that black is going to go Queen side
here one more thing I want to point out
from a sort of technical standpoint is
that if black Castle's Queen side I
think a lot of people would be afraid to
to do that but this kind of bumper that
plaque has constructed on the queen side
can actually serve as a very effective
Pawn Shield so let's for the sake of
illustration let's make a couple random
moves H3 by the way is a very bad move
in these types of positions because it
creates a pawn a hook that black can use
for attacking purposes but the point I
wanted to make is that when white tries
to attack black with a move like A4 well
I can stop it with A5 then you say okay
didn't work there let's try the sifo no
way C5 and look at this Pawn
construction white has absolutely no
breakthroughs the Knight looks like a
dummy over on B3 and unless I can get
some sort of a sacrifice going on A5 I
mean you're not going to get anywhere on
the queen side so I would consider this
a rather disconcerting possibility
something that notorbeck definitely has
to factor in to his thinking
yeah uh absolutely and I agree with you
the main thing that kind of I would be
looking at is the fact that the White
Knight as you say is very badly placed
and knowing Lavon and also knowing how
he was on the wrong side of uh a defeat
when he played white and uh black
castled queenside
um I think he's going to go all for it
he is in gung-ho-mu today and like you
say
after yesterday's team draw against
Anish Gary he wants to be invited back
to next year's tournament every single
chess player wants to play invite and
say that is like the Pinnacle of the
chess career
it is indeed there's no arguing that
well we will monitor notorbeck's
decision as he continues to ponder this
early critical position let's take
ourselves back to the bird's eye view
the Wesley ding game is actually
developing they have chosen uh a
specific variation of the batmanic
Carl's defense Yogi I
anticipate that you will say yes to this
but shall we take a look at what I think
is our first Karo Khan of uh this entire
tournament and hopefully not a blast
I think so and it's very appropriate
that it's uh being played in front of
two players who adore the opening so
yeah and now the big question is is
where is the black Bishop gonna go now
I've kind of come to the opinion that
this bishop should Retreat to E7
yes yes yes and uh black has a very
simple plan actually blacks are idea is
just simply to play Knight H6 F6 because
Queen side but the Knight on F7 and uh
ask white what are you gonna do with
your porn
and uh that's it A4 also should be
thrown in I agree
and that's it simple times
indeed I've had this line so many times
in Blitz Games and I would argue I would
say that maybe 50 of my Blitz Games at
least all follow the same exact
variation at the end of which black is a
pretty big advantage and I will shout
out a very good book on the caracon by
uh Francesco rimaldi I know that there's
this other commentator who wrote a
really good book on the car I kind of
forgot her name though
um maybe it'll come to me at some point
uh but it's out there I agree with you
he changed my mind
yeah no I mean he Advocates Bishop p7 I
thought his analysis is First Rate let
me show that line really quickly I don't
think it's likely to occur here and you
can uh you know second this uh if you've
come across this as well it starts with
Bishop E7 so most people here uh they
play a move like Bishop D3 black throws
in A5 in order to carve out this very
nice uh spot which is usually used for
the night but the bishop can go there as
well then we develop the Knight to D7
white fiancado is the bishop in order to
protect D5 as you pointed out the Knight
comes out to H6 now a lot of people go
Knight D2 and it's already time uh I
think a good opportunity to play the
move F6 and what tends to happen here is
that people go Knight F3 to support the
pawn the Knight drops back to F7 a very
nice construction and if white takes on
F6 prematurely ax takes takes takes if
white does not know to play C4 and white
simply castles after the movie five I
have had this exact position probably 20
times and white is already in big
trouble because there's no good way to
stop the move E4 if you move your Bishop
back E4 happens anyway and white
basically just gets pushed off the board
so this line has to be avoided like the
plague by Wesley so and guess what I
have some very good news for you Bishop
E7 has been played I'm super excited uh
to see how this game will unfold back to
the live game yeah me too uh and I I
really am enjoying this because I think
Wesley has already deviated from his
his uh his course unless I can't quite
remember his course involved an early
Queen G4 I don't let me just check my
opening database and uh Queen G4 not
played at all in this particular
position everyone is playing Knight F3
and uh really I also have this exact
same experience as you they're all going
903 or Bishop B2 and uh the position
that you showed I've also had and it's a
great feeling when you get it it's so
good for black
and then people always do the same thing
they sack a piece on e4 and there's
never enough compensation and what's
amazing is how many GMS have fallen for
this line it's always good when you
discover it's so rare these days when
you discover a line that people on mass
are still unfamiliar with and it never
gets sold I mean word doesn't spread as
fast because people don't prepare for
online games
well I'm so excited to see what Wesley
has in store for us here
yeah me too and we will definitely keep
a close eye on that game
personally because I really want to and
uh let's go to the bird's eye view
okay Wesley is going to continue
pondering this position and trying to
avoid the line we just Illustrated back
we go to the bird's eye view a lot of
the games are unfolding of course my
personal favorite is the van Forest Eric
Icy game Carolina Carlson also uh
experiencing some Transformations you
can see Fabby grabbing the D4 Pawn with
his Knight that's not something that you
do every day in the Roy Lopez inviting
an exchange of minor pieces the world
champion over on the camera
is he puzzled is he surprised he's
definitely taking his time after that
move
and uh interesting stuff in all of the
games you'll be this promises to be
another really exciting day
yeah absolutely and shall we head over
to the Jordan
aragaisy game primarily because both
these players really need to win Arjun
of course losing yesterday to Abdul
satoroff and Jordan van for East well he
tried to set up a fortress against
pragananda but as the world champion
famously said they don't exist he
doesn't believe in them although
we should I should he kind of later
backpeddled a bit and said no I didn't
say that exactly everyone knows what I
meant
yes it's it's like one of those quotes
that's you know it's not that it's taken
out of context it's like obviously an
exaggeration but you said you don't
believe in Fortress and you set up like
the most obvious Fortress of all time oh
right this is wrong but uh this game is
very interesting from a theoretical
point of view so if we rewind a little
bit I just want to give some context on
this H6 move now of course they play out
the main line of the king's Indian this
is called the classical variation black
plays E5 this is not a blunder this is
the main move and White Castles and here
the traditional Main Line the marginal
platter variation is Knight to C6 I've
played all sorts of Sidelines uh my main
move nowadays the old guy move is e
takes D4 but H6 burst onto the scene not
so long ago and the idea of this move is
actually quite simple it's a
semi-waiting move so you're first of all
exploiting the fact that taking twice on
E5 is not effective because black has
some tactics there with Knight takes C4
say that white wins that black wins the
pawn back so after D5 D5 let's say that
white takes the queen first after Rook
d8 Knight takes E5 black x-rays the
Knight with his bishop and this makes
possible the move Knight takes C4 very
importantly if white takes then black
takes and black uh pressures the B2 Pawn
so he doesn't lose material and if you
think you're a genius and take Desperado
on F7 unfortunately that backfire is
spectacularly due to Knight takes C3 you
recapture the Knight then you lose the
piece you take the rook and you drop the
bishop with check and black is winning
so this is a toothless variation for
that reason white often plays the move
Bishop C1 to E3 completing his
development but there The Genius of H6
really comes into play because after
Bishop E3 black plays the move Knight G4
and the traditional response Bishop G5
is no longer possible because someone
thought to play the move H6 so in a
weird kind of way H6 is a profile
Galactic move against Bishop E3 and it's
hard for white to find a healthy way to
continue improving his position Jordan
responds with a kind of semi-waiting
move of his own putting the Rook on a
square where it removes itself from The
Bishop's potential X-ray and here Arjun
decides to take on D4 and transition
into a variation you'll be the last
thing I'll say which is very popular
without the inclusion of the move's H6
Rick pione what Arjun is saying is that
the inclusion of these moves favors him
I don't know whether he will he will be
proven right
yeah and uh definitely a tense game
developing it's going to be all about
whether white can sit on their space
advantage and maintain the strongholds
on e4 and C4 and pile on the pressure on
D6 or whether black can just generate
enough piece play and uh often I think
often he can there is no I think about
it the Knight will come out but Park
itself on C5 and uh if white is really
careless then D5 is going to be the
ultimate breakthrough
yeah very very common sort of mistake
here is to play Bishop C1 at E3 and this
walks right into D5
and after cd5 black and even take back
with the Knight and x-ray the bishop so
we will not delve too deeply into any
particular sideline just because uh
we're gonna get a lot of clarity on the
position after Jordan's next move the
recent try mostly has to do with
bringing the bishop out to F4 in order
to try to discourage black from playing
D5 and there's also kind of a
semi-waiting move like King H1 which is
considered one of the best lines but
again when I say that I'm talking about
the position without H6 Rook P1 this is
classic modern chess two moves that
appear totally insignificant can in
certain variations completely change the
nature of the game and for Jordan band 4
is the challenge is really to figure out
whether the move that he was planning to
play without these two moves is still
good or does the move H6 change anything
about the position I think he's going to
take his time uh in this critical moment
f i I agree it is the moment to take a
think and it allows us to take a look at
the bird's eye view again and have a
look at how the other games are
developing
yeah and so we shall back to the bird's
eye view top right we've got uh sort of
what started out as a very standard
Italian but things have really gone a
Haywire Vincent has his pawns on H6 and
G5 and he has Castle to that side as
well there's a knight that's moved back
to H7 presumably to open up the path for
the F bond to move forward that looks
like a pretty meat on the bone kind of
game let's go
yeah I mean after
it it looks like your standard Day at
the Office Dania
I mean there's nothing here to write
home about I mean take a look at it the
kings are safe
pawns have come forward no I mean this
is crazy stuff
everything's normal I mean it's just a
classic Italian position it's just that
black split H6 G5 and is about to play
F5
and it's interesting Vincent has taken
his time here Yogi so this is not
necessarily preparation
yeah I I again check the database to see
whether any games have been played in
this and on the chess.com database nope
no games have been seen before and in
fact
I think they were following
some game but after the moves King H1
that'll zip they're in New Territory
Yuri has an hour 40 minutes he basically
has as much time as he started with
which means he's taken a little bit of
time but not all that much the question
really to me is when did things start to
go start to go crazy uh in this game and
we should rewind all the way back to
move five because and with five Geary
played a line that's I think a little
bit less popular than C3 and then Knight
bd2 and A4 which is all the rage he
brought this bishop out to G5 early now
as far as I know black has the move
Bishop C5 to E7 that's kind of the
conservative approach but Vincent taking
the aggressive approach pushing H6 and
then soon after that there's the G5 move
that's not as surprising h625 is very
common in the Italian what really
surprises me is after a couple of
developing moves and so just decides to
Castle King side is I don't care that I
play G5 my king is still perfectly safe
because you cannot exploit the
weaknesses that I've created with these
two moves Yuri expands on the queen side
and there's 19 H7 and King hhg I wonder
what he's preparing with these two moves
hmm could it be F5
um I don't know Daniel no of course it
is it's gonna be here five
um but obviously white can't do a thing
about that so I was wondering what nurse
is White's plan because what has to do
something I mean you don't just sit
around twiddling your thumbs just
waiting for black to strike
um
and I have seen games but in a
completely different context here and
this is where the danger of having
little knowledge
might be much more dangerous than having
no knowledge at all because I have I
remember a game between
um Magnus Wesley so Magnus Carlson in
the Norway chess and I remember that
Wesley just went A4 B5
and it was completely different because
the black king had not castled and is it
still the plan here to kind of go
A4 B5 attack the night and
and just say well I at least I'm getting
something over there I don't really know
what's happening to the right of me
but the left of me I'm okay
the thing is to the right of you you
might your Bishop trapped uh and so I
think he takes F5 is forced
now black and snap off the bishop first
I mean I think that's a sensible
decision uh justifying the Knight on the
rim and the engine doesn't like this as
much but just looking at this visually
again I'm not too familiar with these
structures in general but Black's got a
lot of assets you know black is the
bishop pair all of Black's pieces are
decent and the Knight can come back to
F6 there's a very unpleasant positional
threat of Bishop F5 to G4 and if black
takes on F3 your Bishop on G3 is
completely imprisoned that is no
laughing matter and yeah White's got
some activity on the queen side perhaps
so I can even take on A6 and argue that
he's you know introduced some cosmetic
damage to Black's Pawn structure but
again that damage is purely cosmetic how
are you going to attack the isolated
Pawn on A6 heck you've got an isolated
Pawn yourself so Anish giri is the one
with something to prove on the queen
side Vincent's play on the other side of
the board I think is far more
straightforward I love the way that
Vincent has handled the opening
um after another disappointment
yesterday he seems to be fresh he is
determined as ever
and Anish giri has made a move and it is
in fact A4 back to the live board
that is and I always have that sense of
oh I managed to get something right so
A4 you did maybe a good thing maybe a
bad thing but I did feel that black
sorry white has to do something I mean
at least for some you know just for some
kind of symbolic gesture you know I've
gotta have some activity and uh yeah
things are really sharpening up here and
I do wonder how black is going to react
I'd like your F5 plan also like the H5
plan as well that we've seen in the game
between Eric ice who was Eric icy
uh and it was
Eric icy against
Samara guy see I don't quite remember
but I know yeah guys it was with white
yeah he was with the white pieces and uh
yes anyway ding he played the it was the
game ding against eragisi
and that game ended in a draw correct
yeah I mean it's a pretty safe bet to
say that Arjuna guys who drew because he
drew all of his games but one
yep
yeah H5 versus F5 dob if I had to make a
guess I think F5
is just more consistent with how he's
handled the previous two moves if you
wanted to play H5 he could have played
it on the previous move you know you
wouldn't really need to play King G8 to
h8 and I will say it's it's way too
early to make hard and fast conclusions
uh about this position we're going to
get a lot of clarity in the next couple
of moves but I feel like this is the
first time in the tournament where Anish
giri hasn't necessarily gotten the kind
of position out of the opening with
which he's comfortable he hasn't managed
to steer the game in the direction that
he's wanted to and I wouldn't be fooled
by the fact that Vincent has less time
on the clock yeah he's taking his time
but after F5 I really really like
Black's chances
oh I it's a dynamic game and Vincent of
course likes Dynamic positions and it's
it's what you want from the opening you
want to get your pieces active you want
to have your chance to attack the
opponent and
also if you want to unsettle someone
like Anish you know Anish relies quite
heavily on his opening prep he has a
fantastic knowledge and if he has to
play on the back foot for a while okay
this is going to be a moral victory for
Vincent
it made a lot of sense oh
this one is shaping up to be a brutal
round yet again do you think that the
players are kind of tired maybe we'll
see more blunders than we've done in
previous games sorry previous rounds
I think the day before the rest day is
often notorious for exactly that reason
where the players are just salivating at
the prospect of sleeping and maybe a
little nice trip to Amsterdam a van Gogh
Museum they want to end on a good note
and that often creates anxiety that uh
even accentuates the fact that they're
already fatigued after some long games
yesterday so I think absolutely we're
more likely to see unbalanced games and
we're more likely to see blunders as the
games you know reach their fourth and
fifth hour
yeah and as the tournament draws on of
course the nerves start jangling and uh
well anything can and will happen and uh
shall we take a look at the bird's eye
view and see who has started off rather
mildly oh and who has ignited those
fireworks and uh I mean it's really I
can see a few games that really catch my
eye
and
shall we revisit though uh Fabiana
caruana and Magnus Carlson because this
of course is a very important game and
uh who doesn't like seeing Fabi and
Magnus play each other it's a repeat of
the 2018 World Championship match
it is indeed and the players are older
and wiser the more experienced and
Fabiano I think has had a chip on his
shoulder uh playing Magnus ever since uh
he lost in the rapid tie breaks in 2018
after all of the classical games were
famously drawn as for which openings are
peaceful and we will get back to it in
due course but I really think the kukesh
game might be the only one that I would
qualify as positional or quiet now this
game well I suppose the kings are not in
danger so it isn't necessarily tactical
but there is a lot going on on the queen
side and just to uh clarify the point I
made earlier two moves ago Magnus
Carlson released the tension in the
center by taking on D4 and here it is
automatic in 99 of cases Yogi for white
to play C takes D4 why did Carolina not
take back with a pawn I don't have a
great answer for you maybe it's that he
didn't like the central Counter-Strike
D5 and after E5 black entrenches his
Knight on that lovely E4 Square Bishop
B4 becomes a possibility and you start
experiencing problems with your A5
funnel make the moves on the board D5 E5
Knight E4 and if you just make a
nonchalant developing move after Bishop
before you're already dropping the A5
Pawn you can see the eval bar dropping
precipitously there and perhaps for that
reason Fabiano takes with the Knight
and in the event of a trade the effect
of Bishop B4 is diminished because the
Knight on C6 no longer exists but Agnes
says no I am keeping you saddled with
these weak pawns and he gets his Bishop
out to D7 Fabiano does the same Bishop
F4
and this is the current position Navy
what do you make of this yeah and uh you
know Fabi has said in the past that uh
commentators read too much into his body
language or player's body language in
general and I'm going to read into
something else I'm going to read into
the clock times look at that Fabi one
hour 37 minutes he's barely used any
time so to me this indicates that he is
in his own preparation
he has done the research here he's done
the analytical work and
now he just is trying to work out what
to do next
before not a move you play
unless you're familiar with the idea
yeah and uh it was the the computer's
recommendation actually to capture on D4
with the Knight
and now Magnus has to think about what's
ahead you know
how should he handle this position you
know the big problem with hit with it is
that it's not easy to kind of unravel
all those pieces that are clustered
together in the center I'm thinking of
the Bishops and the Knight because you
kind of if you make some happy move like
the move the route to E8 then you know
the F7 Point starts looking a slightly
sensitive it's only defended by the king
and that would make me nervous also
if you take back the Rook go into E8
um other moves that Fabi could be
thinking about playing is putting a
knight on F5 also Fabi will probably be
thinking about developing his own pieces
like due to what A3 haven't quite made
up my mind but somehow these pieces are
going to just develop very easily very
freely towards the center I I love your
Bishop C4 move uh direct Chess at its
best and uh how is black gonna counter
it and 95 was in fact the only move that
I saw
but hmm that's it that's as far as
you're getting
oh yeah
territory as long as white doesn't go
Knight D2 then okay that's okay
um moose I would consider maybe not
Knight F5 I would kind of keep that one
in the pocket just for a later time it
would probably be to develop the the
Knight to A3
uh hang on a second
yeah I unfortunately know 92 because of
Knight D3
but then you could go to C4 and if you
can exchange Black's only active piece I
mean this is what you're talking about
let's again let's I feel like we've
designated we're victimizing rookie as
the sort of you know standard waiting
move after Knight C4 black probably is
best advised to play Bishop f8 because
if you just sort of take well you can
get in into huge trouble in a position
like this not only is why developing
massive pressure on A6 and forcing you
to curl up into a ball but after
something like E5 you know white blasts
open the center and you know when the
Center opens like this the side of the
more active pieces often stands to
benefit and here I mean we've got an
incredibly lopsided situation with
respect uh to piece activity and I'm
already thinking jumping really far
ahead here to moves like Queen G6 this
is what could happen uh if life doesn't
handle this position with the utmost
caution and even if he does this is
unpleasant you'll be I think there's no
arguing that fabi's opening preparation
has already been a success both in terms
of the clock situation you want to build
up a 30 minute time Advantage uh hear
that that's a big deal but also in terms
of the challenges that Magnus Carlson
faces as we go back to live position
it's not that easy as you said for black
to unravel and for black to keep the
balance in the center and on the queen
side
yeah I I agree
the uh world champion in an
uncomfortable position at the minute and
uh well
it's a good preparation by Fabi in fact
all of these guys are famous for their
opening preparation we've kind of seen
it left right and Center in this
tournament you know people have been
springing surprises playing different
things keeping us on on their toes us on
our toes rather and uh it's it's what we
like well this dodging diving
weaving around love it
we would not have it any other way well
as the world champion uh
ruminates over what seems to be a rather
unpleasant position out of the opening
we will take the opportunity first to go
back quickly to our bird's eye view we
can see our usual assortment of exciting
openings I'll point out the Wesley so
game they are following the exactly the
path that we kind of set out with the
knight from G8 likely to drop into H6
and then back to F7 dislodging the pawn
from E5 we will keep you posted on that
game and the other exciting battles we
have here in round eight of the Tata
steel chess tournament but first we are
going to take our first break of the day
ladies and gentlemen we hope you're
enjoying our coverage thus far we are
one hour into the round and we will be
back with more coverage on the other
side of this break
or maybe where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
foreign
it's a blustery and cold chilly two
degree Centigrade day over in the
seaside town of Wake On the perfect
weather to huddle in that magnificent
playing Hall and place of Chess we see
it filled to the brink with Spectators
and players in the open tournaments
we've talked about it before Tata steel
isn't just a super tournament it is also
a festival but as for the super
Tournament part of it it is the most
anticipated super tournament every year
Welcome to our coverage of round eight
we're 45 50 minutes into this very
important round past the halfway point
of the tournament and the last round
before the second rest day yovi this is
a test of the player's nerves this is a
test of their mental Firepower it's a
test of their resilience and the world
for the world champion it's a test of
his ability to go above 50 percent
shocking to say Agnes Carlson still kind
of in the doldrums he's trying to get
out of them ASAP
yeah I mean it's so unheard of that we
see past the Midway Mark that the world
champion is in seventh place as you say
I'm 50 that's just never been seen
before I think and not I don't know not
in my lifetime at least and we kind of
don't expect that from him either but uh
he is up against Fabiano Carolina there
we can see both of them thinking hard
about their middle game and it is a
tense game and a tense situation indeed
and uh yeah
they can just see how they are so
focused both of them with their
trademark body language you have uh
Magnus Carlson to me one thing I've
always noticed about him is that it
appears that chess is his meditation you
always see feel that when he's there in
his comfort zone it's long exhales he's
calming himself down this is his Solace
and uh Fabi
just also just looks so concentrated so
focused so determined I mean there is
pride at stake here and uh there we see
Fabi make move
developing his mind to the edge of the
board
and exactly as you advised
I never know whether to take as a
compliment or
whether I should be worried for the
players
oh my coach my coach uh when when he
would test me on Grandmaster games he
would always tell me uh good there's
good news and bad news the good news is
you played the same move as you know
Vasily Smith's love bad news is Vaseline
Smith's love made a blunder so you're in
pretty good company but I actually like
Knight A3 I think Knight A3 is a good
way to skirt the problem of Knight E5 to
D3 which would have followed after
Knight D2 as you had explained so I mean
wherever you turn we have so many
different types of Rich structures I
mean this is a day of differing punch
structures we've got that caricon over
on the top left so again Stingley run
we've got the anti-berlin kind of
rosalimo-like Pawn structure as you uh
we're talking about during the break and
Abdul sator of aronian and now in report
prognananda that's bottom center of your
screen we have the most typical Richard
report move of all time h2h4 shall we
pay a brief visit to that game
yes because I was gonna say it looks
like most of the players have just left
opening territory and are now in well in
the Realms of the middle game and well
in the Realms of just being in their own
territory you know they are freestyling
making things up but uh Richard Rapport
well he has taken it outside the box as
always I mean I'm just checking to see
whether anyone anyone has ever played
h2h4 and according to the chess.com
database
nope not at all I mean the most popular
move I mean have only been played once
before but that person chose to play
Knight to E3
um well Knight E3 makes a lot of sense
completing the sort of standard rule
Lopez maneuver H4 is one of those moves
whose point is not to obscure your
intentions your intentions are very
clear and they're violent he is trying
to push this spawn all the way up to H6
in order to provoke G6 and soften up the
Knight on F6 increasing the intensity of
this pin and the big question for Prague
is well does he want to allow that and
prepare for it or does he want to nip
the idea in the bud by playing H6
himself I'm not even talking
about H7 H5 I think that move is largely
out of the question because then the
bishop is totally unassailable on G5 so
let's pull up an announce board and dive
into H6 you'll be do you think report
might be planning to play H5 anyway
absolutely
um if you can force the Black Knight to
go to h8 I mean that looks terrible but
I mean I'm expecting the Knight to jump
forward or yeah I don't want to be
capturing this bishop at all so jump
forward with the Knights if you capture
it's like oh no you can just see a Czech
mating idea on H7 I mean things are just
going to get lined up on the edge Line
This would just be
yeah
um I mean just getting excited
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I guess it's better to play GF first
Rook F7 I mean his eye let's not talk
about this because the Knight comes in
and you win the queen in any case he's
not gonna do that I agree he's gonna go
Knight F4 and what do you make of this
very unconventional Pawn structures this
part of strength or a weakness
um
it's traditionally a kind of a weakness
but on the other hand black does have
the bishop pair and the pawn is
disabling the Knight on F1
and of course it can't be targeted so
easily I mean
and should it be targeted I I'm kind of
thinking it's a strength for the time
being of course it can be developed into
a weakness but
I mean also my vibe is
why should black even stress about that
pawn
instead just uh generate the counter
play ASAP
like D5 88 and D5 yeah yeah but don't go
Knight G4 that's the one thing that's
annoying about the pawn shifting away
from E5 the effect of D3 D4 increases so
you want to keep the Knight on F6 too
allow for Knight takes E4 in response to
D4 but I agree I mean rookie a D5 this
is exactly the kind of position Prague
wants because he wants to win this game
report is struggling he lost to Magnus
and prog is having the tournament of his
life so I think already at this point in
the game as the position becomes
increasingly unbalanced Prague isn't
thinking yeah I want to do something
conservative let's drop the Knight back
to h8 and grovel he wants to meet
Richard report at the top
and and this is style as well and one
thing that I've noticed about Prague is
he just never likes to sound The Retreat
so it wouldn't even surprise me if
instead of playing H6 I think you could
even see a move like rookie eight he
will have calculated that after H5 he
can jump forward with his Knight to F4 I
mean he will only be playing he will
only be playing H6
once the complicated lines are not
working in his favor
speaking of H6 reports that could say oh
if you don't want to do it I'm going to
do it that sacrifices the pawn on G2
with check not something you do every
day but Prague wouldn't necessarily take
that pawn I think he could even choose
to keep the tension uh well the email
bar uh is laughing me out of the
building here but I guess G6 isn't the
right approach maybe you should take on
G2 first and then strike at the center
with D5 we get a completely wild chaotic
position which on the surface is in
report's favorite that is what report
likes the only problem is that is also
what Prague likes I mean those players
they have relatively similar Styles both
of them enjoy uh attacking both of them
enjoy highly unbalanced positions I
think both of them are enjoying this
game right they love chess and sometimes
you just want to take a step back and I
remind myself of this when I start
getting stressed out about a wild
position I just remind myself this is
fun for me this is my style so I'm just
going to focus on enjoying the process
of calculation
yeah absolutely and this is the both
their strengths calculation I mean this
is what Prague has been doing since he
was a baby you know they've been doing
calculation exercises I don't want to
say a child because I feel like he's
he's still a child
um okay yeah yeah I I just think that he
is so practical he knows how to coolly
handle any kind of complications I've
seen it time and time again and also he
never gets flustered when he's under
pressure
either on the clock or on the position
he's just looking for those defensive
resources
the opposite perspective he was under
pressure yesterday against Ben Forrest
not on the board he was obviously better
forever but definitely on the clock his
clock was starting to dwindle he wasn't
making too much progress progress and at
some point he just switched on beast
mode and with you know eight minutes for
10 moves he just rattled off a series of
excellent moves and ultimately brought
Jordan Ben forrest's uh Valiant
resistance to a close that was a very
impressive positional win just showing
that Prague isn't just a calculator he's
a multi-faceted player and at this point
in his career as he inches up to 2700 he
can essentially play any position he's
made his style more Universal but it is
his tactical prowess that he is likely
to have to lean on as this game
percolates and becomes sharper and
sharper well let's leave Prague to his
devices here his clock down to an hour
and seven minutes he doesn't have too
much longer to think about this position
you want to leave yourself with a lot of
time to handle the ensuing complications
and let's travel back to our bird's eye
view Yogi well any interesting updates
Magnus has played rookie eight what else
catches your eye I think we should take
a look at a game we haven't seen before
and that's the game between gukash and
Max Hulu
um
it seems like it's quite peaceful but
in my experience these positions are
anything but looks can be deceiving
they can indeed we have an isolated
Queen Pawn structure where black is the
one with the iqp so let's rewind back to
the start
and uh let's see how they reached this
unbalanced Pawn structure this started
off
as a whoa
E6 Knight F3 H6 by para maxillo this is
I've never seen this move before I've
seen A6 and A6 is not that uncommon but
H6 are you kidding me stopping Bishop G5
yeah I have I haven't seen in this
context normally you see it with a black
plain D5 but nope this is a new one and
uh I like the way you could cash handled
it he was like okay I'm just gonna
develop you can keep your H6 to yourself
and somehow it feels like they've
transitioned into something mainstream
except that black has taken the time out
to do a very early age six
yeah this is a Rubenstein nimso Indian
but in this position Black's Knight is
usually on C6 the move H6 doesn't really
hurt black but it doesn't help all that
much either and it does feel like wet is
slightly better here kukesh immediately
goes into the iqp structure he releases
the central tension and he says hey you
know in this exact position normally
black has a knight on C6 this cannot be
all that good for blackened I don't
think it is now he plays Knight C6
and it should be pointed out Yogi that
because he's allowed White's Bishop on
to B2 the standard move d4 no longer
works because white has the very
powerful response Knight to A4 hitting
the bishop forcing it off of its defense
of the D4 pawn and after Bishop D6 for
example white grabs D4 and uh agree gift
sacrifice in these types of positions uh
is almost almost never effective for for
various reasons but one of them is that
after Knight takes D4 Bishop takes D4 I
know a lot of people get very excited at
the prospect of the Greek gift but the
king walks forward to G3 and after Queen
G5 it's time for the first whoop of the
day F4 deserves it and normally you go
Queen G6 here you can't do that so the
king is safe and sound on G3 long story
short like Sulu develops his Bishop who
cash chases it away
and after Bishop H5 we have
uh the current position is kukesh gonna
follow up with G4 yovi or do you think
he's gonna take a more uh passive a more
quiet approach I should say with the
Rook C1 yeah I think he's gonna go Roxy
one I don't see it G2 G4 is unnecessary
and also considering that you've I'm
just putting myself into Cash's shoes
and saying you know he's had a bad time
in this tournament things haven't gone
his way there's no need to make life
complicated there's Beauty and
simplicity but you work on C1 and if you
do want to invite complications then I
would suggest moves like Knight E2
because yes okay you know you do allow
Bishop takes Knight but that's not such
a big problem because you can step
forward with the King and that you can
use the power of the open g-line to your
own advantage
yeah I think that's a great point a lot
of people would rule out 92 or any move
that allows Bishop takes Knight but I've
seen games where Checkmate results in
like five moves the moment a rook
appears on G1 I mean these Bishops
that are staring menacingly at Black's
King I've heard them refer to as
Horowitz Bishops so when you've got one
Bishop on the long diagonal and one
Bishop on B1 H7 I don't know if that's
uh kind of a standardized term but I
definitely think these Bishops deserve a
name because this particular type of
development is quite common
let's see if gukesh stays calm here and
continues to tighten the screws with
Rook C1 but I like his position I think
there's no question that white is better
it's one of those things where the
question is how much is white better uh
the who has the advantage is not up for
debate
yeah I I agree and I I feel that it's up
to kukesh how he wants to proceed he
doesn't actually need to invite
complications all he has to do is just
maintain control over the default Square
which is the square in front of the
isolated spawn and if he does that and
tries to bully Black by offering some
minor piece trades I mean he's gonna be
from slightly better to much better and
whether he can transfer that to a
winning Advantage remains to be seen
yes it does kukesh continues to think in
this early critical moment and he
definitely will want to score his first
victory in this game the opening has
been successful he's got the white
pieces he really needs to try to stop
the bleeding and you know victory over
someone of Mexico's caliber will
definitely go a long way all right let's
uh take one more look at our bird's eye
view because we've got some exciting
developments in a lot of the other games
uh in particular I'd highlight Wesley
against ding the position has
transformed and is actively transforming
there wow then Forest Eric icy the king
side has closed down and Arjun is going
after Jordan benforest King and top
right Gary kymer is following a very
similar path to the one that we were
exploring where Anish trying to whip up
queenside counterplay and induce
weaknesses in Black spawn structure
because there is a ticking clock Vincent
is assembling his forces on the kingside
Yogi I mean this is just such an
exciting round we're only an hour in uh
I know and I was just I just couldn't
see there that uh pregnant did in fact
move the Rook to E8 because we were
discussing whether he would go rookie
eight or age six and uh of course the
most combative approach is played by the
young Indian I I must admit the game I
really do want to see it because it
looks like there's gonna be absolute
chaos maybe even a Czech mating attack
or King side attack it's the game
between Jordan van forest and Arjun Eric
icy because uh both players lost
yesterday they are in a fighting mood
today and they've come to the board just
ready for a big old-fashioned slugfest
indeed they have and I will I should
almost recuse myself from uh the
commentary of this game because I'm so
biased in Black's favor in these types
of positions which I've had so many
times and I think what has happened in
the last four moves is very favorable to
our gen from an objective standpoint so
Jordan played Bishop F4 which is a move
I pointed out inducing Knight a traffic
and now dropping the bishop back to E3
the point is that D5 is no longer
possible black doesn't have enough
Defenders on that square but instead a
different idea is possible F5 Queen D2
and F for anyway can't take on F4 the
queen is going to be overextended and
you're going to lose the Knight on D4
the bishop has to drop back to F2 and
now Arjun continues to accumulate the
forces with Queen to G5 this creates the
obvious threat of King H1 of Bishop H3
but you might ask well what's the point
uh since white can just play King H1 I
think the point of inducing King H1 is
that after black sticks a bishop on E5
there are constantly going to be ideas
of Knight to G3 check and when this move
comes with check it essentially forces
White's hand the last thing white wants
to do is allow an F Pawn to sneak onto
G3 for example let's say white makes a
nonchalant move like moves the queen
away to be able to recapture with the
pawn and white continues as if nothing's
happening
this is purely hypothetical because
Knight G3 here does not quite work due
to Bishop takes two three but just to
illustrate the concept these types of
positions can be incredibly dangerous
even though black doesn't have anything
actually in the attack simply on the
strength of the idea Queen H4 Queen H2
which is tremendously difficult to stop
okay so King H1
I thought your idea Knight G3 was
working I I I got very excited there
because I was like I think it does work
oh because you have Queen H5 check
because you have the check yeah the
bishop on E5 and I was like oh and then
you took it back and I was like no yeah
pessimistic there and Rook fd1 by Jordan
that's a creative defensive but Bishop
H3 he says I don't care about the King
on G1 I'm just dropping my Bishop back
to F1 and you have no way to accentuate
the pressure on G2 Arjun says no problem
I didn't want to go Bishop H3 I'm just
developing my pieces
and I think he's gonna put a bishop on
E5 he could also put the Knight on E5
but then you might experience some
problems yovi with a Pawn on D6 that
pawn is really the linchpin of Black's
construction if you lose that pawn the
Dam breaks and the water starts flowing
into Black's position
okay because uh
this is very very important to know
because people will be thinking you know
at what point do you just give up that
pawn in order just to maintain your
attack perhaps to open up some Central
lines for the Rooks to go or or do you
just grimly hold on to that pawn for as
long as you can
hmm kind of changing my mind I mean I
was trying to consider the consequences
of Knight D4 to C2 which you often see
in these positions but in that case 95
looks quite good because the problem
with Jordan's Rook F to D1 is that
Bishop H3 remains in play and if black
gets the knights E5 Bishop H3 becomes a
lot more menacing because you could
start thinking about Knight E5 takes F3
check if the bishop leaves uh E2 so I
feel like Jordan has put a Band-Aid over
the problem but he hasn't removed the
sort of underlying condition I actually
think he should have played King H1 and
what could end up happening is that he
plays King H1 anyway and then you start
wondering whether Rook f2d1 was the best
use of that tempo
yeah
um yeah it's interesting actually
because I if I were playing with the
white pieces I would be very terrified
of putting my king in the corner
primarily because of the Knight G3 ideas
that you showed especially if you back
it up with a bishop on E5 they would
become a real threat
um can I just so if you do play King H1
uh what whose move is it it's uh White's
play it's a king H1
and then Bishop E5 I love the idea by
the way and then Knight G3 is seriously
in the air so if you go B4 Knight G3
Pawn takes Pawn what's up Pawn takes
Knight then you throw in the check this
is very very important and King goes to
G1 unfortunately and then Pawn takes
pawn and you go
I am having a fantastic time here this
must this must be winning right this is
one of these positions where I haven't
backed it up with any calculation
whatsoever but I'm like uh it's so in
the bag just need to invite everyone to
the party
you're talking to a Kings Indian junkie
here so I I need no convincing I Bishop
F4 is one uh way to handle this the
point is if Bishop takes then there's
Queen H2 Queen H1 made in the bishop
can't block on G1 oh yeah it's winning
and if the queen moves away in comes the
Knight I love how black uses the E5
Square first for the bishop then the
bishop kindly steps away and makes room
for its brother the Knight 95 and that's
it if white doesn't move the queen out
of D2 Mike Plays a move like B5 as if
nothing's the matter black checks and
checks and white has to give up the
queen this is how quickly things go from
zero to a hundred in the king's Indian
you know out of a clear blue sky the
attack takes five or six moves and then
your checkmated now the last thing I'll
say yovi this is a very uh illustrative
line white should probably cut his
losses by taking with the bishop here
and forcing the queen trade the issue is
that even the end game doesn't look all
that good for white because Black's got
complete dominance over the dark squares
Knight's coming out to F6
White's definitely worse here as well
and guess what Jordan he's played B4
he starts the queen side attack and he
doesn't seem too concerned
I'd be quaking in my boots here with
white yeah me too I would not be happy
at all but I think Jordan is just
relying on keeping his King on G1 and I
suspect like he can maybe laugh at me
quite significantly because what I'm
gonna suggest is a little bit on the
ridiculous side let's hear it that the
king runs to the F1 Square rather than
H1 when it gets into trouble oh no I
think that is very likely to be exactly
what Jordan has in mind
because it's in Knight G3 the effect of
Knight G3 is diminished when you don't
have that intermediate check on H5
yeah
so uh
it's uh it's a race basically who is
gonna be quicker arjun's King side
attack or Jordan's positional space
spacecraft there in the queen side
such a fascinating game
and this is one of those games which I
don't care the result is less important
than the process as chess fans and
commentators the process of a game like
this is what makes it so exhilarating
whose attack is going to succeed and the
immediate question for Arjun is which
piece is he going to put on E5 we talked
extensively about Bishop E5 the benefit
of putting the Knight on E5 is that of
course you're essentially forcing
White's hand because Bishop H3 followed
by C5 to dislodge the knight from D4
becomes a very serious problem and I
think you're absolutely right I think he
is planning uh the defensive Retreat
King G1 to F1
and we'll see if Arjun can continue
Fanning the Flames of this attack
yeah oh and uh well whilst we wait for
the play to develop there let's uh head
over to the bird's eye view where we can
see the developments in the other games
and having a look at them and I can say
whoa It's like take your pick
Le game this is unheard of I mean okay
maybe we should quickly take a peek at
the Wesley so ding lorang game because
it was a caracon it was the master's
first caracon it's not often we see ding
play on the black side of a C5
advancement one I actually never knew
the name that you called it
foreign
s that I and let me you know caveat this
by saying that it's not a verb uh but by
saying that I'm not great with opening
names I think I'm pretty mediocre for a
GM I mean I've come across people who
know the name for like 1a4 H5 2b3 oh yes
that is the Johnson Smith uh Michelson
variation of course how did you not know
that uh but this one for some reason
I've come across before
mm-hmm okay that's uh cool because I
knew it as another and I knew and
another name that was the thing I knew
it as the kinkin aqua variation
it's interesting interesting
ah etherical came up in our pre uh show
discussion didn't he yeah yeah he did we
were complimenting his in-game play and
of course he's a great expert in these
lines
okay so we need to clear the air here we
need to remove the elephant in the room
Wesley so has not just blundered the
bishop on E5
uh with his last move because if black
takes it which is a positive distinct
possibility that dink does take it there
is a check on H5
and uh
in the event of G6 we're gonna get an
end game if our call
would be very happy but he wouldn't be
very happy with Black's position here
because after Queen F6 white can trade
on his own terms with Knight F3 and
you'll be this is the last thing you
want against someone like Wesley so this
is exactly the types of positions in
which he excels
yeah I agree no my vibe is that I don't
go into this type of ending end game not
unless you have to and the move that I
was expecting ding to do perhaps it's
some unfamiliarity with this particular
position
um is to play Knight age six
yeah to try to force white to capture on
F6 you want to put your knight on F7 and
kind of
challenge White's grip in the center
hmm
I mean I kind of expected this move
earlier
ah I can't play Bishop D3 anywhere
you're because the bishop takes D5 what
a devilish little idea Knight H6 F7
defends the bishop
it does huh
so you're prying White's fingers away
from the ledge if white plays Knight F3
that's like the most natural move I
think after Knight F7 White's kind of
experiencing some problems with you know
the king stuck in the center Queen C3 is
an unpleasant possibility why do you
think the evil bar is showing an edge
for white here what's what's the hidden
move
I I don't know
I don't know to me Knight H6 is is the
most logical move in the position
um probably it's just laughing at us and
just saying hey you have to take on F6
and then I don't know just develop the
pieces and white is better on account of
this light Square Bishop that's jammed
in by its own pawns maybe it's something
like that
I think it is well the Babar is not
going down so it must be this asshole's
castles and I think this is very very
likely
uh just by process of elimination Wesley
might choose this approach it's still
it's one of those situations where the
engine is showing like 0.4.5 but I I
don't feel like this would be all that
disappointing for ding he's got a lot of
activity he's got Knight F5 Black's
position is pretty easy to play even
though nominally you know he might be
slightly worse I I feel like if ding
navigates his way to a position like
this he should be able to hold uh hold
the draw
I I agree
um I don't see why the computer is so
pessimistic but then again like you've
said before I'm not very biased this is
one of my favorite openings I'm gonna
look for every single way to try to
justify it so yeah
same here
Knight to D2 that's a smart move by
Wesley just that that creativity that
spark you've seen it in Wesley's last
three games first his excellent
technical win against kymer then of
course yesterday his game against gukesh
which was going well for the Indian
youngster it was like plus one and then
all of a sudden kesho the complete
collapse but all credit to Wesley he
always finds ways to put his opponent
into these situations where uh you know
where it's not clear how to proceed in
gukesh already in bad form got nervous
again and uh Wesley was able to achieve
his second win in a row
yeah oh he's a he's a fantastic player
and uh it's not for no reason that when
the Champions chess tour happened he was
Magnus Carlson's biggest Contender you
know he was there every step of the way
keeping Pace with the world champion and
uh Dingle around of course he is World
Championship Contender he could be the
world champion come May
um who knows anything can happen there
and uh ding he of course is world number
two 2800s
is just a phenomenal player there's
nothing for it and when was the last
meeting do you happen to know
when did they last play against each
other
so their last meeting in a classical
chess was in 2019 at the same Fields cup
we have a really nice card here with a
couple of story lines to discuss you
mentioned of course uh ding being a
world championship Challenger and that
could give him confidence but it also
forces him to hide his opening
preparation so actually it could be a
negative their head to head series at
wike is tied with two draws
and uh of course most famously in in
2017 ding becomes the first player from
China to qualify for the candidates
where he acquitted himself incredibly
well and the craziest fact of all Yobe
is really the last one I always love uh
these these stories when two players
face each other in the early 2000s and
then 20 years later you know they're
both a top Mount Olympus
yeah uh
it's just uh I I also quite like that's
that almost 20 years ago Robert in
didn't mean this are in their first
classical matchup in 2004 World youth
Championship under 12. I was like where
was I into it 2004 I was playing in the
Calvin Olympiad and uh yeah I can
remember it was a great great event and
that was amazing 20 years ago blimey and
uh it just goes to show how amazing
these players are like uh I also saw an
interview with Jordan uh this morning
where he was talking about how he's
played at bike now for 10 years
now in my mind it's just like I'm so bad
with numbers I'm always thinking ah yeah
10 years that must mean that he's in his
uh 30s no no no no Jordan is 23. so he's
been playing if I can say since he was a
kid and I I just can't get over the
numbers about how much younger everyone
is getting and the game and I think 2004
is when Abdul satoroff was born right
so oh my God
stop it
oh my gosh
and meanwhile we do have a move from
ding he has played A5 now this is a move
that you and I were advocating but we
advocated it
very early on in the opening in fact I
would have recommended playing this A5
move even before F6 it now it could be a
case of too little too late or it could
be just a good move
I think it's somewhere in the middle I
don't think it's as effective when you
don't have a knight that you can put on
C5 in response to B5 on the other hand
A5 B5 doesn't hurt
um I think it it makes White's Queen
Side Pawn Mass a little bit less mobile
um it's somewhat weakens the C4 Pawn so
I don't think it really changes the
position all that much the one thing
that Ding has to keep in mind is of
course the possibility that Wesley
doesn't go B5 but if he doesn't go B5
then ding will take the opportunity to
simplify and you know the side that
lacks space
um and the more passive side typically
benefits When pieces get traded and I
think ding would definitely jump at the
opportunity to remove a pair of Brooks
from the board and then trade the
Bishops and you know if you're Wesley
you don't want the game to fizzle out
like that I think we're gonna see B5 and
then I think we will be likely uh to to
see that the path that we outlined uh
before we're black it's the night out
white ultimately takes on F6 and plays
Bishop f F1 to E2 and Wesley is going to
nurse this um small but stable Advantage
for the foreseeable future I think and
ding ease really struggled to equalize
with black there's B5 and once again
he's got you know a rather annoying
defensive task in front of him
yeah I agree uh somehow hasn't quite
worked out but I do think that if he
plays normally with some Knight H6
doesn't panic doesn't determine the
situation he can't study the ship and
generate enough compensation for those
positional weaknesses that he has
um should we take a look at the bird's
eye view
well you're not going to get any
resistance from me let's
go to our view of all the boards
couple the games are stabilizing it
feels like the car one Magnus game is
just sort of entering a maneuvering
phase you'll be but some of the other
games are merely heating up a lot of
transformations in the notorbeck game as
well they only have one pair of Bishops
left on the board
uh and the Geary kymer game is
percolating as well as usual I don't
know where to turn to
okay I'll I'll make the decision for you
it's the day is the position is the game
with the nicest Pawn structure I want
with the one where one side has all
their pawns on virtually the white
squares and the other side has thorns
and the dark squares
it's not often you see that
configuration
I'm gonna give you the nod or the nutter
back
yes go to tournament leaders game
against Mr aronian is this just dead
equal or
would you say that white has a little
something something going here
yeah I mean when it comes to closed
positions I always think of them as um
almost like both sides have their
fortresses and you just I always
Envision these kind of medieval castles
and one side has a catapult and they're
trying to get a line into this Fortress
just to so that they can get their
troops in to invade and so basically
what I'm trying to say just using these
analogies is that you have to look at
Pawn breaks if your Pawn breaks are
going to be effective for instance C3 in
this particular position and for black
it would be C5 C4 then
um
or even G6 then
one side can use the rest of their
forces to infiltrate I do feel that this
position might be headed into a drawer
just because I don't see any effective
openings so for instance now
I mean we could even see a repetition of
moves right so we could see nordeback
saying no I don't want to offer up and
don't want to trade off Queens so I just
want to go Queen B5 check and then
aronia will say how about now and not
abec will say no and go back and then we
have this
dance between Korean Queens
because uh
I also would be calculating what happens
after Queen takes queen king takes and
then C3 the problem is there is going to
be no line opening that's going to be
effective
because after C3 black can back up the
pawn on D4 by either supporting it with
a bishop or maybe going C5
yeah let's pull up a board here or
Bishop C5 and it could totally backfire
like the D3 Pawn uh becomes very very
tender
as a result but I would also argue that
perhaps I can go Queen C6 check here
this does not win a rook black has the
simple King to E7 and on the next move
you could get that repetition you
mentioned Queen E8 Queen C4 Queen back
to F7 I don't know if white really can
use this Tempo uh to do anything special
I was looking at B4 like this almost
works I was looking at B4 a b Bishop
takes before unfortunately this leads
absolutely nowhere because you take this
Pawn but the king you know easily hides
away on f8 I'm surprised the Evo bar is
not as far down as you think it would be
probably after Queen takes B6 you know
this is nothing to sneeze at but you
know leading the tournament and playing
like this are rather incompatible I
think Notre back would much rather play
a peaceful move like B3 and uh you know
acquiesce to what would be a very solid
result I mean he's a point ahead of the
field he's playing a lebanaronian who's
been unbeatable this tournament so you
know I don't think we're going to see
Notre back taking any crazy risks but
yoby am I missing anything in this
position or do you think that we're
going to be likely to see some sort of a
repetition or the position drying up in
a positional draw
um
Nordic has been playing quite
aggressively as of late so it wouldn't
surprise me if he does go for the most
aggressive continuation playing for some
kind of B4
um but then again he's in the lead
it's the day before the rest day you
kind of want a solid gentle start
to that day so that you can properly
enjoy the rest day because there's
nothing worse than going into the rest
day on the back of a loss
you just have like one whole day just to
criticize yourself and uh that's no fun
so yeah
I I'm I suspect we're gonna see
something like you've indicated B3
Queen C4 and then here you go but I mean
what about Iranian could aronian just
decide
I want to play on for the win for
instance because I mean we talked about
white opening lines but let's not forget
that there is G6 in the air that is one
way to open up the position
I think
I would inclined to say no because I
think G6 suffers from a similar fault to
White's C3 which is that it softens up
the F6 spawn and white is very much
equipped to handle that by taking on G6
and then quickly doubling Rooks on the
app file from lavon's perspective you
know he has a lot of the same
considerations he's on plus one he's got
a good score
um and if he draws with black against
the tournament leader that'll give him a
nice little confidence boost going into
the rest day so it seems to me that uh I
think there's a there's a name for this
in Game Theory or neither side you know
uh is the one who who will deviate from
this path that they're both following by
inertia that leads directly to some sort
of repetition or a draw not trying to uh
you know reduce the excitement of this
game I think there's plenty of Chess
left to be played but I'd give this a 50
chance that we see one kind of
repetition or another and you know
neuterbeck we've sung his Praises
throughout the tournament you know we've
talked extensively about uh his level of
talent and the support for Notre back on
on social media has been astounding
press caught up with with the young
Uzbek Talent yesterday to ask him if
he's keeping up with all of the hype and
how it's affecting his play Let's listen
I I definitely uh read some some news of
course but
uh I'm generally
very focused on tournament uh during his
tournament so yeah
um I don't I don't read uh much but yeah
I I know some news about in my country
Uzbekistan uh all uh chess fans are
supporting me so yeah I'd like to thank
them
for their support and yeah I will try my
best
well after his astounding performance at
the last Olympiad yovi in a
well-publicized event I think notrebec
received a car in an apartment from the
president of Uzbekistan who met the team
at the airport gotta say that's pretty
cool
yeah that is pretty cool yeah I know he
got the apartment after winning the
world rapid Championship
um I think also in that interview he
talks about working with a Kazi majanov
and of course kajimajanov is from
Uzbekistan and he was basically a
national hero and he was someone that
Abdus idolized as a kid and so he just
felt incredibly honored to be working
with such a renowned player and Coach
yeah we mustn't forget that kazir
majanov was also a world champion
himself
in fact he became world champion of
memory service being right in the year
of Notre bag's birth in 2004 in Tripoli
Libya at the fide World Cup uh where he
defeated Michael Adams in the final so
you know everything seems to come full
circle I mean there's so many
significant dates
and uh how amazing that notorbeck gets
to work with his childhood Idol somebody
with such a wealth of experience someone
who's worked extensively with Fabi and
uh you know I'm positive that their
relationship extends far beyond just you
know solving puzzles I'm sure it's it's
a mentor mentee relationship and
together with Ivan sokolov the
experienced Jim who coached the
Uzbekistan Olympia team notabeg has
benefited from the wisdom of you know
some Elder Statesman that is so
impactful so important in a young
player's career and you'll be it's not
about the rating yes Notre back is
higher rated than rustam but as chess
players we know that that could not be
less significant
oh absolutely I mean it's about the
influence a person has on you and it's
the effect they also give you I mean for
instance you don't want someone who's
just going to make you feel bad you want
someone who's going to make you feel
like you can achieve anything and uh
again that person has to also know how
to use the resources sometimes it's even
can take on a managerial role as in the
sense that if you're working with a team
they will direct the other team members
and say okay this we need this
information they will almost sometimes I
mean I've seen hired certain information
that could be negative from the person
who wants to become more Champion I'm I
mean it's a very very important role and
it's as we see it saw kazir majanov is a
fantastic coach with Fabi you know
together they got up to challenge Magnus
Carlson for the world championship and
here we see in order back under
casimerjanov's influence now
well he's like leading I can say
classical tournament and uh I can just
see the move that was played there Queen
C6 check on the board
and it's just like you called it Dania
you are the new chess prophet
you give me Dania any position he will
tell you what the players play next
well I I feel like yeah King E7 I was
gonna make a very bold prediction and
say one will not blunder both of his
Rooks in one move
and just the way Lavon is sitting back I
think he's convinced that the the game
will end with this queen E8 Queen F7
repetition we will keep a close eye on
the tournament leader as he decides
really between something risky like G4
or yielding to the repetition which I
think is far more likely given his
tournament situation one more quick look
at the bird's eye view we see so many
Rich games today Eric icy trying to
Checkmate Jordan on the black side of a
king's Indian report prognananda
following precisely the path that you
set out with the Knight jumping into for
the carwana game is heating up even
further Fabby with F2 F4 and likely
going to follow that up with E5 so
definitely something to examine when we
return but we will indeed take a short
second break ladies and gentlemen this
is our coverage of round eight of the
Tata steel chess tournament you can see
a view beautiful view of that vast
expansive playing Hall and there we have
no Rebecca abdussator of the tournament
leader we will leave you with Notre back
and we will be back in just a couple of
short minutes
[Music]
this is Doug chesh you guys this is a
new variant it's called duck chess chess
but with a duck quack quack how to play
duck chest the duck is a brick pieces
cannot move through the square occupied
by the duck they kind of scared to place
the dog
[Music]
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the Pawn's Kingdom too oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still me but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it I think this works oh
that's a horrible blunder oh my God I
just blundered I have to move something
else first then dark and Knight will
take my king this is the best way to
lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chess so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
foreign
we are back this is our coverage of
round eight of the Tata steel chess
tournament 2023 85 years of Excellence
of exciting Fighting Chess this is a
13-round marathon event and we are more
than halfway through a look at the
playing haul look at those Spectators
over at the front every square inch is
occupied everybody in the vicinity wants
to see Magnus Carlson and Notre back
abdusitar of display their best chess
and motorbike has indeed displayed his
best chess as we take one quick look at
the current leaderboard after seven
rounds round eight is in progress we
don't have any results yet and yovi I
mean we can say it again and again it
Bears repeating again and again an
absolute breakout performance by
notorbeck abdusitorov and if he's able
to win Tata steel this will be something
that he tells his grandkids about yeah
it will make him a national hero let's
face it I mean he's just playing a
blinding tournament I mean this is
incredible five and a half out of seven
defeating Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces I is just insane what he's doing
and it just seems like he's doing it so
effortlessly he hasn't been in trouble
on any of his games and uh yesterday he
just played such a beautiful game
against Arjun aragaisy I mean it's just
it's like we're seeing a work of art and
maybe even I'm going to say a future
Champion develop because to be 18 years
old
up there with the world's best in the
world's strongest tournament
I mean it's just unbelievable
15 years old just keep thinking about it
there's an ad up in your head how many
more years of his prime he it hasn't
even entered his Prime and these are the
results that he is already displaying
amazing stuff as we go to the bird's eye
view we've got a lot of games that are
moving so so fast if you look at Geary
kymer over on the top right we've had a
mass Liquidation in that game Geary
stands up a pawn but Vincent has that
Bishop pair that Bishop on A7 attacking
the F2 Pawn that game at least
intuitively seems to me approximately
balanced so we will examine that end
game in due course but you'll be I think
everybody in the chat is itching to go
to the Magnus game because that game is
virtually unrecognizable compared to
that complicated middle game they had a
couple of moves ago there's a knight
that's hanging on F6 let's figure out
what's going on in Magnus Carlson land
okay so let me rewind a couple of moves
to 95. it was a sort of a normal Rich
position with a closed Center Watch What
Happens Knight A3 rookie eight okay
improving the position Bishop drops back
Bishop drop back and bang Carlson just
the recipient of lightning play by
carwana as he smashes through in the
center F4 and then E5
but the world champion as usual responds
in incredible Zen fashion he doesn't
panic when he does he trades on E5 the
Knight on F6 it looks like it has
nowhere to go it looks like White's
gonna sacrifice on F7 to the Checkmate
no no no Knight takes D4 CD and Bishop
D7 to C6 you'll be a brilliant move that
I'm quite confident I'd be on a carwana
simply missed
yeah and uh perhaps we can go through
the lines of why why can't capture the
night because after porn takes night I'm
sure everyone is thinking well this
takes work but aha you don't have to
capture that Rook with the queen take it
with a bishop and what happens next
bang is what happens next The Rook takes
the bishop anyway
and after Queen takes B3 it's the other
Rook lpdo goes the abbreviation loose
pieces drop off as Dr John Nunn uh would
remind us and after Queen takes D4 check
The Rook on A1 is forked and not only
that white loses all of his other pieces
as well the whole position just
collapses like a house of cards this is
out of the question Yogi and that means
but white can probably take on you one
with the queen but this is promises no
relief either here black just takes on
B3 and swings the queen up to D5 this is
completely lost and that means
white cannot take on F6 and if you can't
take on F6 look at Black's control over
this crucial D5 Square Carlson is gonna
plant a knight on that square carwana's
pawns are going to be frozen in space
and White's King is going to start
feeling mighty uncomfortable as are he's
very very loose minor pieces on the
queen side I think Carlson is taking
over the initiative
yeah I mean what a fantastic move Bishop
C6 that comes like a cold shower I mean
it was brilliant tactical vision from
the world champion and okay
so Fabi obviously in the tank thinking
about how he can fix this because he has
some troubles with coordination I mean
his Knight in on A3 I recommended
putting it there it was a resolution of
being there
it is my fault
Bobby was channeling me don't do it Abby
don't go there
um
what I'm thinking of is that okay so
that Knight needs to be introduced into
the game
um the light Square Bishop it's loose
loose pieces drop off that's also
concerning me so I'm also thinking of
push putting the bishop on C4
just to kind of solidify the positions
somewhat maybe the Knight can drop back
to C2 I know it's
it's not ambitious let's face it but uh
needs must
think that's there yes this is where I'm
going you're understanding me put the
Knight back on C2 protect
who came up with the idea of bringing it
out to A3 I mean what kind of outlandish
developing move is that Fabian Corona
making the one mistake you could never
make
um although I think if you trusted me uh
he would have played Knight T2 and
blundered Knight T3 so the very least he
still has all his minor pieces the
reality of the situation though yo is
that he right now White's priority is on
not losing any pieces like he's not even
thinking about removing the knight from
T5 that's basically impossible the thing
is if you take that Knight the queen
replaces it and that's an even worse
outcome so it's not about whatever what
pieces on D5 it's about Black's control
over that square so if you take on A6
and you focus on Pawn grabbing there is
no way that you will get away with that
even the simple Bishop B4 forces The
Rook onto a square and wherever it moves
it's going to get forked this is
incredibly alarming for Fabiano caruana
the Eva bar is not giving a major
advantage to black and it appears that
the best move here is actually to
advance the pawn past the Knight play
the move E6 and open up the other Bishop
try to stabilize the situation in the
center let me say that is not an easy
move to blind and if he doesn't find it
I'm starting to get worried not only for
the position but also for his clock you
could easily take 30 minutes in a
position like this 30 minutes that he
just doesn't have
yeah that is a radical move
um it's very hard to make those type of
moves because you know symbolically
those two pawns by themselves yeah
they're blockaded then they're not great
but they do stand together and just to
disrupt that and go for peace activity
well that isn't Mark of class so if Fabi
plays it and actually I think he will
um
then of course everything will be
balanced but the position it's open it's
wild
it is and it just seems much easier to
play or Carlson there also also is the
move Rook E1 to F1 renewing the threat
of taking the Knight then the Knight
will drop into D5 perhaps white can
mount
counter play based on an attack on the
F7 pawn something like Queen H5 maybe
Rook C1 so I would hesitate I wouldn't
want to overstate the case here I think
objectively White's position is still
okay but there's no doubt in my mind
that it is crucial for Fabiano to play
very very accurately in the next three
or four moves and he knows that you know
you can see that with the naked eye and
that is why he's investing a significant
amount of time into this critical moment
you can just see Fabiano caruanna deep
in thought but one thing is for a
certain Yogi I think he missed Bishop C6
otherwise he wouldn't have gone F4 E5
yeah I agree with you but I have to say
it is forgivable that he missed Bishop
C6 because I mean when you get to this
position in your mind you are just
assuming night moves you don't
necessarily think about your opponent's
tactical opportunities
no you do not and the Knight just didn't
have a lot of squares Knight F6 to H5
might have been a move that he focused
on and problem for black there is that
white has the Desperado sack on F7 and
only then does he pick up the Knight
with interest let's not even talk about
Knight H7 that is not the kind of move
that it's in Magnus Carlson's dictionary
white could have set the second Pawn in
motion I'll just show uh the Knight H5
line because if not for Bishop takes F7
black is all right here but boom goes
the dynamite and then the queen picks up
the Knight white is very much in charge
here
in the event of Knight H7 Whitehead at
the very least a move like D5 and E6 is
coming to a theater near you but it's
this one move right that's what super
Grand Master chess comes down to it's
always one move one detail one tiny
Nuance that's the difference between
success and failure
yeah and uh
well we have to say hats off to the
world champion for finding such a
beautiful resource and okay things are
not critical yet for Fabi he still has
to find a few accurate moves so let's
not write him off but the situation is
definitely
well it's getting worse for Fabi he just
has to handle it precisely from now on
Abby is a full point ahead of Magnus
Carlson and he holds second place
currently along with Anish Geary Wesley
and prognananda it is a log gym at the
top here uh fight for second place a dog
fight and it's very important or Fabi
for a niche for Wesley to win this game
um Notre big draws which he's very
likely to do then they will shrink his
lead by 50 but we also have some juicy
stats Carlson and carlana are no
strangers they have played dozens of
times they've played nine times in vikan
say alone Carlson leads their head to
head 12 wins 38 tries including nine of
them in the world championship and of
course or 11 of them I think the world
championship in five losses only
just great stats here all around Yogi
yeah I I know and uh the one that says
really disconcerting to me is that
Carlson eight-time tattoo Steel champion
is making his 19th appearance at what I
can say again like how I mean the world
champion is just just 30 31 how
I mean but I mean it just goes to show
how how often these guys playing at Mike
and say and also just how esteemed they
have that uh tournament in their
estimations and we see also caruana is
making his 13th appearance in I can say
yeah so it's not very experienced
you must be feeling some nerves you know
you just never really there's no way I
can say that well he doesn't know where
to eat
you know he hasn't been in the hotel
many times
only come on Step It Up Fabby yeah
complete newbie and in 2010 they drew
their first ever meeting in Reich
2010 not that long ago but apparently it
was 15 times 40 13 years ago
yeah
feels like a different era doesn't it I
was looking at some commercials from
2010 recently and
I mean just by the definition alone you
just know that you're in a totally
different Millennium almost
it's quite funny because many things
change and other things don't and I
think I was watching an old Jennifer
Lopez video and she just looks the same
there's no doubt about that she's as
stunning as always but the technology
was definitely like okay this is 1998
here foreign
vision is going to happen in the future
and there's always like the same kind of
technology and also another film that I
was watching was Blade Runner the
original one
and how they visualized it to be in 20
whatever it was and I was like and they
their technology was still very much
linked to 1980s computer screens and
things it made me laugh
it's fascinating I'm a big fan of you
know listening to predictions and
futurism that entire rabbit hole is
fascinating well one thing remained
constant the Berlin was still popular uh
Magnus Carlson was still a beast in 2010
as was Fabiano caruana but it's just so
interesting to see the path that these
players follow through the years well as
we speak our wanna now drops below 40
minutes he's going to make have to make
a move pretty soon but I could easily
see him taking another 15 minutes here
so critical so important it is to find
the correct path and I think that gives
us an opportunity to swing back to the
bird's eye view because all of these
games are rapidly transforming a report
has just taken prague's night on F4
enabling Prague to open up that e-file
kukesh Maxwell some trades in that game
as well yovi the abdicator of game has
gone into an end game one in which I
really can't see either side making any
significant progress I think that'll be
the first result of the day and the
kymer game is Just unrecognizable the
Queens are off the board shall we take a
closer look at what happened there
yeah definitely because uh we have a
very interesting scenario it's a very
unbalanced end game on the board and uh
First Sight it looks like it's going to
be a battle of the bishop pair
against the bishop of Knight but I'll
take a look at this bishop on A7 it's a
bit of a dud that's starring at a brick
wall so the first thing that I would be
looking at is uh trying to break it open
and uh yeah you called it I want to be
playing C5
hmm
I like C5 and if white goes D5 you have
the typical response C4
quite kind of like benoni style opening
up the diagonal
I guess as white I'd be thinking about
taking the sting out of G4 with a move
like H3
would you take on D4 here
um I think I'd keep it in my pocket for
a while and instead improve some pieces
um the one who I think
could be improved is The Rook I think
the Rook belongs on E7 protecting the E7
no no not E2
yeah no I wasn't I I wasn't implying
that you were thinking that I just
wanted to
show the important fact that the bishop
controls that square
yeah and the reason I'm putting on E7 is
because I'm simply following the rule of
over protection that I know that super
Grand Masters love to do that's it
indeed they do and it is important to
keep this bishop under a lock and key
but you know what's worrying me is that
again this game is starting to follow
the narrative that's been all too common
in Vincent's last four games where all
of them have reached an end game at one
time or another yesterday against thing
he was in the driver's seat he was
playing without risk and you know he
messed it up so much so that at the end
we were almost talking about a three
result game but the two rounds before
that Vincent got a worse end game it was
defensible he came very close to drawing
and then all of a sudden his opponents
managed to crack his resistance at the
last second Levon aronian and Wesley so
earning points off of kymers and game
play and once again Yogi it seems to me
to be the kind of situation where white
is playing for two results I don't think
black's got full compensation for the
pawn
and that last move d4 it really changed
the landscape of the position entirely
now the bishop looks bad now The Rook
isn't getting to E2 and the last thing
I'll point out is that the moochi 4 is
very dangerous in the middle game but in
the end game it's totally innocuous
white could even respond with a cheeky
Rook to E1 and if the Rooks get off the
board well that a pawn is going to have
its moment in the sonnets
eventually going to rush forward to A5
that night isn't going to be there
forever Bishop D7 you can homily drop
down to B5 you ain't giving away that
pawn
uh and man I'm getting very concerned on
Vincent's behalf here
yeah me too and uh it seems to be a
trend as you have you as you've pointed
out you know Vincent goes into the end
game a pawn down
and then holds holds holes and at the
very last minute tends to crack under
the pressure
um I have to be honest I didn't realize
that Vincent was a pawn down I didn't I
made that terrible mistake of not
counting the Pawns
I assumed that that was all equal
somewhere but no I do feel that Vincent
needs to do something now he needs to
generate some play he needs to apply
pressure to the white porn Santa
I mean Rook B8 that might be the best
path forward but Vincent he's been
struggling and some guy named Wesley so
uh after beating gukesh another
struggling Junior Wesley had some advice
for the younger generation of players
who are struggling in these difficult
events let's listen in to Wesley's Sage
words
you know I think you just gotta enjoy
the game you gotta take these losses and
you gotta keep working keep improving
when you're a teenager the ratings don't
really matter that much and you play for
For the Love of the Game
um
and we have a lot of great teenagers in
this tournament well I'm still not sure
who's going to become a professional a
few years from now or maybe they all
will
but I guess you just gotta keep learning
and improving and and you learn a lot
more from your losses then
very wise words by Wesley so I think the
operative phrase there Yogi is that the
rating it doesn't matter as much when
you're as young as Vincent and good cash
Because You're Gonna Play in 15 more
Tata Steels you're playing 15 20
tournaments a year so you have to focus
on extracting the lessons from the most
difficult tournaments so much easier
said than done though isn't it yeah and
uh Wesley actually said it himself he
said this is advice just for the younger
players for me he said I'm old I can
take those drawers
and uh yeah I totally agree with his
advice you know when you're young
give it your all it is uh every single
day game just play it out until the
better end and uh however
however things happen it doesn't matter
what matters is that you're going to
learn from it I say for instance like
yesterday's game um maxoodloo against
the Fabiana caruana it was insane what
actually happened I mean if we think
about it logically because it was a
total draw but maxillou just press press
over press and suddenly it was a
turnaround and from that very
instructive Queen ending we learned
something there didn't we I was like I I
didn't know about this whole thing about
advancing the age porn utilizing the
king and knowing just instinctively how
to identify which king and queen endings
are drawn which ones are lost and okay
these are lessons to put in the memory
bank and then you can apply them when
they occur because inevitably they do
occur in your games
I'm totally in the same boat on the
basis of that game and the Carlson Notre
back end game I would already feel much
more comfortable handling let's say a
queen in two pawns versus queen and pawn
or queen and pawn versus queen end game
in one of my own games so you know this
is really the the amazing thing about
getting to compensate this tournament
getting to watch the games you know I
feel my brain expanding as I look at
these games and as I look at these
amazing performances well we're watching
Vincent take his sweet time on this move
18 minutes 19 minutes and Counting now
uh he's thinking after the move d4 it
appears that Rook E8 to B8 is the only
way to really keep the objective balance
you have to squeeze that Rook into B2
but your move C5 I think is very
tempting as well I'd say with plenty of
time he played very very quickly in the
first stage of this game as his opponent
so I'm expecting a slow burn as this end
game gets underway well some of the
other games are not slow Burns they are
fast Burns and uh I think we should take
one more look at the bird's eye view
before deciding where we jump to next
here we go oh
yeah
um
I I know we've just come off this game
but I do still feel that there's so much
play and that things are happening at a
dangerous speed I mean it would be great
to revisit the Fabiana Corona
because the quit is on D5 I mean Black's
pieces are just swarming forward and of
course that Knight on F6 hasn't moved I
mean it's still up for grabs
Fabiano Caron is blundered Fabiano
caruana has made a huge mistake and in
the position after Bishop C6 he took us
that he recognized that the position was
critical but he just wasn't able to
navigate his way out of the chaos his
decision was to bring the bishop back to
C2 and this move is a big error because
he relinquishes the pressure on F7
he thinks that this move is finally
gonna Force the Knight out of F6 but no
no no this move is not what he missed
Queen D5 threatens mate Fabiano says no
problem what he missed is the brilliant
next move which Carlson issued after
only a couple of minutes of thought Rook
B8 to B4 and you might look at this and
say well that's a blunder because
finally I can take this darn Knight on
F6 and yet you still cannot as far as I
understand and the reason why is Rook
takes D4
still looks like no problem everything's
protected but after Rook takes E2 Queen
takes E2 The Rook swings forward to D2
obscuring the G2 Pawn doesn't matter
where the queen goes black will take G2
with a completely one-sided devastating
attack and look at this line Queen F3
you can win the game with Queen D4 check
but even prettier it's the still take on
G2 removing the defender and white gets
checkmated in just a couple of moves
this is unbelievable and Yobe if white
doesn't take on the F6 and you play
Bishop F2 no you cannot because you get
checkmated Fabiano simply has no way to
defend the D4 Pawn I would go so far as
to say that he is completely lost
oh wow
it is unbelievable uh okay so it's Fabi
is already in Desperate trouble okay I
mean can Fabi just take a deep breath
and look at a a way to defend his
position is there any move that will
cause Magnus some trouble so the first
move that I'm thinking about
and doesn't work because the D4 Pawn is
going to be captured with check I was
thinking about the queen moving over the
Rook coming to D2
um so say The Rook comes to D2 let's try
that one how is that going to pan out
oh to God
this is Checkmate on G2
okay this is wild
relaxed let's try again attempt number
two attempt number two
um I was thinking Queen E1 that was uh
one thing I had in mind but then this
queen takes D4 right and
there's check and you have to play
Bishop F2 King H2 and
I mean I would even take sorry to show
off you know I would take with a rook
here I think that's even simpler
and I'm still tortured by that
whole thing on the second rank I mean I
just can't escape it it's not fabby's
day
um
King HD yeah but this
this is resignable I mean even better
but Knight to H5
yeah that looks oh
okay
goodbye
no no no no back back okay and Fabi oh
did you catch that glare
his who he was angry with himself
because how many moves are we into the
game let's have a yeah this is White's
24th move
oh you do not want to lose
with the white pieces in under 26 moves
20 30 moves it kind of
it's not good
um anything
no you can't resign now you don't resign
this type of position you've got to
fight it all the way okay okay okay King
H2
Let's uh follow the golden rule of oh
but over protection okay and then the
the
Queen
ah I don't know Queen B1 I don't know
well preparing Bishop B3 I think this is
a sensible defensive approach but the
issue and Carlson is so much time to
figure out the killer blow I'm playing
off of instinct Rook D2 looks totally
devastating because the threat is
actually Queen takes G2 check if you go
here Bang
and there's a windmill at the end of the
line look at this takes takes
snap the bishop back to G2 take the
bishop back to G2 oh this is just a
massacre
yeah this is uh
that's not good
um
okay but it
it's happening though that's the thing
Rook takes D4 is happening like it or
not
so you just have to deal with it in and
anyway you can and
Queen C1 isn't it the same kind of thing
I liked your root Knight h
M what about your knight H4 move age
five sorry
I think this is one of the situations in
which everything works I mean I like
Knight t7 here because you're gonna win
a second Pawn in the center but Knight
H5 looks phenomenal as well if you move
the bishop away you either get mated or
you lose the pawn on E5 and that the
most soul-crushing thing about this
position is not just the black has the
devastating attack it's that black will
also emerge at least two pawns up so
White's getting mated and he's two pawns
up and Fabiano is now down to 30 minutes
I mean you the words this is over are
very dangerous and you don't speak them
until it's actually over the thing is
when Magnus Carlson is handling the
black pieces yovi in a position like
this he just doesn't let opportunities
like this pass him by I am in total
total disbelief at how quickly this
situation has deteriorated fatally for
Mr caruana
yeah
I'm not surprised actually that it's
deteriorated so quickly because uh open
positions are notorious for being
incredibly tricky you make one bad move
and that blunder will cost you the game
in a closed position okay you can make
maybe three inaccuracies and you haven't
lost
um the game you or you haven't like you
maybe you've neutralized uh sorry maybe
you've gone from a small advantage to an
equal position and that's it but this
type of position is wild every mistake
WIll count
um
King
no moves I I'm stuck no moves
there are no moves I mean it's totally
lost Rook takes D4 pre-move
and literally pre-move Rook D2 doesn't
matter how white tries to defend upon
Queen D3 does not do anything it doesn't
threaten mate
and yovi we talked about this
extensively the tendency of the Chess
World especially with respect to Magnus
Carlson to jump to conclusions way too
quickly even within the same tournament
he's washed up this is an indicator that
his career is going downhill folks it's
one tournament and it's not even one
tournament it's half of one tournament
haven't we already learned our lesson
that's for Magnus Carlson doesn't matter
how he's doing in the first half of the
tournament great athletes are exactly
the same way doesn't matter how Michael
Jordan would play in the first half of
the game you could come back in the
second half and score 45 points Rafael
Nadal could lose the first two sets and
then play the greatest three sets of his
life to come back how many times have
they done that Agnes Carlson is exactly
the same way and I think we are very
likely to be witnessing right now the
beginning of one of the most
unbelievable comebacks we might see
there's six more rounds to go and if
Carlson continues in the spirit
in order back to producatorov is going
to be quaking in his boots I'm jumping
the gun here obviously but two wins in a
row like this to get back to plus one
is already unfathomable Yogi given the
situation we were just in
yeah I I have to say I agree with you uh
a lot of the time whenever Magnus has a
slight off day I mean the chest will
just completely just says who's you know
what is he doing he's washed up he's
getting old he's gonna focus on poker I
saw I mean but that's just ridiculous I
mean I mean I'm sorry I saw so many
negative comments and it's just really
guys it's just a bad day at the office
everyone has those and uh Magnus and I I
remember Hikaru Nakamura had a quote
that I really liked and Magnus has the
same philosophy if you if you get hit
you don't get knocked down you get back
up you just simply carry on you don't
it's just about building up that soft
sense so that you don't have a glass jaw
you need to be tough you need to be
resilient you need to have grit and okay
one bad result you can have five bad
results or 10 bad results or one year of
bad results doesn't matter keep plodding
along keep on going and uh don't indulge
yourself on all this negative thinking
don't spiral down that's just a waste of
your time waste of your energy and
instead just to keep on going keep on
doing what you love to do and Magnus he
loves chess he wants to be 2900 he said
that so okay
he will take whatever he can he will do
whatever it takes to get him there and
if it involves playing some bad chess on
occasion okay that's just life
very well said and I would just
contribute one more point which is that
if you look at Magnus Carlson's two
losses right it wasn't really even the
case as Fabiano accepts the inevitable
and plays King H2 the best move the only
way to at least prolong the fight get
the king out of the immediate danger
zone but Magnus is going to take on D4
it really wasn't a case of Magnus
playing that badly against Anish giri
phenomenal opening preparation and
almost a Flawless end game played by a
niche then again subdue Satora one of
Notre breakfast's greatest games if not
his greatest game from a purely
objective standpoint the guy played like
an engine the entire game Carlson
defended with Incredible resilience in
that game it came down to a queen end
game that could have been a draw if
Magnus had made one move differently so
our tendency is always to blame Magnus
and say he's playing terribly in this
case he didn't play as well as he is
capable of but it's also a case of his
opponents playing some of their absolute
best games and we know what magnus's
opponents are capable of let's not
forget that they are also the greatest
players in the world for very good
reason in any case Rook takes D4 is on
the board let's not jump the gun it's
not over just yet Queen B1 on the board
and Yogi we talked about this if Magnus
plays Rook D2 Fabiano will resign
immediately
I I think you're absolutely right it's
Rook D2 with a killer threat of Queen
takes Pawn as you spotted and This
Magnificent windmill in operation it's
yeah uh it's uh devastating for Carolina
I have to say I mean he had he had a
great opening what can I say I mean it
was slightly better for him it looked
like he was in his comfort zone but then
he struck in the center just that little
bit too early and Magnus was ready with
this magnificent tactical shot and now
Magnus just gonna make it look easy and
what he's doing now is
checking double checking seeing what
happens after Rook D2 because I'm 100
sure that he will play that move I mean
it's just crying out to be played and
totally is
yeah I was just gonna say there's just
no no way for whites to hold on actually
I mean I was wondering whether white
could try to hold on try to not reduce
material and the answer is no absolutely
not you have to drop a piece you have to
cover this deadly idea on G2
mm-hmm
oh and it's all Fallen apart for Fabi
and shaking his head there
if you look at the subsequent pairings
or a Magnus Carlsen again you want to
avoid this temptation of falling into
narrative murder this is what's going to
happen and he's got easy opponents but
let's be real he's got kukesh with the
white pieces
uh after this game after the rest day
and the way gukesh has been playing I
mean this is a game a Magnus is very
much looking forward to playing if he
wins that one he goes to plus two and
potentially if the cards fall in his
favor I mean he might already be with a
win in the next round against kukesh
half a point away from the lead you
could probably invent some mathematics
invent some hypothetical in which he's
already tied for the lead that's
obviously virtually impossible then he's
got maxoodloo Wesley Prague and Eric icy
you know it's it's crazy to talk about
easier and harder pairings everybody
here is an absolute beast but he's got
two whites in a row uh to finish off the
tournament rounds 11 and 12 eov so
Magnus is looking at his pairings and I
can guarantee you in his mind he's
already expecting himself to win this
tournament I know it sounds radical but
that's what he's actually telling
himself not what he's saying in the
interviews but what is actually actual
expectations are for himself
yeah I agree with you he's a man who's
confident in his own abilities and that
confidence will set him up in good shape
for the remainder of the tournament and
what I've noticed about Magnus is that
he doesn't tend to think about the
results overall I mean he just knows
that he can win this
it's just that when he sits down in the
chessboard and I've said this time and
time again and I repeat myself again
once more but I simply think that he's
in his element this is his comfort zone
this is his meditation and so put him in
front of the board
he is just going to be 100 dedicated and
focused on playing chess I mean I saw an
interview he did in Norway chess 2021
and he said to be fair he said he didn't
have done too much preparation before
the event or even during the event but
once he was sat there at the board he
made sure he gave 100 to the game and it
was that effort that he put where he
worked so hard at the board that made
sure that he won the event and
it's just an interesting question you
know when was the last time you kind of
gave 100
to anything
because normally you kind of give 60 80
and you kind of hold yourself back but
this willingness to push yourself to the
edge
that's rare I think
and it's what I appreciate so much about
Magnus you know even when he plays
casual Blitz matches on chess.com which
has been doing a lot of you can just
sense that for him this isn't just a
casual way to spend an evening this
isn't just you know a way to chill out
he's playing full strength he's playing
real openings he's producing
masterpieces on the board and I guess
when you reach this level of Excellence
you know Magnus feels that he owes it to
himself uh to put in as you're saying
100 150 because when he does he's just
able to produce works of art on such a
consistent basis you know we should we
should take in this moment we should
really take it in fully because you just
never know when somebody of this caliber
of this level of dominance is going to
rise to prominence again so appreciate
every moment and uh you know especially
appreciate the way that this tournament
is going to end because we are in for an
epic finale with Notre back Beeston in
first place but Magnus Carlson saying
that he still has a few things left to
say in this 85th edition of Tata steel
well Rook be Rook D2 is going to end the
game conceivably Magnus could take 10
minutes to play that move so I think
this affords us a good opportunity to go
back to the bird's eye view and we will
bring you the results of this game as
soon as we know it the moment Magnus
makes a move we will update you on that
as well but the other games haven't
stopped to wait uh yovi you can see
kymer there playing d65 interesting
choice and the end game between Abdus
and aronian is sort of heating up a
little bit as well but I still think is
well within the bounds of a peaceful
result man all of the games are
interesting really without exception I I
agree with that and I can't quite make
up my mind you know the game between
Richard Rapport pregnant and catches my
eye because I'm like oh there's a very
unpleasant ugly looking coordination of
pieces that um or Richard and of course
I'm still absolutely fascinated between
the tussle in the tussle between van
forest and Eric Argent aragaisi because
I actually can't make up my mind I don't
know who is going to crash through
it looks like Jordan has the advantage
to begin with but of course this could
dissipate with just one inaccuracy from
Van Forest I'm going to leave it to you
Daniel
oh and it looks like they might be
repeating moves
let's jump to that game because we
actually might have a result
uh within a couple of minutes here if
both Eric icy and benforest decide that
a draw is the rightful result so let's
go to that game and see exactly why they
are repeating moves so here's what's
happening uh van Forest drives this Pawn
down to A6 trying to fix the pawn on A7
in the event the black plays C5
prematurely the Knight will swing over
to B5 and then both of these pawns are
going to be in the crosshairs uh Arjun
plays a com move Rook e to d8 supporting
the pawn Jordan drops back to attack D6
Arjun moves forward to defend encounter
attack the C4 pawn and Jordan moves up
to D4 and of course the point is that
Bishop takes C4 is not possible because
by Pawn on B6 isn't protecting its
neighbor on C6 Bishop takes D4 white
will simply take well I can Stave off
the inevitable but not avoid it takes
and Knight takes C6 with a fork against
the two Rooks but even if this wasn't a
fork the end game is out of the question
for black and so the bishop has moved
back to D7 the big question now the ball
is in Jordan's Court I think Arjun is
probably fine with the repetition UV not
100 sure of that
my guess is that Jordan will go for the
repetition just because Black's Knight
is so imposing and the idea of Knight G3
check very much still in play
would again get me to quake in my boots
I would take the repetition here with
white what do you think
I'm also in your Camp as well because
you know this king's Indian attack sorry
it's just very very scary I mean as
you've indicated Knight G3 you can also
see a potential Pawn storm brewing with
a G5 the night going back age five and
all these pawns headed your way and it's
not entirely clear
where Jordan is gonna be striking next I
mean you can't just go all in on the
queen side and just forget about the
fact that his King is undefended so yeah
the tension's too much for me to Bear
repeat moves yeah case I mean I would
Hazard a guess that Arjun after Knight
to C2 might be the one who holds you
know the power to decline the repetition
now some of you might notice Knight
takes F3 that is a possibility but I'm
not too convinced by it because after it
takes takes Rook takes D6 white
obviously benefits uh from this trade
the D file opens up and White's pieces
are actually pretty well equipped to
handle the opening of the file you know
maybe black and try Bishop E6 here but
that means giving up another Pawn on C6
things get very very chaotic here but
here Bishop E1 we have a result by the
way this it's not the result the result
is I'm just a tour of game Let's jump
straight to that game and see the
players setting up the pieces
you'll be as expected that game never
really got off the ground
no it didn't get off the ground and uh
once again we see a draw offer
and okay we we found out the rules
yesterday that although not illegal draw
offers were heavily frowned upon shall
we say and uh
and and I can understand
I can understand why they took a draw
because the position really there's not
much life in it the position is
relatively close things will get traded
off but still
I I feel it's a risky decision for
aronian because this is his second draw
in a row where he's agreed to draw by
offer by draw offer so well live on
your your risk of entry for 2024 is at
stake
yes but of course in all seriousness
this is a dead draw even though Black's
structure might look menacing there's no
Universe in which black will ever be
able to take on e4 because the Rook on a
fade is hanging and if it moves then you
blunder the point on F5 so essentially
both players here are reduced to just
like shuffling King E2 Rook F2 back to
F3 and black uh essentially doing the
same thing with rook h8 and Rook H7 so
the dropper here I would say is even
more Justified uh than the offer in the
Geary game so I don't think the
organizers are going to hold this
against the players this was still a
combative game it was an interesting
early middle game that just happened uh
to liquidate and Bizzle out so our first
results of the day ladies and gentlemen
the tournament leader Notre pick up de
sotorov draws against aronian moving to
six out of eight still a monster monster
score
yeah uh is a huge score and he will be
happy going into the rest day uh he will
use that time just simply to relax and
get ready for the last part of the
tournament and uh
well we have a lot of other interesting
battles
um whilst we're waiting to see whether
Magnus is actually going to play the
killer move Rook D2
um one game that catches my eye is the
game between gukash and uh maxoodloo
primarily because maxulu is breaking the
rules and pushing Pawns in front of his
King like there's no tomorrow what is
this G7 G5 move which immediately makes
me jump up in my seat and go huh can you
make moves like that
our home of sudlu has been walking on
hot calls ever since his game against
Fabiano yesterday the guy has nerves of
Steel so they had you know the position
structurally hasn't changed all that
much in the last 10 moves it's just that
some pieces have been traded the light
squared Bishop for black took the Knight
on F3 uh nothing
crazy happened until uh move 21 and in
this position Arham drives this Pawn up
to G5 taking a page out of Vincent
kymer's book Moving pawns on the same
side where he's Castle now I think
there's two uh justifications for this
the first is that you know quite a few
pieces are off the board and white
doesn't have the Firepower to launch any
kind of immediate attack against Black's
King the second justification is that
the bishop on F3 is actually very very
vulnerable and given only two moves
black will drive the pawn up to G4 and
that can become very alarming very
quickly let me just uh well let's say A3
H5 then black plays G4 and G3
and the pawn on E3 actually ends up very
very tender because it's only protected
by the F2 Pawn so psychologically Yogi I
think Arham knows that kukesh is off and
he's trying to get him to get into here
we go again mode like here we go again
my opponent's attacking me and I don't
know what to do but I love the way that
kukesh has responded he says no no no
I'm going to attack two because two can
play at that game and he moves his own
Pawn up on the knights file
yeah I have to say you know is that porn
is coming to attack the night once that
Knight has to move then take a look at
whose Pawn is going to be extremely weak
it is the Pawn on D5 and
I I really don't like this G5 move I
understand it's aggressive intentions I
understand that Haram wanted to also
dominate The Knight on D3 but
is asking too much from the position I
think I mean I was kind of expecting
more standard moves like night coming
into E4
and
you know getting some activity that way
but B5 now
in the air so I guess you'd have to stop
it A6
and if you can't stop it
hey everyone yeah white insists on this
okay why
we just not let black have an easy ride
of it
um yeah it's difficult to suggest
something
because you have to actually now start
thinking about mobilizing your pieces
and over protecting D5 and
in in the meantime take a look at the
queen on E7 I mean she's tied down she's
tied down to the defense of her loose
piece on F6
yeah I think
I'm just underestimated that the power
of driving this Pawn up to B5 opening
the C file trading the heavy pieces
diminishes the effect of H5 G4 so no
question that cash is clearly better
this is a big opportunity for him now
folks we don't want to miss the ending
of the Magnus Carlson game Carlson
didn't play Rook D2 he played a
perfectly suitable alternative in 94.
he's completely winning and we will go
on a short break when we return we'll
have more action for you and possibly
another win for the world champion here
in round eight of Tata steel we'll be
back very shortly
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
is on the cusp of a second consecutive
Victory here in round eight of the 2023
Tata steel chess tournament Magnus
Carlson with a sparkling
dominating game against Fabiano caruana
with the black pieces as he tries to
move to plus one he was minus one just
two rounds ago but yovi we have some
surprising news even though Carlson is
still winning spoiler alert not only did
he not find Rook D2 but definitely not
choosing the most efficient path to
Victory several moves should have won
the game in just a couple of moves he's
chosen to transition the game into a
grinded out end game
yeah uh he hasn't chosen the most
accurate way but the good news for
Magnus fans is that they're still very
much enough to win the position I mean
there really is nothing that Fabiano can
do take a look at the power of magnus's
double Bishop pair take a look at his
Rook standing there on an open b line
and that Rook you just know it is headed
to the second rank once it kicks away
the White Knight and take a look at this
white weak white porn on E5 it's just
ripe there for the taking eventually
it really is not good news for Fabi so
what Magnus has done okay it's gonna win
the game but not within the next few
moves that much is clear
can I take devil's advocate here
I think it's very likely to win the game
as karawana shifts his Rook to C1 by the
way the computer defense here was to
play E6 and open up the C7 score I think
there's a 95 chance he's gonna win the
game I really can't get over the fact
that Magnus didn't play Rook D2 and yes
I'm the Monday Morning Quarterback the
classic commentator who sits in his
armchair and criticizes the world
champion who's playing in Titus steel
but I just feel like Magnus at this
stage in the tournament is still
handling most of these positions with an
abundance of caution I think if Magnus
was on plus two or plus three we would
have seen Rook D2 in the span of a
couple of minutes but instead he forces
a transition into an end game with 94
Knight H5 uh was also pretty much
crushing and after 94 this does give
Fabi a chance to trade everything on e4
and oh joy an end game where black has
the bishop pair and an extra pawn and
you're facing the world champion you
made a great point though during the
break yes that was a little sloppy for
Magnus this but from fabi's perspective
in a certain sense he actually probably
wanted to see Rook D2 can you expand on
that point
yeah I just I was joking to you Daniel
and I was saying that Magnus has done
the thing that every player hates you
know you you know you're in this
situation you've made a mess of the
position you see a way that you can be
put out of misery but your opponent
doesn't do that your opponent plays
something inaccurate he prolongs the
game and still you know that you're
gonna totally lose and there's nothing
you can do about it and the game
continues continues and your opponent
keeps making those inaccuracies and
still the evaluation of the position
doesn't change I mean this is one of
every player's worst nightmares and uh
it's happening to Fabi right now
it is but you don't want to play with
your food when you're facing people like
Fabiano caruana because the moment you
start giving them a little bit of Hope
he changes his body language he changes
his mentality and Magnus Carlson hasn't
won the game yet he needs to demonstrate
a good amount of precision in this end
game in order to actually finish the
game off and I think the way to do that
is to play Rook B8 to B5 in the world
champion
it didn't take him long The Rook swings
up to the best Square on the boardy Obi
black threatens Rook to C5 which will
create a deadly pin against the Knight
and obviously if the Knight moves away
then the pawn on A5 is going to drop but
Fabby E6 he didn't play it on the
previous move he does play it now and
he's not gonna go gentle into that good
night
that's for sure like he's not going to
go gentle but still
I mean let's be realistic I don't think
that there is any way that he can come
back from this I don't think that
there's any way this Knight and Bishop
can hold off the bishop pair and I'm
expecting Magnus simply to capture that
pawn and then mobilize the only piece
that hasn't been playing for a while and
that's the bishop on their feet
I think Rook C5 might win the game
outright because white has to drop back
to F4 right so that the Rook is
protected can I just go here
here Trader Rooks and I think the game
ends after Bishop to B4 winning a second
pawn and once black goes up two pawns I
don't think Bobby will continue the
resistance so that's one option
there you go Ponte spawn on the board
and Rewind back to the live position
yeah I agree with you Dania I think that
line that you showed very forcing very
convincing and the fact that Fabiano is
hesitating now to capture that pawn
says to me that he is actually
considering just resigning the game and
there you can see he takes the sigh
he's not happy
and they slide
frown
you're right and just somehow thought
maybe he would be able to resist but
this is too lost it's too depressing
yeah he's that was the problem you know
Tom okay Bishop takes Pawn on the board
um and this is the problem with chess
there are some mistakes that you make
you just can't claw your your way back
to safety and
Jess is brutal like that
I mean I I've played many games where my
opponent has played terrible moves even
though they've been terrible
they still haven't been enough for me to
win
so it's just the way it goes and
sometimes you know I've also played a
brilliant game and then I've made one
huge cataclysmic error and that is it
all my hard work has just been put to
waste and that's the end of that
and uh I'm expecting the bishop to
retreat to F4 we're going to go right
down your line because
the bishop must protect the Rook on C1
as you've indicated
yeah we're in we're in resigned
territory here after the 185 disappears
from the board
you're right and and that's why when
you're looking at a game you have to
take you know moves and mistakes with a
grain of salt from an evaluation
standpoint the decision to go into this
end game for Magnus you know the
computer would assign that move two
question marks because Rook D2 was
something like plus eight and you know
94 was let's say plus three
but the thing is plus three for Magnus
Carlson when he has 47 minutes on his
clock is just more than sufficient to
win the game smoothly and maybe E6 on
the previous move one move before he
played it would have afforded I'll be on
a car wanna sum you know chances to pull
off a miracle but you can just see it on
his face he's devastated and this is
such a crushing defeat for Fabiano
caruano has been having a great
tournament who's in second place and was
really looking forward to a nice solid
game against the world champion wasn't
meant to be
yeah this is the Ultimate Nightmare you
know you want to maximize all the
chances that you get when you're playing
with the white pieces the last thing you
want is to full foul of some like to
something like this just and okay the
bishop comes to F4 our chest profit
strikes again
but thank you
and then Knight has to move and we are
gonna see that trade
there oh
there's one trap I I can't even figure
out a single way that black can mess
this up like even if he tries I was
looking at some lines
there's just nothing maybe it's worth
for Fabi to not go Knight B6 and instead
to go 93 blunders The Rook oh my God
Knight B2 no get that out of here this
is over
yeah
no yeah Knight B2 is not good you kind
of want the knights
and
somewhere
um okay the only thing that I can see is
you put your knight on E5 because
it's in the center
yeah
I can still take
yeah I know
I know there we go no effective point
and we have the handshake Fabiana Carona
has resigned and Magnus Carlson takes a
very convincing point
prophetic words there from the chatter
Sandy doggo Abby gonna call it a day and
get some pizza is what he said and then
Fabi immediately resigns he will make it
to Tarantella he needs to take his mind
off of this game because this was a
disaster and what a game for Magnus
setting aside 94 which was only a slight
blot on the perfect painting yovi this
was a tour de force this is why Magnus
dominates the Chess World and has done
so for well over a decade now
yeah uh he made it look easy and
effortless and you have to remember that
Magnus was the one who was surprised in
the opening and he was the one who had
to react instinctively he had to
Freestyle and he just found the perfect
antidote to Fabiano's play
he did indeed and
man what a tough pill to swallow for
Fabiano caruana who was going to lose
his grip on second place and will move
from plus two to plus one he will have
some coming back to do Carlson meanwhile
after the rest day has gukesh with the
white pieces and now a huge chance for
the world champion to make a furious run
at first place with plenty of Chess
still to be played you can see him there
he is now on plus one a score that we
are more used to a score that still does
not represent a successful result but
man does the landscape of the tournament
look completely different from what it
did just two rounds ago Notre pick
abusator of draws and currently holds a
one and a half point lead but most
likely Wesley Anish and Prague will not
all lose their games
I would be very surprising to say the
least if we see such action and uh I
guess it's the perfect time to check out
the bird's eye view and see how the
other games are going
they're going they're ambling along if I
had to predict I think the next result
we will see might be the Wesley Den game
which is furiously moving toward a very
peaceful conclusion I will point out
that Jordan van Forrest declined one of
them declined the repetition I'm not
sure exactly who it is but does it
matter uh the game continues the Bishop
from D7 has moved back to E8 in order to
reinforce the D6 spawn I still like
Arjun aragice's chances here uh to pull
off his first Victory the position is
just punishingly complex and nuanced
Yogi I'll give you the choice between
the Wesley game we can examine it and
just make sure that there are no hidden
details there that it is in fact as Josh
as it appears but the other games are
just as interesting so I'll give you the
final say
yeah I agree we haven't visited them in
a while so let's go and check up on
Wesley against ding after all it started
with our very favorite caracon
it did indeed and currently we have an
end game and that end game was reached
after a rather unremarkable series of
moves the pieces sort of slowly got
traded off the board but I think ding's
decision to play A5 and induced B5 was a
very prescient one because now he does
have the C5 Square which he can access
on demand
insofar as one side is pushing and
squeezing I think there's no question in
my mind that that side is Wesley this is
a two result game Lex Pawns in the
center are very tender the h-spawn is
isolated and ding at all costs has to
remain active in order to counterbalance
that and keep the position relatively
balanced
I agree there's a nice standoff going on
between the two Bishops neither of them
want to take each other because if black
were to capture the bishop on C4 well
one problem has been sold but another
problem has arisen and the Knight it
stands very well on C4 looking at the
weak B6 Pawn so you don't really want
that and yep and Daniel sharing exactly
what black is trying to avoid
and there is
there is Rook B8
yeah
yeah that looks nice
very good for whites you don't want to
be headed into this but uh neither do
you does white necessarily want to
capture the bishop because if you
capture the bishop
it would be black
yeah so it would be black who controls
the very important C4 square and
suddenly this D5 Pawn yes is isolated
but it feels like it could be more of an
asset especially backed up by a knight
on C5 so that would be very very tense
and uh it's an interesting question how
are both sides going to improve because
that's what both
they both need to do so the king I would
put the King on F7 just like you've
indicated
how is white gonna
harmonize their pieces
um well thinking outside the box there
isn't a knight to E4
but the issue there is that although
white might very well achieve the trade
that he is looking forward to
after 96 King E7 you don't want to take
the Rook obviously what kind of fun is
hanging the problem is that Black's King
is now in optimal spot it's covering D6
after Rook C8 black essentially takes
over the initiative that's not really in
question
another possibility
is to play the direct tactical move F5
and this I think is far more likely in
the event that Ding plays King F7 here
you have yielded control of the E5
square but after F take C6 you have
further damaged black spawn structure
and to make matters worse if you take
with the bishop you blunder the Knight
on E5 the King on F7 that's the one
downside of its placement the F6 Pawn is
pinned so you would have to take here
with the Monarch but here I like the
look of a move like Bishop to D3 go
after the H7 Pawn you know Bishop F5
check and while Black's minor pieces are
very active Black's got structural
weaknesses and the King on E6 could sort
of get caught in the crossfire a little
bit
King to G7 I think for that reason
was ding's Choice back to the live chord
I agree King G7 looks a lot safer in
light of the lines you highlight it
um
okay now the ball is back in White's
Court how to improve the forces
not so easy
well maybe Rick Nick t
rookie 3 was something that came to my
mind
receive one
wixy one I was never very sure about
because I feel that black is simply
going to play copycat and say you know
yay you two want to take control well I
will challenge you and put my Rook on C8
good idea rookie three I think
for that reason is a good compromise
maybe the other one could come to see
one or you double on the IFA I mean this
Pawn is Black's real only Target and I
think it makes logical sense for white
to pursue uh a direct attack on that
Target with his Rooks
uh-huh
yeah so it's not quite as easy this
position as the eyes make out the eyes
are kind of saying draw
and still a lot of danger a lot of
tension a lot of scope to go wrong so
uh interesting battle ahead
equally exciting
a lot of Chess to be played in this end
game I could see this fizzling out in a
couple of moves but I think at the very
least Wesley is going to try a third win
in a row would be huge it would put
Wesley squarely in second place one only
half a point behind an order back so I
think he's going to try okay so I think
we have a pretty good sense of how this
end game is likely to unfold let's uh
take a gander once again at the bird's
eye view and see if any other games are
worth looking at more deeply we have
gukesh maxulu with white pursuing that
Furious Queen Side Pawn storm A5 and B5
and maxulu has made zero progress on the
other side of the board ever since
playing that Brazen G7 G5 I think you
called it Yogi I think that move has
backfired spectacularly and gukesh might
have the best winning chances in a game
that he has had all tournament
yeah I I agree
such a move such as a G5 I mean you're
playing with fire sometimes you get
burnt
um the game that strikes my eye is the
game between Richard Rapport and
pragananda because when I was a kid my
favorite thing in the world back in the
day was opposite side castly when I
first learned about this powerful weapon
I did it at nearly every single game I
was so pleased with myself I had chest
down to a formula so what I would do is
I would provoke a weakness I would
encourage my opponent to play H6 because
I was a kid I would often play H3 and
they would repeat by playing H6 and as
soon as they did that I was like right
you think my king is going to copy no is
going to go to the other side and then I
would Press On
you would wait for your opponent to show
their cards and then yeah necessarily go
the other way it reminds me of a of a
story that I'm a little bit embarrassed
about
um I'll I'll share it quickly and then
we'll promise we'll get to the game
because you look at the time situation
both players well under 30 minutes now
it's only move 19 so we're gonna get a
lot of moves here really really fast I
was giving a simul on the subject of
castling to an old folks home many many
years ago I was 11 or 12. now uh you
know Russian players have sometimes a
habit when they Castle especially older
amateurs of moving The Rook to f8 first
and then the king to G8 even Anatoly
karpov uh famously did that against
Yonder palmnushi so I'm playing this
older guys being very nice and he
Castles by moving The Rook to f8 now I
was a little kid I didn't really
understand that you gotta let that kind
of thing slide so I insisted that he has
to move his Rook which according to the
rules is true if you you cannot move the
Rook first or else you're gonna have to
release it on f8 that is a legal move
and I made him release The Rook he was
unhappy and my parents just yelled at me
afterwards like you can't do that you're
giving a silo you got to be nicer than
that and I was so embarrassed afterwards
but that story has always stuck with me
sometimes you just gotta let people
slide a little bit but don't move the
Rook first you've got to move the king
to G8 first because that is an illegal
move without completing the castle
I can remember Hikaru Nakamura I got
burnt by that rule I remember he just
picked up the Rook yeah and he said that
the rules in America are different that
you can actually pick up the rook and uh
everyone said no no no no but the feeder
says these are the rules you gotta pick
up your king but I'm kind of with you
when it comes to enforcing the rules
yeah well especially if you're a child
you know I used to live for those
moments I didn't care he was in front of
me when I was a kid you picked up the
Rook you're gonna move that rook and I
was going to call and enforce that many
many times so yeah
um a little bit on your side there
thank you I really appreciate it I mean
it would have been easy to pile you know
salt into the wound
but you know when you're a kid the rules
are the important thing I as you as you
said it's I don't think of it as I'm not
being nice and you violated the rules he
has to pay the price now ragnananda
seems to be paying a pretty steep price
here for uh playing that Knight F4 move
because the pawn has disappeared from F4
and Richard report
in the greatest style of young Ivanka
Huska has on Queen side
oh and uh results another result and uh
there's a draw between Anish giri and
Vincent kaima so
we take a quick look to see how that one
finished
in rather steep anti-climactic fashion
with just liquidation and you're
redeciding that kymer has sufficient
compensation for the pawn here's what
happened after D4 Vincent drove the pawn
up to G4 you already dropped the Knight
back to E1
you had D5
King moves toward the center and after
C5 Bishop D3 Bishop D7 attacking that
pawn on A4 and after d takes C5 Gary
decided that a draw for was in order and
I think it's another Justified draw for
because after Bishop takes E5 you have a
detail he might have overlooked from a
distance is that black has this
devastating threat of G4 G3 that forces
white to spend a Tempo moving the king
away and then black could snap off the
remaining on on A4 looks like
liquidation looks like Black's very
powerful Bishops give him enough
activity or a draw
yeah okay
oh the results are coming in quite
quickly and okay that was uh
well a fizzler but uh nevertheless an
exciting game and uh can we go back to
the bird's eye view and perhaps revisit
the written reports
shall we yes
maybe we'll get another result
yeah and I I think we are gonna get a
result in this particular game because
take a look at what pregnant has done
you know he's gone and said yes I might
have lost the F4 Pawn but I'm gonna grab
the H5 phone thereby opening up the edge
line as an Avenue to attack the black
king So Pregnant under he Brave
jeez
ing up the age belt he says I don't care
I got all the defensive forces I need on
the king side Queen could come out to F6
uh at the right moment in order to give
a little bit more support to the king
how is report going to handle this he's
got to decide fast I think he's gonna
take the Knight we can open an elsewhere
take the Knight and the tempting with
your Yogi of course is Rook to H1
but it's not like you put a rook on H1
in Black's King side or King just turns
into dust after Bishop G6 it's not so
easy for Richard report to actually
exploit that semi-open H file maybe you
go G4 but I think here the queen does
come out to F6 white has created a big
hole on F4 and most importantly the F2
Pawn is also going to hang if the Knight
moves away maybe not H4 no Bishop takes
F2 Forks the knight in The Rook this is
no good okay one Queen G5 check
Intermezzo so maybe it was worth going
King B1 at some point how do you think
report is going to handle this
well I I think he has to take
inspiration from a pawn storm and I
think if you're going to rewind back the
first move that I would play is actually
not to attack the bishop once the bishop
is on H5 instead I wouldn't just leave
my Rook on F1 take it easy and I I'm
actually want to get rid of the Knight
sitting on F3 relocated now because the
king is standing on an open diagonal
I'm feeling a bit uncomfortable so
that's why I want to put my knight to D2
now it looks a bit odd but the idea is
just to go
before
F5
lock your Bishop out
goodbye Bishop
maybe black could Counter-Strike with C5
but
maybe then white could take on D5 it
gets really complicated
that's also true
um I'm also considering that maybe I
don't even need to put my knight on D2
maybe I could put it to H2
mm-hmm which also looks pretty
but still Night On The Edge I have not
loved my lesson they fall off the Hedge
oh that's a new one I haven't heard that
one night's on the edge fall off the
Hedge whoa all right that's gonna answer
my repertoire thank you
okay welcome
another one stolen from your movie
references
yeah that was uh from brew from Bruce
Almighty very good film and of of course
my uh whoop is also I have to admit not
an invention those who watch uh
assiduously watch American Sports will
recognize that in the repertoire of
Chris Berman who's one of my favorite
sports casters he he does a lot of
Recaps and he I think is the originator
of the whoop sound
um and that's basically all I do just
adapt Sports phrases to chess steal
shamelessly plagiarize from other
commentators
um but just to close off the discussion
in this very complicated position Yogi I
think it's likely that he takes on H5
and I like your ideas moving the night
away he might also lay it slow and just
go King C1 to B1 you're never afraid of
black taking on F3 because you would
more than happily pay uh the price for
your Pawn structure because you get that
incredibly juicy G file I think this is
going to be all about the king side Ken
white yet the engine started on that
side of the board 17 minutes left on the
clock we're gonna get a big time time
scramble here
yeah I I agree with you lots of moves to
be played and the position is getting
complicated and that means only one
thing the players are forced to burn
time on the clock so that means we are
going to see a lot of action happening
soon and okay
so can we take a look at the bird's eye
view
and uh Richard actually playing Queen D2
in that position
okay I think that's a very reasonable
logical move he wants to trade on his
own terms and he wants to send the queen
into the attack actually there's a very
cool detail if Knight takes F4 I think
there's Bishop takes F7 check Intermezzo
and then you pick up the Knight forking
the bishop Richard is just devilishly
tricky and so Prague might be best
advised to bring his own Queen into the
game with Queen F6 what else what else
is going on here
well F5 by Wesley
yeah
um
can we revisit the game between van Far
East and aragaisi because
that one was your typical slugfest I
mean both sides just coming at each
other on different sides of the board
I still don't know who stands better I
don't know who's going to crash through
and have they kind of reached some kind
of impasse
well I'll tell you what it may appear
that they have but the pressure on C4
has mounted and mounted and reached uh
an apex I am shocked that Jordan Ben
Forrest was the one who declined the
repetition
and if we rewind back to move 23 really
quickly we might remember that he was
playing Knight C2 and the Knight D4 and
all of a sudden after thinking for a
long time he decided on the Move Rook to
D2 and with Black's Center being as
stable as it is this just seems to me to
be a rather I mean extreme risk and all
right guys who just started out playing
him he tucked his King away and look at
what Jordan is doing he just moved his
Rook back to D1 I don't understand maybe
he was afraid of something after Knight
C2
and then he just shuffles his pieces
Bishop F1 92 Eric icy sort of gets his
Queen to F7 and builds a little battery
onto the C4 Pawn Joey this is
getting very unpleasant for Mr van
Forrest at least I think yeah
um it's
to me
it's looking very difficult to defend
the C4 Pawn so therefore you have to do
some counter-attacking things and the
only counter Tech that I can see is V5
but this is a pawn break that you've
both sides are kind of like well Jordan
has shied away from making such a
committal move and as you highlighted C5
can be played
but okay maybe this move
yeah
yeah I guess so sacrificing
really greedy okay a knight jumps into
D5 and aren't we proud about that
oh very much so
are you gonna take that
nasty little Knight over there no you
live with it
you just suffer the effects of it and
you just say okay you have a beautiful
night but I'm gonna play around it and
you put your queen I agree on E8 and
what kind of night the bishop
is an octo Knight
oh beautiful I thought it was a perfect
opportunity for be beautiful sorry yeah
beautiful I'm nerding out over this
reference I'm nerding out over this
reference okay please proceed
[Laughter]
I'm not that quick uh so yeah I was
thinking and then after that you just
put your Bishop on E5 and
oh I'm so obsessed with these kind of
things but you know you clear the path
you put your works on the G line either
you're going to go Knight G3 or you're
going to do my favorite thing
G4 G5 H5 G4 G3 just crack open a line
with those Pawns
and it's you might well black doesn't
have enough time for that thing is look
at the queen side it's so watertight
even with the Knight sitting on D5 the
Knight alone is not going to cause black
that many problems in the meantime we
are back to good form
we go back to the live board Jordan has
indeed struck out at the queen side with
B5
yes
but I I do feel that that position is
rather critical and
um well Jordan now is going to have to
find some resourceful ideas in order to
stay alive there and in the meantime can
we revisit the game between good cash
well first of all let's check out the
bird's eye view and the game that I had
my eye on was between gukash and Max
hoodloo
okay yeah I have my eye on that as well
dangly rent top left is pondering the
situation after F5 so the other games
have stabilized just a little bit we
have four games in progress two games
have ended in peace in the world
champion smashing Fabiano caruana just
running him out of the gym literally
because they are playing I think in a
repurposed gym there's Knight C6 by
Jordan Let's Travel to lukesha's game
as the Indian Talent tries to score his
first win of the tournament he's very
very close
how bad is it for Parham
yeah and the first question is
what's stopping white from going ahead
and grabbing that pawn on B7
the first move that I would consider as
uh
certified porn grabber
I'll take on A5 I'm a certified prawn
Grabber myself prong Grabber I don't
like prize you take on C8
yeah hang up let's try it
an analysis board here because we have
some end game exploring to do how do we
evaluate this end game
not so easy the White Knight is not well
placed
you know it would be so nice if I could
go Knight F4 it's like some genius
thought to play G5 earlier
night before similarly impossible I
would say that indicator here uh like
the like you know really litmus test
it's whether white can launch an all-out
assault against the D5 Pawn if not black
and get the Knight into C4 later on the
Knight could jump into E4
I don't think this is all that
convincing though Yogi I think this is a
two result game no question about it but
how exactly is white going to make
concrete progress here
it's not easy I mean when it comes to
fighting against the queen
the Rooks will have to combine together
as well as the night and I was thinking
Knight C5 could be an idea to try to
make use of this piece
um
um there is there is also maybe I should
uh take a lesson from the grand Masters
again I'm not learning I the Knight
needs to go somewhere
I keep putting my Knights and my pieces
on unstable Square
and in order to become a super Grand
Master I must learn the art of over
protection so perhaps the Knight needs
to go somewhere else I have an idea
um the Knight needs to go to E1
okay this is right off of magnus's the
Magnus Carlson School of Chess in fact I
think he did play 91 in a similar
situation against Notre back obviously
he lost in the end I actually really
like this move
okay I will follow through with my plan
H5
okay and so the first thing is that I do
have this tactic which is Bishop
that you counter attack
my Rook
IE okay so I can go
Knight C2
can I show a hilarious line I was
looking at yeah go for it and I like
Knight C2 I was just contemplating this
move and obviously it's not gonna go for
this but I was attempting to evaluate
this position and at first I thought oh
I can draw the game takes takes takes
and I thought no there's a fork on C3
and black wins but then I realized that
white Rook takes G5 check and then
somehow after Knight F3 white keeps
everything under wraps and everything
protected so
obviously this is a totally moot point
Bishop takes D5 is impossible but
perhaps I could save the game in that
case your move though Knight C2 oh that
juicy F5 Square
I'll go G4 and counter attack
yeah this is the thing I I'm thinking
that I'm rushing things too much so now
can I can I rewind one move
and
and play
and now I have played safety first move
yeah maybe Chief this is it this is
rooked D4
he's still unstable I can come back to
C6 I think
oh so amazing so this is very unclear
yeah but then the queen D7 so still oh
roll roll
the game never finishes though because
it's like every time we think there's
Clarity there's some counter-attacking
move but but the upshot of this I mean
we've gone pretty far uh which I think
is Justified because this is an
incredibly important Line This is what
gukesh has to evaluate and you can just
sense the wheels turning in his brain
this is what he's thinking about I would
not be convinced by this position with
white and when you're having a bad
tournament I think one of the things
that goes first is your evaluating
ability you lose confidence in your
ability to accurately evaluate positions
uh you lose confidence in your ability
to evaluate Transformations and so I
think subconsciously you tend to try to
keep the structure the pawn structure in
the piece uh balance and avoid peace
imbalances because of the risk of
misevaluating it let's see if gukesh
shows nerves of Steel and takes on B7
that really might be his only path to
fighting for a serious Advantage even
though
I'm not convinced that he's got that
advantage
yeah I I have to say that one thing that
also concerns me is how much time he's
using I mean it's been just a pattern
throughout this tournament that good
cash has been using and burning all the
time in in the in the world and then
when it comes to those critical moments
he's in time trouble and he can't
navigate the complications and he makes
mistakes and it was something that
Wesley so highlighted yesterday he said
he basically won the game because the
cash hadn't left himself enough time to
get to move 40 and uh maybe we can see
the bird's eye view
yeah let's let's go back to the bird's
eye view gukesh is obviously evaluating
Queen takes B7 and has been now for
right around six or seven minutes
there's a sunk cost effect too where you
spend so much time evaluating the
principled move to then play a calm move
like Rook c1a1 it's just so dejecting
disappointing then you know why did I
take those seven minutes if I could have
played that move immediately we will
keep tabs on what kukesh decides
and uh okay can we just have a look
because I just saw something in the
bird's eye view that I was like oh hello
it was in the game between uh Jordan
against Arjun because Northern he's just
played Knight A7
he's just sacrificed a piece
my lands
what is this just genius
I I I'm surprised that first of all Air
Guys he did not accept upon sacrifice he
just went Rook to D7 perhaps he thought
that giving up the B5 Square was not
worth the trouble and in this position
bang knight takes pawn and Rook takes
Pawn
Jordan crashes through on the D file the
b-pawn is hanging from a practical
perspective I think this is a
fascinating idea even if it's
and even objectively I think it might be
sound
it looks like it's sound because that
pawn on A6 is worth many a minor piece
um okay so the only thing that black can
do is he just has to grimly defend his
pawns so
just play Rook B8
report would give up a second piece and
play Rook B6 here but I think that's a
little bit premature perhaps Knight to
A4
deserves consideration ah but then no no
no that Knight takes C4
let me amend that Knight to five
night and then you have to go Bishop
takes Knight
seems like it I'll take with the E Pawn
ah come on Eva bar
oh there we go
but uh
and your Rook
it's pretty safe because it has the E6
Square to hide to and if you take a look
at Black's extra piece it's a knight on
H5
ain't that doing a fine job there oh
yeah no I'm I'm B I'm being sarcastic
um
yes
oh but but then our guy sees in serious
trouble
yeah I mean you look at a position like
this okay it's move 35 but 20 minutes is
nothing for five moves this complex Rook
A7 to E7 in this position
uh might be the best way to keep things
stable but already in this position this
incredible sacrifice seems to work
because after oh my God look at this
position this is crazy black can defend
both pieces at the same time
but oh my gosh I think
actually wait a second
so in this position
yeah the the engine which I just double
checked is in fact indicating Rook B6
and Bishop C5
Queen d8 Bishop B7 Queen E7 and C5 look
at this two minor pieces down
oh my God and here there's crazy ideas
like Queen G5 and Knight G3 so this
might not work out concretely but these
are the kinds of ridiculous deadly ideas
that Arjun
uh has his hands tied up with all of a
sudden
yeah no I mean that's terrifying and uh
the worst thing about that line is that
white had many options as well yeah you
took the Rook on E7 it was actually
possible to take the Rook on B6 and
displaced the queen that way and still
those pawns are Marching forward and
Arjun has to calculate every single
possibility and that is a nightmare oh
Arden 20 minutes remaining on the clock
oh man
I mean the thing is though there's going
to be a sacrifice on B6 come what may
you feel it in your bones
95 wanna move
yeah
I mean it's people often fall into the
trap in these types of positions of
assuming that if you don't win the game
in the next three moves then the
sacrifice will have turned out to be on
sound let's not forget that white
actually has two pawns for the piece so
it's still a big sacrifice but it's not
like sacrificing a queen white can slow
roll this position and not worry too
much about not having enough men on the
field especially as you very astutely
pointed out that quote unquote extra
piece on H5 is a total dud that night
was a one-trick pony its only prospect
was to move to G3 and the position has
transformed so much that Knight G3 is
completely not a problem white also has
three Defenders on that square so you're
never going to be able to take back on
G3 and keep the pawn alive I think this
is a brilliant decision by Jordan van
forest and I think as he leans over the
board hunched over in full concentration
I think Arjun aragaisy is seriously
regret writing not eliminating that
Knight on C6 when he had a chance
not to anticipate that Jordan would
actually
fires his Knight on A7 but what a stroke
of Genius from the Dutchman it's been
beautiful beautiful idea and uh erag icy
he is a tactician I mean one of his
biggest skill sets is that he is
fantastic with the initiative so I would
not discount him if there's some way if
there's someone who can generate some
play it's going to be Arjun
it most certainly is I mean he lost the
game to Notre back abdusitor of no shame
in that before you had a couple of
sparkling comeback draws he's solid as a
rock and like you said very very tricky
player and speaking of Arjun uh the
Press caught up with him right before
the event to ask him how he feels going
into one of his first true super
tournaments of his incredibly promising
career let's listen in to Mr Eric dicey
so it's definitely going to be a lot
stronger than a lot more challenging and
there was a lot of top players and this
is my first tournament playing amongst
the elite In classical so I look forward
and I'm very excited
to be honest I don't think it changes
anything
particularly to me but it's nice to have
a Spectators watching chess
I I'm quite used to playing the happy
Blitz in general even the pandemic I
used to play a lot of Blitz on them so
so rapid Blitz I'm always used to and
classical is something that's been there
since years since basically when I
started playing chess so at the moment
it's not so difficult to adjust someone
format to another
oh like the fact that there's a so many
Spectators watching and and they
cheerful chefs not just for me but just
their vouchers and this is getting more
attraction that feels great
Well India is in the midst of a historic
chess boom and Arjun aragaisies at the
center of that boom I think you said it
best you'll be it almost feels like
there's a new Grandmaster every day and
that's not as much of an exaggeration
we're talking five ten new grand Masters
per year we're talking an entire country
that's obsessed with chess with some of
the best chess fans so supportive of
their players and it's so easy to be
supportive of a player like Arjun Eric
icy because all he does is succeed
yeah and uh Arden he's so calm uh you
rarely see him get flustered you rarely
see him stressed and uh one of the
things that struck me about Arjun is
when he said that uh he's actually been
working with a performance coach and uh
the performers coach helps him with
meditation helps him calm down helps him
put in in the right frame of mind
because this is an aspect to chess which
is kind of almost been overlooked by a
lot of the top uh chess players that's
it's not just about training the body
it's also about training the mind just
making sure that you have enough grit
and resilience just to endure those
tough times and to endure the tremendous
strain you put on yourself by playing
seven hours of grueling chess
yeah I mean it's it's so easy just to
fall into the Trap of thinking that well
we're talking chess we're talking not a
physical sport isn't it a bit of an
exaggeration Overkill to get a sports
psychologist and a lot of players have a
personal trainer no it is not you need
that physical stamina you need the
mental stamina if you want to succeed
consistently at this level over the
course of as you're saying a six seven
hour game you know against the world
champion or example so as Eric icy
continues to think about his next move
his clock is dwindling he's down to 15
minutes and he's got one two three four
five six moves to make until time
control we have another game that's
heating up we have two games that's
heating up kukash and maxoulu with a
Counter-Strike by Parham in the center
but look at report prognananda I Can't
Take My Eyes Off of that position Yogi
I can't hide that because Frank Ananda
would kind of called him Brave and here
he is you know he's playing
so recklessly and so bravely I have to
say you know he's just opened up the G
Line open up the age line ready for
those Rooks to come down and start
looking at the black king and oh I I
don't know about this position I would
be quaking in my boots but because it's
pregnant under I somehow feel that he
must have an answer here you must have a
way to counter-attack this because
you know the white Rook is coming to G1
and from there we suddenly have horrible
threats on the board you know there's
even ideas of actually The Rook
sacrificing itself on G7 and that would
just be a killer blow
and you've got to also blunt this light
squared Bishop that's sitting on B3
pointing at the black king
actually the more I look at it the more
I think pregnant under is in serious
trouble we could really start seeing a
shake-up of the standings a lot of the
players who we had kind of almost
written off they're playing spoilers
they are I mean the line between Brave
and Brazen it's a very thin one and I
think Prague might be Towing that line
Richard is also down to five and a half
minutes that might be part of the reason
why Prague is trying to complicate the
game and we will have this time Scramble
for you as well as updates on the other
games we still have four games on going
all of them are fascinating you will not
want to miss the conclusion of round
eight of Tata steel we will be back with
more action on the other side of this
short break
foreign struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level most importantly
all of our courses are powered by
chessable's exclusive move Trader
technology which uses the science of
space repetition to make sure it all
sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun happy seems
more fresh and I know he loves Todd of
Steel and you could just see the
inspiration in fabby's play once again
vikon Zay starts the new year as the
center of the chess Universe this year
as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is playing for a win and he
has to start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge at the top half of the Cross
table the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
Joe leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish is taking
down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps elderbeck
just playing a modern brilliancy what a
performance
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
[Music]
yet another exciting round at the Tata
steel chess tournament round eight is
three and a half hours in we've got a
couple of results and the remaining
games have officially reached the climax
most of them in a Time scramble as the
players struggle to make move 40 and
nowhere is this more evident than in
Richard reports dogfight against
pragnananda we remind you that the
players receive a hundred minutes for
the first 40 moves when move 40 is made
they get an additional 55-0 minutes and
on move 60 they get another 15 minutes
for the rest of the game and of course
the 30 second increment has saved almost
all of the players from losing on time
it's a generous time control but it's
not a Time control uh that entirely
allows the players to avoid the
occasional time scramble let's go back
to Richard reports game where he has
sacrificed upon Jovi for a fury attack
and what an attack he has things are
looking very Grim or Prague
yeah I mean just look at this on sort of
Pawns F4 E4 there's an two open lines
for the black king to just feel the heat
of those white Works
um
it's such a scary position the only
comfort that I would take if I were
pregnant under is that it's not entirely
clear now how is white gonna continue
their attack and maybe the black king
can find solace in the center oh and uh
you see that's uh another result has
been uh reached that is between Wesley
so and dinglerant and of course that
game ended peacefully in a draw
yeah a slightly more peaceful day today
by the way gookash is also going to make
a draw pretty shortly we'll bring you
that result when we have it but dingley
Ren great defensive effort things did
look a little bit dubious for him for a
while but he managed to stay afloat and
Wesley we last looked at the game after
F5 ding very calmly brings his Rook to
the seventh rank we have a mass trade
and dings slight damage on the king side
is counterbalanced by his incredibly
active Knight and Rooks and pretty
quickly we had a total liquidation
followed by uh a drop okay a good solid
high level game and a good result for
dingley Wren who goes into the rest day
with a good draw with the black pieces
against Wesley let's go back to the
report ragnan on the game because
pragnanada himself is now dropping down
and down on the clock
yeah and uh he they he's on move 26 and
he has to reach the critical move 40 and
as you can see
both sides not that much time remaining
pregnant and just just under seven and a
half minutes and then we have a Richard
just over six minutes
it's very it's not that much time for
such a complicated position and do you
remember you have to remember it's not
very easy to defend and because the
position is still so open pragnananda
will have to be calculating every single
possibility he'll be have to be thinking
how is Richard gonna continue his attack
is he going to push his Pawn forward is
he going to put his Rook on the G2
square and start bearing down against
the G7 Pawn Prague has to have an answer
every step of the way
I mean
the black keg has managed to escape the
G file the issue is that it's going from
the frying pan Into the Fire King E7
looks like the most tempting move to me
the issue there is that white can blast
open the center with you could play E5
immediately but I also like the
possibility of D4 followed by E5 let's
not forget that black is only one Pawn
up it's not like white sacrificed a
piece for this attack white has made a
minimal investment and in return he's
got a furious Pawn storm in the center
the Bishop from D1 at the right moment
can a visit to B3 pressuring F7 you can
also move into C2 if the black queen
escapes to one of the two squares that
I've highlighted and lastly from a
positional standpoint Black's Bishop is
going to be terrible it's going to be
totally out of commission should Richard
report Advance his Pawn to D4 now the
time situation as equalized as well so
Prague doesn't even have a Time
advantage to suffer for
yeah and I I love the fact that you
suggested the black king running into
the center because that was my vibe as
well that King has got a skedaddle out
of trouble but uh trouble is still gonna
find him and uh let's uh take a look at
the bird's eye view and have a look at
the other games because I'm sure the
action is brewing
it is indeed I mean it's Brewing most
intensely in the van Forest game along
with the report game that we just saw I
think we should go very quickly to that
Richard report game because the third
remaining game between dukesh and
maxillo as tactical as it is it's still
a lot more tame and moving a lot more
slowly than our other two games so
Richard report has a furious attack
against pragnananda and Van Forest has
just made his 40th move so I think we
should see what aragaisy's move 40
response will be at which point the
players will finally be able to relax
and take a deep breath with 50.
additional minutes added to their clocks
oh my God yeah oh my God what's
happening I know and I think we actually
should rewind
to see how the flow has con has kind of
developed because okay we saw this
beautiful Sacrifice from Jordan
uh very very decisive and that Bishop
takes Knight I think played but watch
what happens next
oh my gosh he brought his Knight back
finally Arch and Eric icy brings his
Knight back into civilization but Ron
talked about frying pan Into the Fire
Ian comes the pawn looks like Jordan
walks into a fork right just giving up
the E5 but no Bang
Rook takes G6 what tactical creativity
by Van forest and if black takes that
poisoned Rook the queen moves up to E4
whichever way the black king goes either
you lose the bishop and get massacred in
the center or you obviously get
checkmated on the king side King G5
staves off Chuck mate uh but no it
doesn't even stay buff mate buy one move
it's still made in two
and so Arjun nerves of Steel as he says
I don't need your Rook I need the pawn
95 forces The Rook off of G6 it moves to
D6 and as move 40 is about to be made
one thing important to point out you
have a knight D3 Queen E4 check is out
of the question so whatever Arjun does
you will have to make sure that he
doesn't lose any minor pieces in the
center and doesn't get victimized by a
check on e4
the check on e4 is the immediate thing
to deal with and uh Arjun is his 40th
move and he has plenty of time to
navigate this point
um eight minutes left on the clock my
first instinct is to actually drop the
king back to h8 just to keep it
protected
I'm really trying to get into the Super
Grand Master mindset of just keeping the
king covered at all times
yeah I love King h8 I think it takes
this thing out of Queen E4 alternatively
I would consider bringing either The
Rook to E8 or the other Rook to E7
although the moment you move the Rook
out of A7 let's not forget that the
reason why it sacrificed the piece in
the first place was to uh produce some
rather imposing pawns that sit on B5 and
A6 connected passers right in Black's
Grill
but with seven and a half minutes I
think Arjun has just enough time to keep
his bearings and find a good move and
he's already played a move and it is in
fact Rook C8 to E8
yep
okay definitely looks like a menacing
move Knight D3 as you've highlighted now
in the air so white has to get off the
e-line as quickly as possible probably
line up the queen and the Rook together
make a bold prediction that this is
going to be our last game of the day
because this is the kind of position
where you can totally anticipate Jordan
and aragaisy taking turns spending 20 25
minutes per move there are so many
options here you can take C5 you can
move the queen away from the pin there
is that check on e4 which upon closer
inspection doesn't seem to yield as many
benefits as I thought it would Black's
pieces are all well protected
I think this is a good time to leave the
players to their own devices move 41 is
going to take a while
it will do too many possibilities and uh
okay three gains remaining shall we
pop in on gukesh against Max sudlu
yeah and then we should definitely take
a look at the climax
uh in the report productive game because
the players are moving ever faster and
faster their clocks are dwindling and
this game has gotten totally wild too
what's happening
and take a look at gukesh's clock he has
just under two minutes and the position
is again getting wild I mean we have a
rook takes D4 on the board we have all
kinds of potential threats against this
bishop on G2 and maxidly he plays it
oh okay I feel that ukesh is teetering
on the edge now he has to play Super
accurately and the first move that I
would think about and it's not just
about greed it's about connecting the um
the queen with the bishop on G2 that is
this vulnerable piece just take the pawn
on B7
you're absolutely right that is the only
way to keep the balance the position is
equal but gukesh has to be perfect as
you're saying there are so many false
friends here moves that might look
tempting you know A6 is a move I could
see him playing but apparently that move
loses and Yogi is good cash losing
control of the game yet again what
happened to his Advantage not only is it
done but black has now firmly taken
control of the initiative fantastic time
management for Mike Zulu he left himself
with 14 minutes that is plenty of time
to work through the complications 50
seconds for the Indian Grandmaster can
he take on B7 can he find the only move
let's watch
oh you know what I think A6 is such a
tempting possibility it is isn't it
yeah I don't know maybe we should
highlight why
well I think the problem isn't the
problem Rook takes Knight
oh a night back to E3 and you could even
allow white to promote to a second queen
that might not help he's found it he's
found Queen takes B7
oh living on the edge and uh one of the
things that saves white is that Rook
takes Knight is also met by the the
white work capturing his own Knight and
then White's pieces are coordinated to
organize a defense of this weak Bishop
on G2
and it can Stave off the attack just
long enough to enable him to launch a
counter assault on Black's King that
counter result is not going to yield
Checkmate uh by any means but it is
going to give white Perpetual check if
he handles uh the situation correctly
because Arham really has no choice but
to take this Knight and swing his Rook
down to the second rank obviously Rook
D2 is not possible as of yet that square
is controlled and after takes takes
rooksy to Rook G1 the knight's gonna
enter the game imagine having that
position with 50 seconds
yeah but you know what Max sudlu is
gonna use his time and I don't think
he's gonna capture that night I think
he's gonna play some other confusing
move because the reason I'm saying this
is because after Rook takes Knight it is
very obvious that what white has to do
white is gonna immediately capture the
Knight giving more time to kakesh when
gakesh has just 60 seconds left the best
thing to do is to make a move that will
just confuse him and I'm thinking can
you get away with some I don't know some
kind of move and I'm just oh and okay
he's taking the night
just don't think he saw an alternative I
don't think there were any other ways to
coordinate his pieces and here we go
Breakneck action Rook to C2 is on the
board but you're right this allows
gukesh to make a couple of moves really
really quickly builds up at least a tiny
amount of cushion which I think will
allow him to find the subsequent series
of only moves Rook G1 is forced you
could throw in a check but I don't see
the point of that there it is rook q1
and Arham is likely to swing his Knight
into the action with Knight to D4
oh my gosh which game do we go because
Parham or report Prague NADA is also
going crazy
okay 94 on the board and the Knight is
making a beeline to the E2 square but it
will help the queen attack G3 and G1
oh this is
so difficult
how is he gonna
King's age one only move no way
gotta step out of Knight F3 well Knight
F3 is a devastating threat
yeah it is King H1
oh
good cash on the brink
we definitely should wait for Google
Cash's move because this game is Just
percolating King H1 every other move
loses if you give a check on B8 which I
could totally see him doing that check
is tempting buy yourself some time it's
premature and it would lose the game
literally the only move is to drop the
Kink back in cold-blooded fashion and 40
seconds for gukesh
is cool
I don't know did you see the way he was
looking at the clock
but it seems to me that he's nervous
keeps looking at the clock and then he
looks at the ball okay he finds the best
move
oh
he's done it okay
yeah but he's still not out of the woods
just uh so many aggressive moves and the
first of all what is going to happen
after the Knight jumps to eat too
well I guess Queen B8 check and the
point is that the king cannot escape the
zigzaggy series of checks if Queen G7
there's a queen check on E5 most
importantly if King H7 the bishop comes
to the rescue with a check on e4 that
will open up
the seventh rank so white can apparently
with a series of accurate checks Force
the Perpetual check in Black has really
no choice but to take uh to play 92
because Queen takes G3 there's Queen
takes F7 check that's the saving
resource just beautiful okay
okay so it looks like a cache it has
this under control with seconds left but
we really should go to the game between
Rapport and pragnananda because it's
just Madness look at practice King it's
out there in the center it's been oh my
God my richest forces ah this is looking
dire it is and he's got one minute for
nine moves in a situation where his King
has no safety no Solace his Bishop is
locked out by the way gukesh is about to
make his 40th move if he makes a mistake
if he does not give that check on B8 we
will keep you posted but if he does he
will most likely hold the draw what does
Prague do Rook has come to G7 yo the
black is up two pawns does anybody care
about that no E6 is coming I think he's
lost I think this is dead lost
for for product
V6 is a huge threat
um he's just under a minute and he moves
to f8
he's six okay the first and six is
winning
it's a deadly threat and you have Pawn
takes Pawn on the board oh my God E6
and Richard well he has just under four
and a half minutes to find this move but
his position is just crying it crying
out for this kind of Pawn advance
I mean the thing is I think Prague
actually saw E6 I'm going to amend what
I just said I think he wants to slide
the king over to C7 and there it's
important for Richard to realize that he
can just take the pawn on H6 you don't
actually need to play e takes F7 to rush
that move if you rush it then somehow
the black king is going to use that F
Pawn as an umbrella and Prague might
start to worm his way out of the dire
situation he has found himself in three
and a half minutes for the Romanian
Grand Master he can't fall asleep either
no he certainly can't
31 moves played so far nine moves left
this is insane
that bears repeating nine moves to make
in one minute
in a situation where his King is just
caught in a furious attack a storm that
never seems to end we remind you that
they will receive 50 minutes after move
40 is played white makes his 40th move
50 minutes black makes his 40th move 50
minutes but that is so far away Prague
isn't even thinking about move 40 he is
thinking about surviving each individual
move and not losing on time
um yeah it is just a question of
surviving here because the position is
just in tatters for him
and uh Richard doing the right thing he
is working out all the details I mean
the great news for Richard is that he
probably doesn't even need to go E6 he
can just improve his position by him
moving the queen to F4 attacking the
pawn on F5 he has all the choice in the
world so E6 we're expecting because it
is the most obvious move
but then again Safety First will also
work
advised in your opponent's time pressure
to give your opponent a choice make an
open-ended move that forces him to spend
more time I think Queen F4 fits the bill
perfectly apart from the fact that it
also attacks you know really one of the
only flimsy uh covers between White's
pieces and the black king so I like
Queen F4 Queen takes H6 is a somewhat
greedier approach that looks very
tempting as well what really kills black
here is the fact that this bishop is is
totally out of commission it's not
really participating in the defense so
black is really left the king is largely
left to its own devices there's E6 check
on the board
yep E6 played and King runs to C7 and
this is how quickly Richard played this
move piling on the pressure on F7 this
is clinical by the remaining Grandmaster
it is indeed Rook takes a n listen he
doesn't even necessarily want to end the
game with Checkmate I think he wants to
end the game by establishing a passed
Pawn on F7 and ultimately smoking out
whatever piece sits on f8 whether it's
the Rook or eventually the Queen the
e-file will open and he will use that
e-file as an Avenue to get a piece to E8
and smoke out again that Rook on f8
which is going to be so unstable
yeah absolutely and uh it's never what
your pieces are it's what they do and a
Pawn on the seventh rank one square away
from queening and it's protected by
anything there's no way that pregnant
can challenge it it's gonna be Mighty
it's gonna be sufficient to win the game
and nothing really for pregnant two
apart from accept that this Pawn will
exist
30 seconds he's got 30 seconds to come
to terms with it he's just played Queen
E7 to F6 apparently the only move to
stay alive that hits the Rook it forces
Richard report's hand we are gonna see
Rook takes F7 check
and then of course Richard will take
back with the epon that's why he put his
Bishop on a tribe that Bishop is going
to be permanently anchored to that pawn
and prague's only defensive approach
might actually be to later bring the
Rook to f8 and sacrifice an exchange on
F7 obviously that resulting position is
losing but perhaps it affords some
practical chances we have a trade on F7
Prague has built up a little bit of a
time question he's got 90 seconds to
choose his next move
I think Rook Cafe is the only way to
stay alive here
yeah it is the only way because uh White
is threatening to actually play Rook E8
himself so I agree rickette fate but the
problem is is that
The Rook is not obliged to go to EA it's
the queen can join in The Fray by moving
itself to E3 and it's all about building
and nurturing that Advantage home
you brought up a fantastic point I think
Queen to E3 is a much more precise than
the tempting rookie 8 that enables black
to keep his Rook alive with Queen to G7
the great thing about Queen's E3 is that
white actually threatens to trade queens
and once the Queens are traded again the
bishop on A7 is nowhere to be found if
only it found a way to worm its way to
D6 it would be protecting The Rook black
would be totally fine the absence of the
bishop The Rook has no stability and the
eventual rookie 8 will be absolutely
deadly particularly if the Queens are
off the board Queen E3 here is the key
to the kingdom and
about to make a move as Richard report
it's got five moves
to make the time control Queen E3 I also
I also like Queen E3 because it
threatens Queen E8
not just exchanging queens and he's
found it oh you give Richard an
aggressive attacking position of course
he's gonna find the best moves this is
so easy to him and uh I think prags only
tries to
capture the pawn I mean it's a sorry
attempt I mean just take a look at this
dark Square Bishop that prag has you
kind of mentioned it so many times it's
locked out of the game and Prague he
knows
he's shaking his head
and he's in Desperate survival mode but
there's nothing to be done
50 seconds C5 is futile he's not getting
that Bishop out in time and after he
gives up The Rook on F7 Richard could
add insults injury tack on one more by
taking on H6 Paving the way for The Rook
infiltration to the seventh rank
technically the engine is giving
something like plus three but I just
don't see Prague being able to make
three more moves without losing more
material in that position here we go we
takes F7 played good job by Prague doing
what he has to do to keep the game going
yeah and uh I would be tempted now to
get rid of the queens and let the Rook
fight against this bad Bishop on A7 and
so that Rook is a mighty fine piece
because it can eye up the H6 pawns pick
up the F5 one and uh not to mention that
B7 is also a Target and we just saw
Richard reach with his hand
Prague looking away
he knows
oh he does and everything wins rookie
Queen takes H6 is the more violent
approach Queen E7 is in the great style
of the sort of Soviet Schoolboy get the
Queens off the board win both of the
kingside pawns and the four on four with
Rook vs Bishop is a relatively
Elementary win it's not the easiest
thing in the world but
with the additional 50 minutes Richard
should have no problems converting it's
largely a matter of taste here what kind
of wind do you prefer a technical one or
one in which you have to do a little bit
of calculation and go for the direct
attack
I vote one with no risk
yeah but Richard report is Richard
report as one wise man said and I think
he's keeping the Queens on the board
yeah yeah I agree with you Queen takes
porn and then the Rook moves itself to
G1 and that is gonna be curtains still
uh time is ticking and uh Richard will
be in calculation mode he'll be thinking
about what's going to happen should
pragnananda
capture the pawn on A2 with his own
Queen
yeah takes takes there's a check on E7
oh and no look at you he goes for safety
first okay oh it's Soviet Style okay the
King has to step back to C8 you don't
want to let the B7 Pawn fall off the
board no and the bishop gets trapped
that's the craziest thing if you play
King d8
Prague has two more moves to make until
time control and then you will have that
additional time to see if he can maybe
keep one of these pawns by Miracle maybe
go C5 very quickly and try to blast open
a diagonal for the bishop there are some
tactics having to do with Bishop E3
checks so
I think Richard still has some work to
do
yeah yeah I think so too
but uh it's just a question of time and
yeah yeah time is
Richard's friend he has all of it in the
world to just sit there and just keep on
improving his position and Prague will
have well he has a big defensive task
ahead of him and is largely dependent on
Richard making a critical mistake
yeah what's what's interesting is that
the theoretical endgame Rook versus
Bishop with three on three on the same
side of the board is a pretty well-known
win but the winning strategy there is
not the easiest to formulate if you
aren't aware of it beforehand when you
start adding pawns to the same side of
the board obviously that favors the side
that's up material because it's easier
to Target the opposing side's pawns when
there are more of them and harder to
defend so if report can win both of
these pawns I think the game ends then
and there it all depends on whether
Prague can find some way maybe to play
C5 at the right moment and keep one of
the pawns alive that complicates the
winning process 10 seconds
now don't fall asleep frog thing B6
okay
it was somewhat surprising to put the
King on B6 but Prague is banking on
moves such as uh D5 and perhaps trying
to keep the F Pawn Alive by putting it
on F4
it's move 39 yovi Prague still has a
move to make and 30 SEC eight seconds to
do it in he's gotten up from his chair
I hope he realizes this has not move
forward he move 40 has not been made yet
by black
yeah
this is weird oh where's he going
where's he going whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
what's happening is that him
it is him he's not on the board he might
have made a mistake on his scoresheet
and he might be under the impression
that 40 moves have been made this has
happened before in Grand Master Level
chess where you skip a move on your
scoresheet but more likely he just
believes in his ability to come back to
the chair and make a move
but this is getting me really nervous
um I I think it's more the former case
I've never seen anyone get up from the
board when they only have 38 seconds
left to make a final move
I know there he is
sit down Prague
yeah
oh my God
and now Richard down to 40 seconds maybe
this is a psychological Ploy maybe
Richard also thinks that he's made move
40.
oh imagine if report no report realizes
it he's making motions
that he is about to move 20 more seconds
and Rook H7 I think and Rook F7 are the
candidate moves you have to decide which
of the pawns you're targeting first now
because f is on a light Square my
inclination would be toward Rook H7
10 seconds eight seconds eight seconds
seconds gotta make a move
come on oh my lands okay seconds he cut
it so close
and he goes C4 interesting move just
keeping the king confined now where is
Prague
he sits down he sits down calmly
20 seconds how promising this is crazy
oh no
oh no he's going to no no no no no no no
no no no no
has he forgotten that he's got 10
seconds
he's got 10 seconds oh my god I've
gotten I can't I can't believe it's six
five four four three three he's lost on
time
no but why does maid move 40 and black
is not
are we unaware of the rules yovi the
rules should be just because your
opponent has made move 40 does not mean
that you get the time black has to
execute his 40th move to get that
additional time the clock is wrong I
think he's lost on time
I think he's lost on time but look at
the clock 50 minutes have been added to
his clock and that is wrong
and uh let's see the handshake you lost
on time lost on time
and
I wouldn't be I would be more shocked
you'll be imagine if his position wasn't
lost how crazy that would be
yeah oh my gosh
what happened
I'm speechless that he just thought that
he had made move 40 I mean his body
language indicated that the way he got
up from the board the way that he kind
of relaxed was hanging around and then
he just sat down when he had 30 seconds
left on the clock and he just calmly
wrote
Richard's move
oh the game this is not over breaking he
would have had far from answers I mean
go Bishop ba go D5 you know three on
three Richard would have had his work
cut out from a surprise Parham walks
over there Yobe we kind of called it the
moment he got up from his chair with 30
seconds left we knew that something was
wrong and the only explanation I can
think of is what I mentioned he made a
mistake on a score sheet let's say he
accidentally wrote the same move twice
or he accidentally missed one of the
moves you don't see what move number it
is on the clock the clock does not tell
you what move number it is so you're
left to your own devices I've made this
mistake before that's why sometimes I
subconsciously try to make 41 moves just
in case I misnotesated what a crazy
crazy ending to this game
uh I I know and it's absolutely
heartbreaking for the Indian teenager um
I mean yes his position was objectively
lost but still there were so many moves
left to play and not the ending that
Prague wanted especially not the ending
that he wanted before a free day
yeah sad things and I agree with you I
actually am paranoid about this
happening during the game so I often
will make sure I get to move 41. rather
than just move 40 or sometimes I will
even ask my opponent move 40 and they go
exactly then I'm like out of there
I will do that too and again I just want
to make it very clear that I think
there's an 80 to 90 chance Richard would
have won but it's not just that it's the
psychological just surprise of losing on
time like you're not supposed to do that
Grandmasters are supposed to be aware of
what the move number is but Prague he
accepted it calmly
he gets his first zero on the tournament
cross stable and still an amazing
performance
that doesn't change but he will have a
tough tough rest day tomorrow a tough
pill to swallow Richard report that was
a great great game
that was a fantastic game and I like the
way that Richard just untangled himself
from a potentially very tricky middle
game and then he just sees the
initiative by casting Queen side and
when Prague grabbed those very hot horns
Richard just launched an initiative and
it was just devastating very impressive
stuff from Richard
when you get Richard reported into the
wrong kind of position he is absolutely
Unstoppable I was floored with the
confidence
with which he carried out the moves E6
and Bishop page five and you can just
sense the energy in his play a big win
for Richard
who uh is going to try to finish this
tournament strong but speaking of
finishing strong we are monitoring the
two remaining games as we go to our
bird's eye view then forest and paragisi
locked into a wildly chaotic struggle
Bishop has just taken on C5 the game
that I think is going to end very
shortly is ukesh maxood Lou so shall we
pay a visit to that game before it ends
in what I think will be Perpetual check
of one form or another
yeah absolutely because at the minute it
looks like black has a killer position
with that Knight on F5
threatening this Pawn on G3 and it seems
to me that white has to bail out as
quickly as possible and start giving
some checks
looks are so deceiving in these types of
positions we just want to clarify nobody
else is going to lose on time uh gukesh
has made move 40 on the previous move
and that means while the clock hasn't
been updated just yet he's got right
about 35 minutes at this point so he's
been thinking for 18 minutes and he
realizes the gravity of this situation
the best move you'll be I think the most
precise way to ensure a draw is actually
just to push the pawn up to G4
and yeah this looks Brazen but it's not
yeah you can just step forward with the
King and uh Knight f one check will
be a Perpetual check
you cannot capture that Knight and then
back you go
and I agree with that oh how are you
gonna handle this now Queen to E5 check
now here comes the perpetual
and uh actually I the move that I was
suggesting could potentially be a big
mistake
if gukash gives a check for the knights
on F5 then black was simply play F6 and
the queen has no good way to deliver a
second check
uh and this occurs in which position
this occurs when the Knight is on F5 in
the in the game position
ah
rewind all the way back you're saying if
he gives the immediate track F6 yeah is
bad news even this is probably maybe a I
mean you could give up G3 and still try
to get the Perpetual but it's a moot
point it's not worth even looking at now
the one point I want to make is that
Arham
should not repeat the kind of thing he
did yesterday against Fabby I think he's
going to learn his lesson because 92
would be very unwise actually Queen E5
check look at this if black drops the
king back to G8 after the com Rook F1
it's Checkmate because Queen E8 and
queen takes F7 is coming next Black
loses his Queen and if you drop the
queen back to F sinks thinking ah Let Me
Be Clever and move this Knight back out
to F4 and maybe it looks like Black's
got some chances why does the brilliant
Intermezzo Bishop to E4 hitting the Rook
attacking the tail of the discovery
after Rook A2 Rook G2 black is in Dire
Straits and is going to end up just
losing this Knight so kukesh is triple
quadruple checking you can't be careful
enough especially when you're in bad
form so he's going to take his sweet
time but I have no doubt in my mind that
we're gonna see a draw after G4
yeah it looks that way because uh
believe it or not the danger is probably
all on parham's side rather than
kakash's and
there's exciting round today and the
players of course will have a free day
tomorrow but that doesn't prevent them
from playing wild and exciting chess
could you have predicted this that prag
would lose a rigid rapport
that Magnus would just simply overwhelm
Fabiana caruano with the black pieces
I would have said no
how the landscape of the tournament has
changed just in the last two games
and we have just seen our fair share
more than our fair share of crazy chess
Fighting Chess and just turn arounds and
just unpredictable occurrences that all
constitute the reason we love this
tournament right if everything went
according to plan and we had tons of
boring draws and the standings wouldn't
really shift us for the first couple of
rounds then Tata steel would not have
the reputation that it has earned and
built up over the course of almost a
century now just think about that the
same tournament held in essentially the
same place for 85 years and these
players are more than well equipped to
continue this amazing tradition in style
now we will continue a tradition of our
own which is
foreign
to take a break now kukesh just made a
crazy move he's played A6
I don't can we when I ask permission
from our producer to spend a little bit
of time on this game we will go on that
break but wait a second kill the
commercial kill the commercial A6 is on
the board and you can see the email bar
protesting wildly
now the reason kukesh played it yovi in
his mind
he thinks that after Knight takes you
three King H2
uh Mike Zulu still has to force the draw
because why does two moves away from
promotion but apparently I will admit I
cheated apparently black has an
additional resource in the form of
Knight of five
oh my God
and if a seven black stops the pawn with
Rook A2
now you think what do you mean stops the
bond white can still promote but after
Rook ate Queen A8 there is a smothered
mate Bang
bang and you don't even sack your queen
even if there was a knight on F3 this
would be made that would be insane
now wait a second cash mess up again
oh
he has but that mates with the Knight on
F1 and the Queen on H2
is notoriously difficult to spot I
remember that kramnik actually didn't
see that Checkmate when he faced off
against the computer and
oh oh gosh
oh I believe what I'm seeing and
the reason the G4 was so important you
know he has nothing to do with the
material count or the inherent value of
that pawn it was just that the pawn on
G4 would have prevented the black knight
from moving back to F5 and setting up
these discovered ideas and the last
thing I'll point out is that after
Knight F5 you might say well obviously
white doesn't have to promote but if
white doesn't promote black just picks
up the A7 Pawn that pawn is hanging and
black will emerge two pawns ahead
according to the eval bar at a
relatively low depth black is already on
the border of winning should this happen
on the board should Parham play the move
Knight F5 and he's got an entire hour to
figure out what I think is an idea that
he is well
uh capable of seeing even in let's say a
rapid game
yeah I I agree with you
uh you can just see that maxidly he's
been surprised actually and
eighth sixth feels like a move
that's not quite right
and um
you know at the very least as you
mentioned you do have the draw but he
will be looking for more and
dropping that Knight back to F5 that's
just remarkable what a move
that's unbelievable stuff and uh we've
seen these Grand Masters they find the
best moves they understand what needs to
be done and Goodness Me
if this is the case and this happens
gukesh is just going to be devastated
because nothing is going his way I mean
he he started this game
he paid great he got a position that was
better for him and somehow other
in the time scramble he let his
advantages slip but still this is very
much a draw and now if Maxwell finds the
correct way
to win it's just going to be all over
there's no way that white can
survive this position if he loses the a
pawn
yeah I mean
it's crazy and and gukesh if he loses
the a pawn when he loses the econ we'll
need a miracle of the magnitude that we
almost saw yesterday in order to turn
that game around but one thing is for
sure Parham he might take on G3 quickly
but on the subsequent move he is going
to take his sweet time because Knight F5
is obviously an incredibly committal
move he will have to calculate it very
very deeply but Parham he looks
surprised I think he's already spotted
that idea on his radar this I think
gives us a good chance to go on our post
time control break do not go anywhere
because here at round eight of the Tata
steel chess tournament we still have two
fascinating games that are on going and
we will bring you more Tata Steel action
from this amazing round on the other
side of this short break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sunday round here at the Tata steel
chess tournament the playing Hall still
mostly filled and the spectators at the
front crowding around the final two
ongoing games we have had a fascinating
round some draws some decisive games
crazy things happening all around as the
world champion demolishes Fabiano
caruana and Richard report wins on time
against prognananda in to be fair a
position that he should have converted
anyway and three results ending
peacefully yovi we called it in the
first 15 minutes we just saw from the
openings and the diversity of structures
that we were in for an exciting round
yeah we really did see it all we saw
players launching King side attacks we
saw people grabbing pawns and it's been
entirely unexpected I could not have
believed what has occurred in this round
and boy some things still take my breath
away and the two games that you
mentioned they were just unbelievable
can you believe Magnus Carlson just you
know whitewash over Fabio Fabiana
caruana and of course Prague just losing
to Richard rapport
insane and the best part of it is that
the insanity continues because the two
games that we have still remaining are
again just crazy
in this game what we just saw uh kukesh
make a shocking error granting our
hamaksudlu a golden opportunity to take
over the advantage and we'll keep you
posted on whether or not RM seizes that
opportunity but the game that everybody
wants to look at is Ben Forrest aragaisy
this was a complicated game really from
the very opening but it was a manageable
it was a manageable King's Indian
position with understandable ideas and
then all hell broke loose when Jordan
Ben Forrest came up with a brilliant
sacrifice on A7 the position remains
objectively unclear but Jordan faced his
opponent with what now is clear are
insurmountable practical problems look
at White's two pawns on B5 and A7 the
pathway is clear and his last move is
the top line of the engine Black's
position is deteriorating rapidly yovi
and I think in the long run and not as
much in the long run really in the next
four or five moves White Pawn is going
to appear on B7 and white will do
anything that it takes and sacrifice
anything he needs to to ensure that
these pawns reach the seventh rank
yes uh absolutely those two poems are
the North Stars in White's position it's
just a case of pushing them the white
Army will help them to their destination
and take a look at Black's extra piece
it's nowhere near in the defense that
black has I mean Black's job is to
Simply blockade them but that is a
thankless task and let's not forget that
the black king
still exposed still out there
um
it looks it looks disastrous for Arjun
eragisi and it looks like he's going to
stumble to his second defeat in a row
yes he is and he's played the move
Knight C4 obviously Jordan has not
missed the Forkey he's just gonna snap
that Knight right off the board he's
going to be down an entire Rook but it's
not going to matter because even with
two Rooks and a queen like does not have
sufficient Firepower to keep his King
protected and keep the pawns confined
Jordan's about to have two queens I'll
just point out that White's King is kind
of sitting in its Castle a warm
fireplace you know the logs are
crackling it's got a nice bottle of
expensive wine nearby just sort of
sitting there with his personal
assistant helping him out and keeping
him safe A Tale of Two disparate Kings I
just want to show on the analysis board
how the game is likely to end Jordan is
certainly going to take on C4 if uh
Arjun takes with the bishop he allows
the extra resource Rook to D7 so black
is most likely going to take with the
rook and white simply continues to push
the pawn and here's the amazing thing
black drops The Rook back to C8 it still
appears that Arjun is keeping things
relatively under control but here
actually have the crazy sacrifice on E6
giving up yet another exchange if the
queen takes and white pushes B7 and
massacres blackstrokes and if the Rook
takes I think the move Knight D6 ends
the game just look at this position this
is ridiculous Yogi this is just
ridiculous black is a full Rook of head
and it does not matter because as soon
as black sticks a queen on B7 Boop Boop
and that's it like has to get rid of the
queen and the pawn finally reaches the
Promised Land
beautiful stuff there and I can see that
Jordan is for sure going to find these
moves and he doesn't capture the knights
but he steps forward with the queen I
still think that this is okay you can
still use the ideas that you've
highlighted of just sacrificing your
Rook for the night and then just
springing forward with the bee Pawn
ah now it is okay but there I would
refrain from one particular line I'm a
little bit worried Jordan might be
attracted to it and that is to give up
the a pawn in order to recapture the
Knight obviously this does not
relinquish the entire Advantage but this
really does allow black to muddy the
waters with the move Rook A1 and
amazingly Knight F6 check that looks
like it wins the game on the spot but
black is a very pretty tactic that turns
the tables Queen takes F6 and don't
forget White's Queen is also hanging
it's not so easy to get rid of this rook
and suddenly black White's King you know
the fireplace has gone out uh you know
it's it's not all that interested in the
wine that it's got nearby and black is
able to whip up an inkling of counter
play so if I'm Jordan I don't know
exactly what to recommend but maybe Rook
to C6 is a a safer way to keep
converting the advantage not totally
sure but he rushed it with Queen D3 yeah
it rush it a little bit I have to say if
I were plain white I would probably play
A8
banquet it's been a wild game and I feel
that
is about time material were restored and
uh there we see Jordan he is in the tank
he is thinking I do like your move Rook
C6
that is also a fantastic idea I mean
black doesn't have a direct threat
against any of White's pieces so just
move the Rook Rook C6 and uh remember
the pawn is protected by the bishop
that's hiding away on G1
I uh it took me a while to spot that
piece
yeah hiding over there in the corner it
took me a while to spot whites King
yeah
yeah but uh
yeah the problem is that there are many
tempting choices Rook C6 and just A8
after playing such a nerve-wracking game
I think this is very tempting
it is and I checked our silicon friend
or shall I say our silicon fiend and it
does appear that I exaggerated the
extent of the danger a little bit A8
Queen is right around plus four the
simple reason is that Rook to A1 it
looks scary but it does not create any
threats The Rook all alone in of itself
doesn't apply sufficient pressure on
that bishop and white well he'll give up
the a pawn but he still has the beep on
and he's got two extra pawns to boot so
I think A8 Queen should in fact do the
job if Jordan maintains his composure
and exercises the utmost caution with
respect to his King well one player that
did not exercise the utmost caution is
Fabiano caruana who got absolutely
smashed in less than 30 moves by a
resurgent world champion Magnus Carlson
is all of a sudden on plus one sitting
pretty a lot prettier and he was sitting
just two rounds ago and Magnus Carlson
caught up with with the Press right
after his sparkling Victory let's listen
in to the world champion
I didn't expect this one so um that's
um that's very good now I am
now I have five
um pretty um winnable games left so uh
I'll just try and keep keep going so um
yeah it's looking it's looking better
I'm not really concerned about winning
the tournament
um but the chances of actually playing a
decent tournament increased a lot
obviously
that was Magnus Carlson as we look at
the standings really quickly but we have
some breaking news coming in right now
I'm just a tour of there keeping a one
point lead for the time being but
something crazy has just happened we
have to take you furiously over to the
gukesh ULU game or something absolutely
Unthinkable has just occurred not only
did parhamak sudlu not find the move
Knight takes G3 check it would have been
forgivable if he didn't see Knight back
to F5 in that resulting position and
gone for the draw but he has made an
absolutely Unthinkable Wonder instead he
has allowed ukesh to claim victory with
Rook A2 he allowed Queen A5 check now in
this position King G8 is an immediate
Perpetual how similar is this Yobe to
the carwana narrative instead he's gone
forward to G6 and the horrible tactic
that he's blundered is that after Knight
G3 check Queen takes G3 he split the
King on the only square that allows this
tactic to work and that's your Bishop E4
check black can resign because the queen
is picked up with an extra piece I
cannot believe this and if he can't play
Knight G3 and he's got to move the
Knight elsewhere and Bishop to E4 is
essentially Checkmate as a result I
think think he can basically resign yeah
I I mean talk about roller coaster I
mean when we took a break we left you
all on a cliffhanger we were like hey
you know Parham has a winning attempt
I'm didn't spot it because he tried to
play too ambitiously he did not play the
obvious move because he did not spot
Knight F5 as Daniel indicated and
instead he's just taking too many risks
in the desire to win he should have just
accepted he got away with it yesterday
but today he is being punished and I
love that line Knight G3 Queen takes
Knight oh
beautiful stuff here and there we can
see param with his head in his hands he
is just desperately racking his brains
to find some kind of solution because
this of course is not the outcome that
he expected and oh
and uh you've highlighted not going back
to G2 G7 and of course the bishop will
come out
but this is so easy F5 you take it the
King has to make its way
um to H5 but then Bishop D5 Bishop F7 is
a mating procedure probably the only
chance is Knight takes F5 and the eval
bar there dropping a little bit maybe
this still gives Parham some off chances
the problem though is if we rewind a
couple of moves apparently the move a6a7
wins the game on the spot if you can
distract the queen then the win is
obvious if you can distract The Rook
which you do then the clinical Rook F1
forces the queen away and then Bishop B4
is simply Checkmate for instance Queen
B6 Bang
and then you actually can take with a
bishop you can take with the pawn and
obviously this is like the most
one-sided Affair of all time instead
Parham has decided to seek his fortunes
on E3 let's bring us back to the live
board Knight to E3 is on the board and
that actually is a much better version
of the Knight H4 line because A7 here
doesn't seem to do the trick black can
actually capture that Bishop is Parham
gonna pull off another Unthinkable
miracle and save this game put all of
that to the side Yogi I can't believe
that he didn't take on g3 at the very
least he would have had that draw in his
pocket I know he's just taking these
crazy risks and I admire the fighting
Spirit he's a fighter but his form and
his delivery in these critical moments
has just been sorely lacking yeah I have
to say
um sometimes it comes from the will to
win you've got to back that up with
moves and sometimes you just have to
accept that your opponent has also
worked as hard as you have and that a
draw is a fair result you just can't
force those victories you can't wheel
them into existence and you have to let
them happen naturally and I do like the
move Knight E3 the first thing that I'm
going to say is follow the checks I mean
the bishop will come to E4
yes the only thing that black can do is
play F5
nothing else for it
and white should take his time
definitely because you have a choice you
know you can check on E6 or you can
check on D6
um is there a difference so I I would
just start with one random one and uh
work my way there so which one do we
want dark squares light squares
I think actually Queen D6 is the more
sensible check because it keeps tabs on
the H2 square and amazingly white
doesn't even have to only play with
checks black has zero threats so after
the king drops back I think the simple G
takes F5
okay I mean unless I'm missing something
could you also if there's no checks
checkmates you can just go with C1
everyone to the party what a move let's
have some fun look at this move I mean
this is unbelievable black says all
three pieces are aiming at the white
king and somehow White's got the
diagonal control over all of the
critical squares this bishop sacrificing
its life for the greater good and white
delivers the latter shower wins all of
flex pieces in the amount of Queen F7
yeah and
I guess Queen D4 for example yeah quiz
is over it is over and uh no way
okay nice spot by Queen D6 I hadn't I
was
nice to see that the queen is an
attacker and defend at the same time so
rooksy won the only move I can see is
Rook C2
that's a nice resource yeah
[Laughter]
yeah exactly wait a second don't do this
because there's like Queen E1 and Knight
F1 with a Perpetual gukesh not
hesitating he finds uh Bishop E5 F5 on
the board and okay now it is crunch time
how is he gonna check the king
so here Rook to be one just to finish
this line I think is the winning move
because you're forcing black to pursue
the rook and now you can give a check on
D7
if King F6 you get forked so you have to
go back to f8
and I think here
there must be some like combination of
checks
that forces the king onto a dark Square
I don't see it off the top of my head
though so maybe you can just check and
go Rook C1 here
no no you get mated what am I saying
so easy to forget about
that I mean
I don't see it off the top of my head
this is crazy
well you can get
oh and check yeah that's it
that's it
because at this point the King has no
shelter to seek either it steps onto
this diagonal or you allow liquidation
and The Rook disappears at the end of
the line wow what a line
oh
gosh I'm actually no and he finds Queen
D6 or horse yeah he understood exactly
what needs to do he has to keep the H2
Square covered and oh my gosh
what a turnaround and
we were kind of just thinking you know
how sorry we were for kikash you know
he's played so well in this tournament
and it just seems he's been a victim of
his own clock but now
he looks like he's on his way to
securing his very first victory
and uh the soul yeah
yeah it's it's a heartbreaking loss for
param and he will be furious I would not
like to be in his shoes when he
finishes this game
and goes to enjoy the rest day what a
miserable rest day it'll be because
Parham got one Miracle yesterday one
close call but he's not gonna survive a
second one in gukesh you have to feel
good for him to get this first win
however he got it when you're in bad
form listen you just got to take
whatever gifts are given to you and this
was a gift Parham he's gonna be kicking
himself for not taking enough time he
played that King G6 move in two or three
minutes and anytime you put your King on
a square like G6 anytime you put your
King on a compromise Square especially
on the same square uh on the same color
Square as the color of your opponent's
Bishop you have to be extra careful you
have to double check that one more time
and Parham failed to do that what a
ridiculous series of turnarounds we have
seen in so many games today
yeah it talk about of a tumultuous round
I mean expect the unexpected and boy I
mean are we seeing this kind kind of
blunders because the tiredness is
fatigue
making a mark and there we see Parham
put his King on F7 and I was looking at
Rook C1
probably now there's also a customer you
can put your Rook on B1 and you can
just shorten the variation yeah yeah
exactly sometimes it's funny when you
like you think no it is essential that I
repeat moves once before going for that
line Rook B1 Rook B2 but the key uh move
there is Bishop E4 to D5 it can be a
little bit
jarring to give up you know the pride of
your position the game-winning piece but
you just have to clear the Shrubbery
there on the king side and then tail the
king over to a dark square but good cash
is he's got 22 minutes and you know he
can take even 15 of them to just
quadruple check the winning line which
he's going to do he doesn't trust
himself at this point in the tournament
he has to make sure that there are no
hallucinations as he's knocking on the
door shocking victory over maksudlu
yeah and of course we have to remind
ourselves that Max sudlu actually held
seven hour gain yesterday against
Carolina
that obviously must play on your energy
reserves when you have such a draining
game I mean could the errors that we saw
that came with King G6 putting the Rook
on A2 could that have been as a result
of this game and also you mustn't forget
that we are closing in at the end of
this tournament we are in the second
half this is a grueling time control
very very long
mm-hmm is this the reason
or is it just simply he's out of shape
I think this must be the reason because
naksudu has had incredible moments this
tournament he said moments when he's
navigated successfully the complexities
of positions far more difficult to
assess and calculate than the one he had
here this was a relatively simple
position there weren't that many
tactical details you know there was the
queen takes G3 idea that he missed and
then the other idea he missed was the
concept of delivering smothered mate
with a knight in the queen I maintained
that Parham is such a strong player that
a fresh
Parham and energized Parham would have
taken that pawn really without a second
thought and would have found Knight F5
in let's say round one of this
tournament so fatigue not only is it
important it is Central to The Narrative
of this tournament who has the stamina
who has the reserves built up to keep
their legs churning as the rounds drag
on and the hours drag by and their brain
starts to turn into mush
yeah and uh I'm glad you kind of said
the brains also start to turn to Mush
because we mustn't forget as well the
players are actually doing prep in the
morning
so it's not just this six hours four
hours or eight hours of play it's also
maybe how many hours would you say
preparation do you do on average
I think at least two to three I mean
obviously there's prep before the
tournament but there's prep during the
tournament which is largely a review
their their team uh or their coaches
send them files they have to review and
process those files uh and those files
contain obviously the openings that they
predict will happen so the amount of
review and maintenance that happens
during the tournament is staggering I
think it's at least you know on the low
end two to three hours maybe an hour in
the evening and then two hours or so in
the morning before they head off to the
game
yeah and uh and also when it comes to
preparation these guys play Everything
how do you prepare against you know
someone like Magnus Carlsen Fabiana
caruana who when you check the databases
you're like okay they play E4 D4 C4 903
G3 anything goes and uh obviously you
can't cover all those lines because it's
just too much and you don't want to turn
up to the to the board brain dead
basically
I remember a very interesting interview
with I think it was cosimjana where he
was talking a little bit about how
openings are predicted and one of the
devices is to basically see where you
score the worst and that's you know it's
a pretty safe bet that your opponent is
going to see the same statistics that
you will but you know for gukesh
nothing has gone quite right this
tournament not his openings not his
middle games and uh this win is going to
come at such an opportune moment it's
going to allow him to press the reset
button and try to finish strong and we
have a very nice interview with gukesh
we caught up with him before uh the
tournament let's hear the Indian
phenom's thoughts on his chances and his
opponents
it's my first super tournament in
classical jazz so yeah with Magnus and
all the top guys it's super interesting
and
there are also a lot of youngsters so
it's going to be super fun I like like
crowded playing halls I just like uh my
Spectators watching watching my games it
just makes me want to do better if
someone is watching
since since the lockdown pandemic
started I
I've been working with engines a lot
yeah no I don't have any real problems
with adapting when it comes to chess
chess engines and I'm usually quite
quite interesting
as this my first really super tournament
I want to learn as much as possible and
to just fight it out and I look forward
to giving my best and hopefully I can
finish on the top
[Music]
kukesh of course burst onto the scene
with an 8 out of eight start at the last
Olympia talking about how he adapted his
style of training in a style of prep
Yobe you talked about that very astutely
earlier involving and incorporating
engines into his training for the first
time in his career that is a pretty
crazy thought that someone of kukesh's
age from his generation were the only
ones not to grow up using engine's
religiously
yeah I I know and uh it's really unheard
of because every generation brings
something new to chess and it could be
within the preparation methods the
training methods and uh gakesh somehow
strikes me a little bit as the old God I
mean even in that interview he said
there are a lot of youngsters in the
tournament that kind of to me implies
that he doesn't see himself as a
youngster
I think that's awesome he sees himself
as an old soul
and uh gukesh is like all the Indian
Juniors along with eragisi and nihal
Saran and others who are coming onto the
scene they're just so easy to root for
they're modest they're classy and
they're incredibly driven so Mukesh is
taken on F5 which is a perfectly
sufficient alternative to Rook B1 the
idea is very simple that pawn is going
to be part of the deadly machine which
is going to cost black his king king is
not long for the sport in the event of
Knight F1 Bishop D5 is an elementary
mating sequence it's amazing that Parham
doesn't have a single Square on the king
side that he can use as a springboard to
create any threats white doesn't even
have to rush he can win the game by
pushing the ape on and promoting it
that's how lost this is yovi and what a
crazy turnaround
yeah that's uh that's insane actually
because you would have thought that
there is a move somewhere somehow but uh
somehow these pieces are just completely
paralyzed they can't do a single active
move despite looking like there are
fearsome creatures but they're not and
uh interesting how looks can be
deceptive once again
chess is just such a crazy game I mean
the Mirage of of lacks pieces of the
activity is is very deceiving as you say
gukesh is going to win this game uh very
shortly Parham might resign here more
likely he'll play one or two more moves
and I think we should take this
opportunity first to go to the bird's
eye view because the other game is going
off the rails as well Jordan van Forest
has been winning for a while against
Eric icy on the strength of that
remarkable remarkable night sacrifice on
A7
and I think Arjun has done a great job
of creating counter play muddying the
waters he still is losing from an
objective standpoint but has Jordan's
clock continues to dwindle
uh I think Arjun has his share of
practical chances here
yeah
no not many but for starters and
something that is definitely giving him
some optimism is this Pawn on F3 I mean
perhaps it can capture the pawn on G2
and
there is a slight weakness to the white
king and okay it sounds a bit flippant
on me but when you are defending you
must always have a positive mindset and
it's always about those small gains
because otherwise if you're very
pessimistic about it then bad things
you're expecting bad things to happen
and bad things will happen because
basically you've manifested themselves
um yeah okay that was me preaching on
about the universe I've listened to too
many of these things
yeah you are what you think
it's true self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah
okay Arjun well
oddness is struggling I mean uh
the moves that I would kind of consider
is you know you have to initiate chaos
so I I am in favor of capturing the pawn
and then after that I'm just in favor of
throwing some pieces out I would really
like a night to get to G4 it's not
really maybe Knight to D3 or something
it's really speculative but then again
the position is ultimately lost so you
might as well
try something
yeah that Bishop on G1 though is such a
heroic defensive piece and I think
Jordan finding striking the balance
between aggressive moves on the queen
side and defensive moves on the king
side most likely I think unless Arjun
sees some crazy way to complicate The
Narrative on the king side is going to
be the move Rook E8 to A8
um if we can pull up an analysis board
and the problem isn't so much that the
Pawn's gonna be on B7 within two moves
it's more like it's gonna land on B7
within six or seven moves Jordan is in
no hurry he will play B6
and the more I look at this the more
hopeless this appears to me if F takes
G2 white can take really with either
piece even King takes G2 is fine but so
is Queen takes G2 and this blockade as
watertight as it seems is not going to
last very long first why it's going to
go Rook A5 then White's gonna go Rook C5
and The Rook is going to travel to in
deadly fashion to C7 and the moment
black moves the Knight away from C6 uh
insult to injury will be added with the
move E5 opening up a direct line of fire
against all three of Black's blockading
pieces no it would be I think this is on
the cusp of being over Arjun has taken
on G2
but that's not going to help us
I agree I'm kind of expecting the queen
just to go to B7 and you kind of killed
my ideas of moving the Black Knight
trying to initiate some kind of checks
because of course E5 is a killer move
um
I mean I'm also thinking that Jordan
might not even capture the porn with his
queen as I'm assuming he might actually
play King takes yeah porn in fact I
think it's
it's entirely safe there
um never assume it's a good philosophy
in life
yeah
I think he will because of course the
queen can come to F5 and give a check
I think it's a brilliant move King takes
you to and a great illustration that you
just you never want to make automatic
moves King takes you too and the key is
that the Rook guards the G6 Square
otherwise Queen G6 would have been uh
very nasty response
um
King tasty too yum
I mean okay so
I mean is there any way that's black can
just not immediately lose so after King
tastes you too
Queen moves to B7 to prevent
to prevent the porn Majesty
and the King has to take a step
backwards
probably relevant where
yeah building
and you
yeah
sure and do you have a big check
and uh unfortunately you have to do
something like that because
if you make a nothing kind of move
you're threatening Bishop takes Knight
mm-hmm
here and it's not even easy to make a
nothing kind of move
no I mean even
swing across to E6
ha What's the most clinical way though
because rookie 6 there is Rook to f8
so I'm trying to figure out how do you
how do you actually end the game
probably taking does win but I don't
like it after Rook takes you by The Rook
has too many Shenanigans going on so
probably white should be a little bit
more patient here
but how exactly maybe it's time for B6
maybe there's nothing wrong with that
move
yeah but what was wrong with rookie six
if we calm about it and just go rookie
six and just again once The Rook attacks
the queen we just go no problems oh oh
where does the queen go oh the queen
queen has to hold on to E4 I forgot
about that
okay
yeah in in these types of positions
often the top computer movies is some
sort of very quiet move that makes one
more decisive Improvement in the
position here it makes sense that the
queen will take on e4 with check so
tucking the king away on the side of the
board
is probably the safest way to ensure
that black doesn't have any Shenanigans
and if black Ozark f8 here then you have
left open the E6 Square for your queen
so patience in small doses is very
important when you're trying to convert
these types of positions smoothly but
this is what I would try if I margin
anything is possible you know whites
King is still pretty unstable
yeah it certainly is and uh as as we've
seen there is still chances to go wrong
um
and if you capture with the queen
on G2
is that gonna be easier on a practical
level
um I think the art well I was very
attracted to Rook B6 here at first
and he has taken to the king good stuff
from Jordan but here the queen would
have dropped back to it and somehow
black is holding the Ford and white is a
very hard time of over protecting the E4
Pawn the White Queen is tied down a
little bit to its defense let's go back
to the live board we've got the check on
F5 and Jordan confidently carrying out
the winning moves here Bishop D4 I think
is coming next
yeah yeah this is
almost over
yeah yeah
is there any other move other than
Bishop D4 is is this the case that
everything is going to win
um
I don't think there are too many other
moves because again rookie six there is
Rook of Fate so you need that that extra
bit you know you need a huff and puff on
the straw house to blow it down but you
need that big bad wolf to finally
uh re-emerge out of its state of Defense
of dormancy on G1 where it was
Faithfully assisting the king but now
the king is able to handle handle
himself nicely
and the pressure on that night
is just a little bit too much for black
to bear it's also important that the
check on E2 can always be buried with
Bishop to F2 and the Queen on F5 guards
all the potential checking squares
Arjun with King 2g8 as predicted
okay
Bishop D4 and Then followed by the very
clever King H3
that that is just too cool for school
yeah Bishop D forking H3 and then you'll
still have to find the crushing blow I
mean maybe rookie six in that position
already works
maybe at that point you take on E5
because Queen takes E4 it's not check
but I think Jordan is probably thinking
I'll cross that bridge when I get there
first let me tighten all the screws to
the maximum
and confident
he is and I I like this move because it
sets up a threat of a bishop takes
Knight
and uh only one move to stay alive
Queen A8 got it blockade the pawn with
the lady
can't do it with a rook because you drop
the Knight
in the meantime
yeah Pizza Parham is still thinking it's
a little bit too late
situation where your opponent has
blitzed into a losing position
and then when they've reached a losing
position
they've had like the longest think in
the world and you're like
it's a little too late
100 would have been better it would have
been better if you had thought before I
had this once and my opponent thought
for an hour and a half I didn't quite
know what to do there comes the stage
where it just feels like it's awkward
you're just like wandering around you
can't sit down on the board because
they're not moving and you're thinking
okay I have paced enough times around
the room
I've paced so long that it's probably
rude and I'm just resigned he's resigned
I mean that's it he's just he figures
that Jordan has so much time he's gonna
figure out king H3 I mean Jordan is a
former Tata Steel champion I think the
resignation is not really premature I
think it makes a lot of sense actually
he wants to put himself out of his
misery and make it to Pizza which I
think might close earlier on Sundays
yeah I I disagree somewhat
um I think that after Queen E8
let Jordan find King H3 and then you can
issue your resignation
because there was still a lot of tricks
on the board like for instance you can
go wrong with Bishop takes Knight and
after Rook takes it suddenly white is
the one that was on the back foot
a grid no I'll concede the point I think
Arjun is just so dejected by the State
of Affairs in the position the way the
game has gone I think it is admirable
that he sits at the board and discusses
it with his opponent rather than you
know storming off it is his second loss
in a row he must feel pretty miserable
going into the rest date but he is a
Class Act he's a professional
professionals they you know they swallow
the bitter pill and uh they behave in in
an adequate manner even when things
don't go well as the players discuss
uh the final fascinating stage of the
game what a brilliant display by Jordan
venforce let's tune into the ukesh game
because he is about to Checkmate his
opponent it is forced made in three and
what a beautiful mate it is
yeah
it is beautiful mate it is it absolutely
is and uh first of all he distracts the
night
away from the defense of the G3
Foursquare and we have another handshake
they the two games almost finished
simultaneously
and uh what an unbelievable game with so
many twists and turns it was just like a
movie kept us on our toes and kept us
entertained
oh my gosh and I think ukesh was
pointing at the G3 Square
and Parham he can't believe it he's like
what was I thinking with King G6 it's
the double whammy yovi of a missing what
looked like a win with Knight G3 back to
F5 but B not even going for the fourth
draw with Knight G3 Knight F1 and his
over ambitious play
his blindingly over ambitious flake
costs him in this game Parham is such a
fighter I mean it is a treat to watch
him play but sometimes when his form is
not ideal he can go too far one step too
far and a dejected Parham sets up the
pieces the first win for kukesh not how
he thought he'd get it but he will take
it
yeah oh oh they're looking at it they're
analyzing it yeah the answer is showing
him Knight F5
oh my gosh this is not gonna make farham
happier they're setting up that position
and not all of the pieces have been set
up but they remember the position
they're just using the pieces as cues
my gosh oh look at Parham
he's like what I missed that
F5 he's pointing to the F5 Square that's
where the Knight should have gone
I know and kakash we have to remember he
loves solving competit compositions in
fact he is a composer himself
and uh param just look at his face he
can't believe it that he did not seize
that opportunity
inconsolable and we have all been there
this is so immensely relatable that
feeling when your opponent tells you
about a missed opportunity when you come
back to the hotel room and check it on
the computer and you just tear your
heart out just thinking how could I
possibly have missed that why didn't I
take another three or five minutes
the course of the tournament
might have been completely different
there is Parham
oh
devastating
he just didn't see it but uh In fairness
backward night moves are actually the
hardest type to spot
I'm sure he was just thinking the Knight
is going to go to F1 I don't want a draw
I feel like I have the kind of position
where I can play for the win but param
just did not sense the danger and there
we concede the results of today see
three draws at the top but boy has been
another bloodthirsty round with four
decisive gains Jordan from Brown Forest
beating Arjun arag icy and Richard
Rapport snatching a point from pragnanda
who lost in on time and of course
while the headline match was Magnus
Carlsen absolutely crushing Fabiana
Corona with the black pieces and there
we have the final victory for cash
getting his first point getting onto the
scoreboard with with by defeating param
maxidlu
wow what around and how this changes the
tournament cross table let's take a look
at the uh standings we have Notre book
abdusatorov who maintains his in one
point lead despite drawing in this round
Anish Gary he had minor chances against
Vincent kymer wasn't able to win neither
was Wesley so who did also stand
slightly better throughout the game but
dingley ran was just too watertight and
Fabiano caruana slips from the ledge he
is now only on plus one he is together
with Magnus Carlson a tie for fourth
place unbelievable progress by the world
champion at only two rounds is turned
the tournament around completely he has
gone from 11th place to a tie for fourth
through seventh but he will need a
couple more wins if he wants to make a
serious bid to win this tournament for
the first time he has a fighting chance
and unfortunately for Vincent kymer and
for gukesh who despite the win still
sits tied for last place we will keep an
eye on these young players as they try
to climb their way out of the bottom of
the tournament standings maybe that win
will give lucash confidence let's review
this the pairings tomorrow is a rest day
so do not tune in at 8 AM and expect a
round this round will come your way on
Tuesday it'll be around 9 of 13 and Yogi
so many of these pairings catch my I
Notre back I think is a good chance with
the black pieces to beat a struggling
Vincent kymer we've got Magnus against
gukesh which we are going to keep a
close eye on as the world champion tries
to continue his Furious comeback among
many other fascinating pairings yeah
absolutely I mean so many catch my eye
and you know what we have come to expect
there is simply going to be fights on
every single board and I definitely
think there will be a lot of drama a lot
of action a lot of Thrills and a lot of
spills
there will indeed and that round is
coming your way again not tomorrow but
Tuesday at 8 00 a.m eastern time well
you're gonna have to wait two days for
the next round but the wait for
something else is over because after a
two-year Hiatus the pro chess league is
back the 2023 season begins with a
qualifier week starting February 1st
with 16 teams advancing into the main
season past PCL participants include
Magnus ding nepo Fabi ikaru and VL and
Anish so we could not be more excited
for the week's return and with over 100k
on the line it's looking like the 2023
season will be one for the history books
use x-glam PCL in the chat to learn all
about it well we've learned all about
Magnus Carlson's comeback skills and of
course about Notre back abducator off
skill as he maintains his one point lead
in the tournament and as we look at a
continuingly devastated Parham he simply
cannot believe it cash scores his first
win in the turn tournament
oh my gosh I can't believe what action
we just observed for five entire hours
but all good things yovi must come to an
end our withdrawal won't last long only
a day and a half but I'll pass it on to
you for your final thoughts on this
incredible round eight
yeah it's been incredible
I mean it's been insane at times
just been the heartbreaking but also the
most thrilling round of the whole
tournament we've had so much drama so
much tales of the unexpected and Daniel
you just made it a pleasure boy has it
been a ride and uh thank you so much
it's been so much fun
thank you I mean the feeling is is
mutual uh and I I just can't believe how
quickly the hours pass when you're
watching games that are this interesting
we'd like to thank everybody in the chat
we had over 40 000 uh at the peak
watching on Twitch and on YouTube we
know your weekends are busy you're
seeing friends you're having brunch but
we appreciate it when you take time out
of your day to watch this historic
fascinating 85th edition of the Tata
steel tournament and thank you also to
Bic our producer and our entire amazing
chess.com team for yet another Flawless
broadcast folks we will see you bright
and early on Tuesday at 5 00 a.m Pacific
8 A.M Eastern 2 p.m Central European
Time For What promises to be an
incredible round nine you will not want
to miss it but for now this was
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski an
international master yvanka houska from
the Tata steel chess tournament we will
see you on Tuesday so long
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]